foreign
welcome back to the devops week by
simply learn
so far we have mastered devops with
cloud in today's session we will be
learning the popular devops tools devops
is important because of its software
development and operations approach that
enables faster development of new
products and easier maintenance of
existing deployments this achievement is
only possible due to the most effective
and efficient tools of devops today we
will be learning the same so without
further Ado let's get started we shall
begin with having a basic understanding
of what devops is after that we shall
dive deeper and understand the basics of
devops its relevance in the present
scenario and several devops phases after
we note about devops we shall begin with
learning different devops Tools in
detail we should learn about git
followed by GitHub and in the process we
shall learn the various GitHub commands
second we shall see what Jenkins is
Jenkins Pipeline and how we install
Jenkins after that we shall move on to
Docker and check what Docker and Docker
container is all about and in the
process we shall see the process to
install docker
moving further we shall learn the basics
of kubernetes the difference between
kubernetes and Docker and kubernetes on
AWS the following tool in our list would
be puppet where we shall know what
puppet is why we use puppet and the
process to install it moving forward we
should learn about ansible its
installation process and what are the
benefits of using ansible
the last tool in our list is selenium
where we will learn about what selenium
is all about and all the selenium suit
tools followed by its installation
process
while we are learning all these tools we
shall understand them with a Hands-On
demo making the understand much more
effective and more accessible and
finally we will have a piece of deep
knowledge regarding devops and several
devops tools we shall look into some of
the most prominent devops interview
questions that will help you excel in
your forthcoming devops interviews so
before we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our YouTube channel and
don't forget to hit that Bell icon so
that you can never miss an update from
Simply learn now without further Ado
let's get started with our first topic
right from the start software
development comprise two different
departments the development team that
develops the plan designs and builds the
system from scratch and the operation
team for testing and implementation of
whatever is developed the operations
team gave the development team feedback
on any bugs that needed fixing and any
rework required invariably the
development team would be idle awaiting
feedback from the operations team this
undoubtedly extended timelines and
delayed the entire software development
cycle there would be instances where the
development team moves on to the next
project while the operations team
continues to provide feedback for the
previous code this meant weeks or even
months for the project to be closed and
final code to be developed now what if
the two departments came together and
worked in collaboration with each other
what if the wall of confusion was broken
and this is called the devops approach
the devops symbol resembles an infinity
sign suggesting that it is a continuous
process of improving efficiency and
constant activity the devops approach
makes companies adapt faster to updates
and development changes the teams can
now deliver quickly and the deployments
are more consistent and smooth though
there may be communication challenges
devops manages a streamlined flow
between the teams and makes the software
development process successful the
devops culture is implemented in several
phases with the help of several tools
let's have a look at these phases
the first phase is the planning phase
where the development team puts down a
plan keeping in mind the application
objectives that are to be delivered to
the customer
once the plan is made the coding Begins
the development team works on the same
code and different versions of the code
are stored into a repository with the
help of tools like git and merged when
required this process is called Version
Control the code is then made executable
with tools like Maven and Gradle in the
build stage
code is successfully built it is then
tested for any bugs or errors the most
popular tool for automation testing is
selenium
once the code is passed several manual
and automated tests we can say that it
is ready for deployment and is sent to
the operations team
the operations team now deploys the code
to the working environment the most
prominent tools used to automate these
phases are ansible Docker and kubernetes
after the deployment the product is
continuously monitored and nagios is one
of the top tools used to automate this
phase the feedback received after this
phase is sent back to the planning phase
and this is what forms the core of the
devops lifecycle that is the integration
phase Jenkins is the tool that sends the
code for building and testing if the
code passes the test it is sent for
deployment and this is referred to as
continuous integration there are many
Tech Giants and organizations that have
opted for the devops approach for
example Amazon Netflix Walmart Facebook
and Adobe Netflix introduced its online
streaming service in 2007. in 2014 it
was estimated that a downtime for about
an hour would cost Netflix two hundred
thousand dollars however now Netflix can
cope with such issues they opted for
devops in the most fantastic way Netflix
developed a tool called the Simeon Army
that continuously created bugs in the
environment without affecting the users
this chaos motivated the developers to
build a system that does not fall apart
when any such thing happens
so on this note here is a quiz for you
match the devops tool with the phase it
is used in a
B
C
[Music]
d none of the above
today more and more companies lean
towards automation with the aim of
reducing its delivery time and the gap
between its development and operations
teams to attain all of these there's
just one Gateway devops and if you're
also looking forward to doing the same
and Excel in devops check out Simply
learn's postgraduate program in devops
design in collaboration with Caltech
ctme the program can help you master
several in-demand devops skills and
tools like continuous integration and
delivery devops on cloud kubernetes
Docker and much more we hope you enjoyed
this video today we're going to
introduce you to devops we're going to
go through a number of key elements
today the first two will be reviewing
models that you're already probably
using for delivering Solutions into your
company and the most popular one is
waterfall followed by agile then we'll
look at devops and how devops differs
from the two models and how it also
borrows and leverages the best of those
models we'll go through each of the
phases that are used in typical devops
delivery and then the tools used within
those phases to really improve the
efficiencies within devops finally we'll
summarize the advantages that devops
brings to you and your teams so let's go
through waterfall so waterfall is a
traditional delivery model that's been
used for many decades for delivering
Solutions not just IT solutions and
digital Solutions but either way before
that it has its history it goes back to
World War II so waterfall is a model
that is used to capture requirements and
then Cascade each key deliverable
through a series of different stage
Gates that is used for building out the
solution so let's take you through each
of those stage Gates the first that you
may have done is requirements analysis
and this is where you sit down with the
actual client and you understand special
specifically what they actually do and
what they're looking for in the software
that you're going to build and then from
that requirements analysis you'll build
out a project plan so you have an
understanding of what the level of work
is needed to be able to be successful in
delivering the solution after that
you've got your plan then you start
doing the development and that means
that the programmers start coding out
their solution they build out their
applications to build out the websites
and this can take weeks or even months
to actually do all the work when you've
done your coding and development then
you send it to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against the
systems and databases that integrate
with your application you'll test it
against the actual code you'll do manual
testing you do UI testing and then after
you've delivered the solution you go
into maintenance mode which is just kind
of making sure that the application
keeps working there's any security risks
that you address those security risks
now the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage Gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your clients and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
challenge you then have is if you want
to add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
again so the client will come back to
you with a list of changes and then you
go back and you have to start your
programming and you have to then start
your testing process again and just
you're really adding in lots of
additional time into the project so
using the waterfall model companies have
soon come to realize that you know the
clients just aren't able to get their
feedback and quickly effectively it's
very expensive to make changes once the
teams have started working and the
requirements in today's digital world is
that Solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop where we're able
to get information to the clients and
the client can get Bank to the
development team much faster typically
when we're actually going through this
process we're looking at the engagement
cycle being about two weeks and so it's
much faster than the traditional
waterfall approach and so we can look at
each feedback loop as comprising of four
key elements we have the planning where
we actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
Sprint and that typically a Sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a Sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that Loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of Sprint 2 and the client says
hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for Sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product backlog and this will
be just a whole bunch of different
features and there may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple Sprints but when you go through
the Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your Sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the actual
Sprint team to ensure that everybody is
staying on track and if there's any
block because that those blockers are
being addressed effectively and
immediately the goal at the end of the
two weeks is to have a deliverable
product that you can put in front of the
customer and the customer can then do a
review the key advantages you have are
running a Sprint with agile is that the
client requirements are better
understood because the client is really
integrated into the scrum team they're
there all the time and the product is
delivered much faster than with a
traditional waterfall model you're
delivering features at the end of each
Sprint versus waiting weeks months or in
some cases years for a waterfall project
to be completed however there are also
some distinct disadvantages the product
itself really doesn't get tested in a
production environment it's only been
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
make the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
Sprint and actually working to build out
the features but then when they're done
at the end of their Sprint and they want
to do a release they kind of fling it
over the wall at the operations team and
then it's the operations team job to
actually install the software and make
sure that the environment is running in
a stable fashion that is really
difficult to do when you have the two
teams really not working together so
here we have is a breakdown of that
process with the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
deployment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
service but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developers test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an API that it doesn't exist
in production and so you have these
challenges that the operations team are
constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works so this is where devops
really comes in and let's dig into how
devops which is developers and operators
working together is the key for
successful continuous delivery so devops
is as an evolution of the agile model
the agile model really is great for
Gathering requirements and for
developing and testing out your
Solutions and what we want to be able to
do is kind of address that challenge and
that gap between the Ops Team and the
dev team and so with devops what we're
doing is bringing together the
operations team and the development team
into a single team and they are able to
then work more seamlessly together
because they are integrated to be able
to build out solutions that are being
tested in a production-like environment
so that when we actually deploy we know
that the code itself will work the
operations team is then able to focus on
what they're really good at which is
analyzing the production environment and
being able to provide feedback to the
developers on what is being successful
so we're able to make adjustments in our
code that is based on data so let's step
through the different phases of a devops
team so typically you'll see that the
devops team will actually have eight
phases now this is somewhat similar to
Agile and what I'd like to point out at
the time is that again agile and devops
are very closely related that agile and
devops are closely related delivery
models that you can use with devops it's
really just extending that model with
the key phases that we have here so
let's step through each of these key
phases so the first phase is planning
and this is where we actually sit down
with a business team and we go through
and understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
Agile is that the code is actually start
coding but they typically they'll start
using tools such as git which is a
distributed Version Control software it
makes it easier for developers to all be
working on the same code base rather
than bits of the code that is rather
than them working on bits of the code
that they are responsible for so the
goal with using tools such as git is
that each developer always has the
current and latest version of the code
you then use tools such as Maven and
Gradle as a way to consistently build
out your environment and then we also
use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving to Awards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as ansible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things I want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using Jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire devops tool set this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience so
let's step through this devops process
so we go through and we have our
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting tests it
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to Agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your Sprint Cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
Google Google any given day will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great
videos on YouTube that you can find out
on how their devops teams work Netflix
is also a similar environment now what's
interesting with Netflix is that Netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and Netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on Smart TVs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for Netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from Netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be where you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver a software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to Waterfall complexity of
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment now you're improving
the communication between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted hello this is Matthew
from Simply learn so what are we going
to cover today so we're going to
introduce the concept of Version Control
that you will use within your devops
environment then we'll talk about the
different tools that are available in a
distributed Version Control System we'll
highlight a product called get which is
typically used for Version Control today
and you'll also go through what are the
differences between git and GitHub you
may have used GitHub in the past or
other products like getlab and we'll
explain what are the differences between
get and get and services such as GitHub
and gitlab will break out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like and how do you go through and
create forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you in get finally I'll take you through
a demo on how you can actually run git
yourself and in this instance sense use
the software of git against a public
service such as GitHub all right let's
talk a little bit about Version Control
Systems so you may have already been
using a virtual control system within
your environment today you may have used
tools such as Microsoft's team
Foundation services but essentially the
use of a Version Control System allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
Version Control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to that so um there will
be the version one changes that you had
then the person would then later on
check out that code and then be a
version two and added to that code and
so you keep adding on versions of that
code the bottom line is that eventually
you'll have people being able to use
your code and that your code will be
stored in a centralized location however
the charge you're running is that it's
very difficult for large groups to work
simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a VCS system a Version
Control System demonstrate that you're
able to store multiple versions of a
solution in a single repository now
let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional Version Control Systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed Version Control so in a
distributed Version Control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed Version Control System
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed VCS server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS environment is
get now you may remember that we
actually covered get in a previous video
and we'll reference that video for you
so we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment that local environment can
be updated manually and then
periodically pushed out to the git
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you've made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so you'll
get repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get get
is a distributed Version Control tool
used for source code management so
GitHub is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
clients to that server remote Hub server
now git is used to track the changes of
the source code and allows large teams
to work simultaneously with each other
it supports a non-linear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about git versus GitHub so
get is a software tool whereas GitHub is
a service and I'll show you how those
two look in a moment you install the
software tool for get locally on your
system whereas GitHub because it is a
service it's actually hosted on a
website git is actually the software
that used to manage different versions
of source code whereas GitHub is used to
have a copy of the local repository
stored on the service on the website
itself git provides command line tools
that allow you to interact with your
files whereas get help has a graphical
interface that allows you to check in
and check out files so let me just show
you the two tools here so here I am at
the git website and this is the website
you would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do Version Control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
Hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with GitHub there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to GitHub gitlab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as Microsoft
Visual Studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of Visual Studio team Services
also provides this same ability but
GitHub it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where we can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to GitHub and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment I'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact I think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on GitHub at the moment that
number is probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project I would certainly encourage you
to start at GitHub to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open
source project that they want to share
that's already available and in GitHub
certainly if you're doing anything with
um Azure you'll find that there are
thousands forty five thousand Azure
projects currently being worked on
interestingly enough GitHub was recently
acquired by Microsoft and Microsoft is
fully embracing open source Technologies
so that's essentially the difference
between get and GitHub one is a piece of
software and that's get and one is a
service that supports the ability of
using the software and that's GitHub so
let's dig deeper into the actual git
architecture itself so the working
directory is the folder where you are
currently working on your get project
and we'll do a demo later on where you
can actually see how we can actually
simulate each of these steps so you
start off with your working directory
where you store your files and then you
add your files to a staging area where
you are getting ready to commit your
files back to the main branch on your
git project you want to push out all of
your changes to a local repository after
you've made your change changes and
these will commit those files and get
them ready for synchronization with the
service and will then push your services
out to the remote repository an example
of a remote repository would be GitHub
later when you want to update your code
before you write any more code you would
pull the latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure the that Aid the code remains at
very high quality and B that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the call code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available in git so let's talk
about about forking and cloning and kit
so both of these terms are quite old
terms when it comes to development but
forking is certainly a term that goes
way way back long before we had
distributed CVS systems such as the ones
that we're using with get to Fork a
piece of software is a particularly open
source project you would take the
project and create a copy of that
project and but then you would then
associate a new team and new people
around that project so it becomes a
separate project in entirety a clone and
this is important when it comes to
working with get a clone is identical
with the same teams and same structuring
as the main project itself so when you
download the code you're downloading
exact copy of that code with all the
same security and access rights as the
main code and then you can then check
that code back in and potentially your
code because it is identical could
potentially become the mainline code in
the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merge into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the main code with get
you can also add collaborators that can
work on the project which is essential
for projects where particularly where
you have large teams and this works
really well when you have product teams
where the teams themselves are
self-empowered you can do a concept
what's called branching and get and so
say for instance you are working on a
new feature that new feature and the
main version of the project have to
still work simultaneously so what you
can do is you can create a branch of
your code so you can actually work on
the new feature whereas the rest of the
team continue to work on the main branch
of the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in Services software the teams
working on from a remote server and git
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and re-establish a new
start from the project so you may be
working a project where there have been
many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody that's working on a separate
Branch will not be able to Branch their
code back into the mainline Branch so
going through the process of a get
rebase essentially allows you to create
a new start for where you're working on
your project so let's go through forks
and clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and Fork
the code that you're working on so this
is the scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate Fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you actually go and you
can take the version of the mainline
Branch but then you take it completely
offline into a local repository for you
to be able to work from and you can take
the mainline code and you can then work
on a local version of the code separate
from the mainland Branch it's now a
separate Fork collaborators is the
ability to have team members working on
a project together so if you know if
someone is working on a piece of code
and they see some errors in the code
that you've created none of us are
perfect at writing code I know I've
certainly made errors in my code it's
great to have other team members that
have your bag and can come in and check
and see what they can do to improve the
code so to do that you have to then add
them as a collaborator now you would do
that in GitHub you can give them
permission within GitHub itself and it's
really easy to do supervisual interface
allows you to do the work quickly and
easily and depending on the type of
permissions you want to give them
sometimes it can be very limited
permissions it may be just to be able to
read the files sometimes it's being able
to go in and make all the changes you
can go through all the different
permission settings on GitHub to
actually see what you can do but you'll
be able to make changes so that people
can actually have access to your
repository and then you as a team can
then start working together on the same
code let's step through branching and
git so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that Branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master Branch at a
later point in time now the benefit
effort you have here is that by default
we're all working on the master Branch
so we always have the latest code the
circles that we have here on the screen
show various different commits that have
been made so we can keep track of the
master branch and then the branches that
have come off which have the new
features and there can be many branches
in git so git keeps you the new features
you're working on in separate branches
until you're ready to merge them back in
with the main branch so let's talk a
little bit about that merge process so
you're starting with the master branch
which is the blue line here and then
here we have a separate parallel branch
which has the new features so if we're
to look at this process the base commit
of feature B is the branch f is what's
going to merge back into the master
branch and it has to be said there can
be so many Divergent branches but
eventually you want to have everything
think merge back into the master Branch
let's step through git rebase so again
we have a summer situation where we have
a branch that's being worked in parallel
to the master branch and we want to do a
get rebase so we're at stage C and what
we've decided is that we want to reset
the project so that everything from here
on out with along the master branch is
the standard product however this means
that any work that's been done in
parallel as a separate Branch we'll be
adding in new features along this new
rebased environment now the benefit you
have by going through the rebase process
is that you're reducing the amount of
storage space that's required for when
you have so many branches it's a great
way to just reduce your total footprint
for your entire project so get rebase is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for facing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase and you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new Master Branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single Master Branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote suppose our two developers
working together on application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers they're always working on the
layer latest code so you could pull any
changes that you have made to your
thought remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that command in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some of the commands
that we have in git so get init
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive get ads one or more
files to your staging area get commit
Dash M commit message is a commit
changes to the git command commits
changes to head up to the git command
commits changes to your local staging
area get status checks the status of
your current repository and lists the
files you have changed get lock provides
a list of all the commits made on your
current branch get stiff the user
changes that you've made to the file so
you can actually have files next to each
other you can actually see the
differences between the two files get
push origin Branch name so the name of
your branch command will push the branch
to the remote repository so that others
can use it this is what you do at the
end of your project git config Dash
Global username will tell get Who You
Are by configuring the author name we'll
go through that in a moment git config
Global user email will tell get the
author of by the email ID get clone
creates a get repository copy from a
remote Source get remote at origin
server connects the local repository to
the remote server and adds the server to
be able to push to it git branch and
then the branch name will create a new
Branch for you to create a new feature
that you may be working on get checkout
and then the branch name will allow you
to switch from one branch to another
branch git merge Branch name Will merge
a branch into the active Branch so if
you're working on a new feature you're
going to merge that into the main branch
a get rebate will reapply commits on top
of another base tip and get rebase or
reapply commits on top of another base
tip and these are just some of the
popular git commands there are some more
but you can certainly dig into those as
you're working through using get so
let's go ahead and run a demo using get
so now we are going to do a demo using
get on our local machine and GitHub as
the remote repository for this to work
I'm going to be using a couple of tools
first I'll have the deck open as we've
been using up to this point now the
second is I'm going to have my terminal
window also available and let me bring
that over so you can actually see this
and the terminal window is actually
running git bash as the software in the
background which you'll need to download
and install you can also run get batch
locally on your Windows computer as well
and in addition I'll also have the
GitHub repository that we're using for
simply learn and already set up and
ready to go all right so let's get
started so the first thing we want to do
is create a local repository so let's go
ahead and do exactly that so the local
repository is going to reside in my
development folder that I have on my
local computer and for me to be able to
do that I need to create a drive in that
folder so I'm going to go ahead and
change the directory so I'm actually
going to be in that folder before I
actually create make the new folder so
I'm going to go ahead and change
directory
and now I'm in the development directory
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and let's go ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
I'm going to move my cursor so that I'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that I'm in the hello world
folder I can now initialize this folder
as a git Repository
so I'm going to use the get command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my Hello
World folder that I've created and
you'll now see that we have a hidden
folder in there which is called dot gate
now we expand that we can actually see
all of the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so that we
can see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users Matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt in our folder so
here is our hello world folder and I'm
going to go ahead and using my text
editor which happens to be Sublime
I'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there the text hello
world and I'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if I go to my Hello World folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt file
actually in the folder what's
interesting is if I select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and select
foreign
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the get status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders haven't been
committed and what we can now do is we
can go and actually add the readme file
so let's go ahead I'm just going to
select at git add so the git command is
ADD
[Music]
readme.txt so that then adds that file
into our main project and we want to
then commit those files into the main
repositories history and so it's that do
that we'll hit the the get command
commit and we'll do a message in that
commit and this one will be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and I can change this so we
can go hello get
get is a very popular
Version Control solution
and we'll
we'll save that now what we can do is we
can actually go and see if we have made
differences to the readme text so to do
that we'll use the diff command forget
so we do get
div
and it gives us two releases the first
is what the original text was which is
hello world and then what we have
afterwards is what is now the new text
in green which has replaced the original
text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on GitHub we already have one so what
we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from GitHub with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do Dash and it's
going to be a
globaluser.name and we'll put in our
username that we use for GitHub and this
instance we're using the simply learn
Dash
GitHub account name
and under the GitHub account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we called the
repository hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local GitHub account with the remote
hello world.get account and we do that
by using this command from get which is
our remote connection and so let's go
ahead and type that in open this up so
we can see the whole thing so we can
type in git remote add origin https
GitHub
.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub and you have to get this
typed in correctly when you're typing in
the location hello dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit git push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote GitHub so I'm just
going to bring up my terminal window
again and so let's select get remote add
origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub slash
hello dash world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master Gish
so get
push origin
master and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to GitHub now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and Fork a project from GitHub and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the fork tool that's actually available
on GitHub let me show you where that is
located and here is our branching tool
it's actually changed more recently with
a new UI interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that to our account using
the forks new HTTP URL address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
Fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now I'm
actually logged in with the default
primary count for this project so I
can't actually Fork the project as I'm
working on the main branch however if I
come in with a separate ID and here I am
I have a different ID and so I'm
actually pretending I'm somebody else I
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
created the fork
so you want to say clone or download
with this and so this is the I select
it'll actually give me the web address I
can actually show you what that looks
like I'll open up my text editor
that's the correct
I guess that is correct
so I'm going to copy that
and
I can Fork the project locally and clone
it locally I can change the directory so
I can create a new directory that I'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that file so I can
now actually have multiple versions of
the same code running on my computer
I can then go into default content and
use the patchwork command
20 so I can create a copy of that code
that we've just created and we call it
that's a clone and we can create a new
folder that we're actually putting the
work in and we could for whatever reason
we wanted to we could call this where
photo Patchwork and that would be maybe
a new feature and then we can then paste
in the URL of the new directory that has
the forked work in it and now at this
point we've now pulled in and created a
clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
Fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in that separate
branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin Branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to GitHub and we
can actually come in and add in our
collaborators
and we'll do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
GitHub name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes and merge it into the
master Branch now to do that you would
create a folder and then that folder in
this instance would be called test we
would then move our cursor into the
folder called test and then initialize
that folder so let's go ahead and do
that so let's call and create a new
folder and we're going to first of all
change our root folder and we're going
to go to
development
and I'm going to create a new folder
call it test and we're going to move
into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
call this one test one
and then we're going to do file save as
and this one's gonna be test
two
and now we're going to commit those
files
get add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git commit
m
files
that's it
make sure I'm in the right folder here I
don't think I was
and now that I'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and get commit
and it's gone ahead and added those
files and so we can see the two files
that were created have been added into
the master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
branch and call this one get branch
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file three
into file save as we'll call this one
test three dot text
and we'll go ahead and add
that file I need to get add
test three Dot txt
and we're going to move from the master
Branch to the test run branch
kit
check
out test underscore
branch
I switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the in that Branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do git merge test underscore
branch
as well we've already updated everything
so that's good so otherwise it would
tell us what we would be merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all my merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from must to Branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore branch
and we can modify the files the test3
file that we took out
and pull that file up
and we can
now modify
right
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in and we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and now
we've seen as the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
the workers kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future so let's switch to it back to our
test branch
which I think we're actually on we're
going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
four
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into our
branch that we're working on so we're
going to go and select get add Dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit Dash a dash m
adding
two new files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch them to our Master
Branch we want to rebase the master
so we do git rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
and we can go
get
check out
Master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then continue
through and rebase the test branch and
then list all the files that are all in
the same area
so let's go get rebase
test and just go
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
welcome to git commands my name is
chidanand and I am with the simply learn
team I'm going to cover a few essential
git commands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it I begin by
installing a git bash or the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once I'm done with configuring the
git client I'm going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once I'm
happy with my local changes I'm going to
commit few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration I plan to use
github.com which is a cloud hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually I
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the get distributed Version Control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed Version Control tool of
recent times and like any other
distributed Version Control tool it
allows us to perform various Version
Control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with Git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like Windows
all flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
this repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git come commands would work perfectly
well so you can bring up a small
repository and you can work with your
repository using this git bash but what
does it take for you to share this
repository with another user who has
also got gitpash installed on his system
this is where you would need something
called as a git server so for user one
or one user to share his repository with
another user he would need to
collaborate using something called as a
git server so in the present Market
there are a bunch of git servers which
are popularly available some of them are
free some of them come with a cost
because they are licensed a bunch of
these servers that I can think of are
GitHub which is one of the most popular
kit servers that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github.com and then the
other one is an Enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this GitHub Enterprise
servers wherein they buy these servers
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is bitbucket this is from
the famous atlassian products and it
integrates very well with all other
atlassian products like jiram in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username name and my password and I'm
going to use a free account so whatever
reposit is that I'm going to put up on
this server is all public by default so
I will register Myself by using my
username or my email ID and my password
so this set of authentication is also
referred to as https authentication so
in order for me to share my repository
with say user 2. the first thing that I
got to do is have an access to a git
server where both user 1 and user 2 are
set up so once I have that I can push my
repository onto this server and provide
right kind of access so that user 2 or
the other developer whoever wishes to
collaborate with me on this repository
can use his credentials as long as is
registered properly on the git server he
can use the credentials and pull down
this repository and work for this
repository so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as SSH authentication as many
of you would know SSH means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while when
creative keys I will be asked for a
passphrase I need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then I take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever I'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as I remember my passphrase correctly I
can authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and SSH are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my GitHub credential to
connect to my GitHub server and push my
repositories out there let me now go
ahead and find my git bash for my
windows so that I can go ahead and
install it so I just type in get client
for windows open up a browser and type
in for this the first one that I find is
a GUI tool I don't need this GUI client
I need this one so this is the git
client or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I may want to
use git from Windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open SSH that's fine
looks good looks good no I don't want
any of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the version that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good it's a git help
all right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iPhone Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also a global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up it to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
getting to the syllable all right as of
now this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment okay so let me create a
repository out of this how do I create a
repository of this is pretty simple I
just run and get init command
when I say kit init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it it
was an empty repository so it initiates
an empty repository in this particular
folder but all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see that something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say get in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
Branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with the
git in it and then I have not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository so I
use a touch command touch is a Linux
command it kind of creates this
particular folder if all you're not
comfortable with the file creation by
this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so I create a file called touch
master.txt and open up in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm going to write inside this
I save this and I come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this tell you there's no
commit set you're in the master Branch
there is an untracked file and this
shows up in thread it also gives you all
the command that is supposed to be run
so if at all you want to add this file
you would say git add and the name of
the file and then you're going to commit
it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
comment this file if at all that's what
I want to do so let me do that
I'll do a kit commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the get status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if I to error I run the git
log command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
foreign
so what I did I modified the older file
that existed I also added a new file to
my repository now if I run the get
status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which was an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with a message that says this is
my second commit
all right
if I do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice I'm doing all these git commands
without really connecting it to any git
server I don't need any network
connection for doing any of these things
I can keep on doing more and more git
commands and run git commands the way I
want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I log into my GitHub account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and push it
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs one is the https
URL and the other one is the SSH URL as
of now we do not have any SSH keys that
is set up so let me use this https URL
to connect my local repository with the
repository on this server
so I've done all these things I already
have the repositories set up all that I
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server URL
so this would be the command that I need
to copy
but essentially links or ads and origin
with the URL of the git server I just
copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I am all set
I've got two comments in my repository
I'm done with all the changes so let me
try to push my repository onto the
server the command for doing it for the
first time is git push hyphen U this is
for linking the Upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
a branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which I have
registered
I would say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text fit all I see
the commits they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was the line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we have
committed the change we have pushed it
so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the SSH
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of SSH keys and ensuring
that I connect to the GitHub server
using the SSH mechanism so for doing
that I need to First create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is SSH Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I'm
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I would click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now a check for my passphrase
let me enter my passphrase I hope I
remember it correctly
all right
triggered I have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I will
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
create a repository
so a random readme file with some
content in it gets created and I can see
there are two URLs to this repository
https and SSH so this time let me copy
the SSH URL so that I will use this URL
to clone this repository on the server
from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first repository earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text some text file I'm going
to put in here yes definitely you will
not find that file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
and save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely won't track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with a message
this is my first
comment for the second repo
I given some particular message
and this time around since I cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more I'll
then push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it puts the content onto the server
let me see if the contents have come in
here okay wonderful I had only one
commit now I see my second comment so
what was added as a part of the second
comment it says a new file was added all
this line that never existed got added
this is the second file the content
exactly what I pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the change changes that has happened in
the repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
files that got added all this with one
particular message get status will give
you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the comment
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server git clone and the URL of the
server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however my perspective
of Version Control tool you will have to
be really cautious about the chain that
you're gonna do in case the changes are
pretty local none of the developers or
none of the other users who are
collaborating with you would be affected
by this change you are good to go ahead
and make this change however if your
repository has been pushed to the server
and you're trying to modify something
from history this would have a very bad
or adverse effect on all the other users
would be using it you need to be really
cautious while running these commands in
case your repository contents are local
if you've not pushed your changes to
your repository and if at all you made
some changes to the repository maybe to
fix a defect or to include a new feature
and you missed few things you can go
over and modify this with some of these
commands let's say I have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all I look at the logs of these I
have the commit histories which are like
this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I added another file in C3
I've also added some file in C4 I made
some changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I
have added another file called M4 now
this is my commit history now let's say
I made these two commits but possibly I
want to Club them together along with
some other changes because whatever
changes I did did not really fix things
the way I expected you to fix so there
is a git command called git reset this
would allow me to go back in history to
go back to any of the snapshot get rid
of all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two comments would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the commit that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is 7 C2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to C5 it's gone back
to C3 now what happened to the cheats
that were there as a part of C4 and C5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of C4 was
some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a new
file got M4 got added if at all I do a
git status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the top most
comment that exists as of now c4 and C5
have been current rate of but the
changes that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say one new file that was missed out
I make this change I go to a get status
all these files are still there I would
send it add dot I was a git
m
C4
rewriting history
and I do a git
blog
pretty
there you go so C1 C2 C3 still existed
and whatever was a part of C4 and C5 the
older ones I have gotten rid of this
along with those old changes I also
added a new file I made some changes and
it was able to commit it now if you look
at my git history it's all nice and
clean however do this activity only when
you don't push your git repository to
the server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and is not being pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a git server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so here's got C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the C3 which is a wrong thing to do
and possibly you know he could have done
a better job of fixing this in in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these commits
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
comment to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this comic
possibly gets rid of the C3 instead of
going back in history it actually is
taking your git history ahead but as a
part of this comment you're undoing some
part of the work that was done as a part
of C3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are you're using this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C to our
another file in C3 I've added one more
file and in C4 I made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all I see the
contents of the git folder it contains
M1 M2 M3 and M4 and
let's say looking at the previous use
case that I mentioned I may want to get
rid of this particular comment I want to
get rid of the C3 which is nothing but
I've added a file called M3 dot text but
I added it by mistake I need a better
way of fixing it possibly I'll look at
it later on but for now I don't want
this particular commit and the changes
that were made as a part of that commit
to exist so the better way to do that is
using the git revert command so git
reward and the commit ID whatever I want
to revert so if I want to revert this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit revert at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
face this
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit It undoes
Whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention a message
which is why this window is showing up
but that message is good for me I say
write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
M3 was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because git deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool in most of
the Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
Git You just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right I'm navigating to this folder
and let me create a repository here
initial as a repository a DOT get folder
is created without any files in it so
let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees dot text
play on
has over 3K employees
I just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
first comment
so if I do a git log
I see only one commit and there are two
files here you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
and this created a branch but I don't
see any changes in the folder structure
or in the file that exists here I've
just created this Branch so if at all I
do a git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and
Baylor Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
plr Branch I've actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because I've
created a branch from my base branch
which is the master branch and when I
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to Bangalore branch
so I will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I see
notepad address dot text
I'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in
some arteries
I would say Bangalore
that is the content of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I would sync it add
Dot
I would say kit commit hyphen m
angalore branch
commit
all right if you see this now I have an
address dot text which is there only in
the Bangalore branch that I'm presently
on now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout Master Branch if you remember
when I forged out or when I created a
new Branch from the master Branch I
didn't have this address dot text in it
so let me go back to git git checkout
Master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you were in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address dot text
file appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever I am switching to Bangalore
Branch I see this address dot text when
I go back to my master Branch I don't
say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise so the name of the
folder needs to be exactly this one so
let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository get Branch
demo this is what I'm going to put in as
a description I would say public I don't
want any readme files in it because I
already have a repository I will just
say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is the SSH URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it here
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master Branch so I
would say git
push hyphen U origin master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says new Bunch Master is created so if I
go back to my server and it will refresh
if you see it is only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if we get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if at all
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this under stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangle Branch to come back into
my master Branch so if I go to click
checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address DOT
type this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge Bangalore Branch
changes and where will it merge it will
merge it into the current brands that
I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
will see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
foreign
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the bank
Advantage commit so with this change let
me push this change onto the server as
well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I mean two branches
the princess's Master even if I'm in
master plan I should see this address
dot text that is there even if I'm in
the Bangalore Branch the content is all
same because we immersed these two
branches now that I've merged this
Branch I don't need this Branch anymore
so I would go ahead and delete this
locally as well as push it under the
server so that it gets deleted from the
server as well so delete Branch locally
the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch only thing you need to ensure is
that you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say get brands and I'm presently
in the master Branch so I can go ahead
and delete the other Branch so get
Branch hyphen D Bangalore branch
all right this got rid of our Pandora
Branch locally
if that's all I don't get Branch iPhone
V it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this Branch would still
exist on the server because Server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done we need to
specifically push our changes onto the
server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen hyphen delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in it go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular Branch today we're going
to Deep dive into what Jenkins is and
how it improves your devops continuous
integration environments
so this is what we're going to be
covering in this session we're going to
cover what life is like before using
Jenkins and the issues that Jenkins
specifically addresses then we'll get
into what Jenkins is about and how it
applies to continuous integration and
the other continuous integration tools
that you need in your devops team then
specifically we'll Deep dive into
features of Jenkins and the Jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using Jenkins
today to actually transform how their it
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before Jenkins
let's see this scenario I think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
a developer may be based in India you
may we have another developer that's
based in the Philippines and you may
have another team lead that's based in
the UK and another development team
that's based in North America so you're
all working at different times and you
have different amounts of code going
into the code repository There's issues
with the integration and you're kind of
running into a situation that we'd like
to call development how where things
just aren't working out and there's just
lots of delays being added into the
project and the bugs just keep mounting
up the bottom line is the project is
delayed and in the past what we would
have to do is we'd have to wait until
the entire software code was built and
tested and before we could even begin
checking for errors and this just really
kind of increased the amount of problems
that you'd have in your project the
actual process of delivering software
was slow there was no way that you could
actually iterate on your software and
you just ended up with just a big
headache with teams pointing fingers at
each other and blaming each other so
let's jump into Jenkins and see what
Jenkins is and how it can address these
problems so Jenkins is a product that
comes out of the concept of continuous
integration that you may have heard of
as power developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code Jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment so there
are two ways in which you can do
continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous so
the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
Legacy approach to building out
Solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly Bell and the way
that our 90 builds would work and
operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created and that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to commit
our changes into our source code but we
can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification Services into the build
environment so you're always running
Cycles to test against your code this is
the power that Jenkins provides in
continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created now if on the continuous
integration server a test isn't passed
then that code gets sent back to the
developer and the developer can then
make their changes it allows the
developer to actually do a couple of
things it allows the developer not to
break the build and we all don't want to
break the builds that are being created
but it also allows the developer not to
actually have to run all of the tests
locally on their computer write tests
particularly if you have a large number
of tests can take up a lot of time so if
you can push that service up to another
environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your device love her
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be Beyond just the standard CI test
so maybe there's a Code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it's
simply just works
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here are open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly so
bamboo is a continuous integration tool
that specifically runs multiple builds
in parallel for faster compilation so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with and and Maven and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and buildbot is that
open source product for you again it's
an open source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you can
actually go in and you can actually get
the environment up and running and you
can then test for and build your
environment and create your releases
very quickly so buildbot's also written
in Python and it does support parallel
execution jobs across multiple platforms
if you're working specifically on Java
projects that need to be built and test
then Apache Gump is the tool for you it
makes all of those projects really easy
it makes all the Java projects easier
for you to be able to test with API
level and functionality level testing so
one of the popular places to actually
store code and create a versioning of
your code is GitHub and it's a service
that's available on the web just
recently acquired by Microsoft if you
are storing your projects in GitHub then
you'll be able to use Travis continuous
integration or Travis CI and it's a tool
design specifically for hosted GitHub
projects and so finally we're covering
Jenkins and Jenkins is a central tool
for automation for all of your projects
now when you're working with Jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called Hudson Hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became Jenkins and it was
acquired by Oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind
um Hudson was a little concerned about
the direction that Oracle May
potentially go with Hudson and so they
created a hard Fork of Hudson that they
renamed Jenkins and Jenkins has now
become that open source project it is
one of the most popular and continuously
contributed projects that's available as
open source so you're always getting new
features being added to it it's a tool
that really becomes the center for your
CI environment so let's jump into some
of those really great features that are
available available in Jenkins so
Jenkins itself is really comprised of
five key areas around easy installation
easy configuration plugins extensibility
and distribution so as I mentioned for
the easy installation Jenkins is a
self-contained Java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS and Unix you can even run it on Linux
it really isn't too bad to set up it
used to be much harder than it is today
the setup process has really improved
the web interface makes it really easy
for you to check for any errors in
addition you have great built-in help
one of the things that makes tools like
Jenkins really powerful for developers
and consumers integration teams in your
devops teams as a whole when you have
plugins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product Jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
Center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly checking out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plugin architecture
Jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure Jenkins to fit in your
environment it's almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending Jenkins not creating a
custom version of Jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
Foundation remains as the court Jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of Jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of Jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core Foundation the
distribution and the nature of Jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your CI environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops so let's
jump into the standard Jenkins pipeline
so when you're doing development you
start off and you're coding away on your
computer the first thing you have to do
when you're working in the Jenkins
pipeline is to actually commit your code
now as a developer this is something
that you're already doing or least you
should be doing you're committing your
code to a git server or to an SVN server
or Sim similar type of service so in
this instance you'll be using Jenkins as
the place for you to commit your code
Jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that Jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the Jenkins environment assuming
everything past the the tests you can
then get everything placed in a stage
and release ready environment within
Jenkins and finally getting ready to
deploy or deliver your code to a
production environment Jenkins is going
to be the tool that helps you with your
server environment to be able to deploy
your code to the production environment
and the result is that you're able to
move from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or
going through a nightly build you're
looking at being able to commit your
code and go through this testing process
and release process continuously as an
example companies Etsy will release up
to 50 different versions of their
website every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within Jenkins it allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections so on the left hand
side of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then Jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and we'll
run tests against it it'll use a build
server such as mavin to actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that Jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that if feedback is sent
right back to the developers so that
they can then change their code so that
the build environment can run
effectively the final stage is to
actually execute specific test scripts
and these test scripts can be written in
selenium amp so it's probably good to
mention here that both mavin and
selenium are plugins that run in the
Jenkins environment so before we were
talking about how Jenkins can be
extended with plugins Maven and selenium
are just two very popular examples of
how you can extend the Jenkins
environment the goal to go through this
whole process again it's an automated
process is to get your code from the
developer to the production server as
quickly as possible have it fully tested
and have no errors so it's probably
important at this point to mention uh
one piece of information around the
Jenkins environment that if you have
different code builds that need to be
managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed Jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of Jenkins for that to be able
to happen so this talk a little bit
about the Master Slave architecture
within Jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the Master Slave
architecture within Jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and that remote source code
repository could be GitHub or it could
be a team Foundation services or the new
Azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the Jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that Master
environment can then push out to
multiple other Jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so Jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server Master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used Jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario um over
the last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex Hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as Tesla where
they are creating uh software to manage
their cars we see the same thing with
companies such as General Motors with
their OnStar program and Ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company what this means
though is that the software within these
cars is becoming more complex and
requires more testing to allow more
capabilities and enhancements to be
added to the core software so vosh is a
company that specifically ran into this
problem and their challenge was that
they wanted to be able to streamline the
increase increasingly complex Automotive
software by adopting continuous
integration and continuous delivery best
practices with the goal of being able to
delight and exceed the customer
expectations of the end user so Bosch
has actually used Cloud bees which is
the Enterprise Jenkins environment so to
be able to reduce the number of manual
steps such as building deploying and
testing Bosch has introduced the use of
cloud bees from Jenkins and this is part
of the Enterprise Jenkins platform it
has significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software development cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because Jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took three days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same three-day
process and reduced it to less than
three hours that is significant
large-scale deployments are now kept on
track and have expert support and there
is clear visibility and transparency
across the whole operations through
using the Jenkins tools Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic Word file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt
differently on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control C and then bring down this
prompt and your Jenkins server would be
down other older versions of Jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a Java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so Jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it does doesn't
matter how we're going to bring up your
Jenkins instance the way we're going to
operate Jenkins is all going to be very
very same or similar one with the subtle
changes in terms of user Administration
if at all you're launching it through
any other web server which will take
care of the user Administration
otherwise all the commands are all the
configuration or the way in which I'm
going to run this demo it is going to be
same across any of these installations
all right so the prerequisites for
running Jenkins as I mentioned earlier
Jenkins is nothing but a simple web
application that is written in Java so
all that it needs is Java preferably jdk
1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the recommended
RAM for running Jenkins and also like
any other open source tool sets when you
install jdk ensure that you set in the
environment variable Java home to point
to the right directory this is something
very specific to jdk but for any other
open source tools that you've installed
there is always a preferred environment
variable that you got to set in which is
specific to that particular tool that
you're going to use this is a generic
thing that is there for you know for any
other open source projects because the
way it open source projects discover
themselves is using this environment
variables so as a general practice or a
good practice always set this
environment variables accordingly so I
already have jdk 1.8 installed on my
system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.heat
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so
I'm not going to do the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I have just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
alright one other thing to do is ensure
that in case you want to run Java or
Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java hyphen version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am going to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch Jenkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file with a generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of these things
so I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes into the
Jenkins configuration SQL and program
files is good for me yeah this is where
all my destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with this I don't want to change
this I would just say go ahead and click
installation
foreign
so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins Launches
on the port 8080. so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I will have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugin that is
required for Jenkins in order to run
properly so Jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you this is a
good combination to kind of begin with
and mind you at this moment Jenkins
needs lots of bandwidth in terms of
network so in case your your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail and these plugins are all
you know all available on openly or or
mirrored sites and sometimes some of
them may be down so do not worry in case
some of these plugins kind of fail to
install you'll get an option to kind of
retry installing them but just ensure
that you know at least most or 1995 of
all these plugins are installed without
any problems let me pause the video here
for a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I get a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name
all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you would kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line UI is
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkins
know at any point in time how many jobs
or how many threads can be run you can
you can kind of visualize it like a
thread that can be run on this
particular instance as a thumb rule if
at all you're on a single core system
number of executors two should be good
enough in case at any point in time if
there are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have there to
open up no need to panic because they
will all get queued up and eventually
Jenkins will get to running those jobs
just bear in mind that whenever a new
job kind of you know gets triggered the
CPU usage and the memory usage in terms
of the disk right is very high on the
Jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are with a valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
an example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this a demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install jdk on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git a git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it will crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
manage Jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
with hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them so as of now it Jenkins
is configured to use its own database
assuming that you are running in an
organization you would probably want to
have a you know some sort of an ad or an
ldap server using which you would want
to control access to your Jenkins
repository rather Jenkins tool so you'd
specify your ldap server details the
root DN password or the manager DN and
the manager password and all these
details in case you want to connect your
Jenkins instance with your ldap or ad or
any of the authentication servers that
you have in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so I will
just say you know first job this is good
for me I just give a name for my job I
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me I don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once I save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you would see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in the job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering uh hook or a web hook kind
of a triggering later on but for now
what I want to do I want to ensure that
this job that I'm going to put in would
be automatically triggered on its own
let's say every minute I want this job
to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me to really
mean every minute oh yeah I want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do I check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not I just don't do
anything I'll just wait for a minute and
if at all everything goes well Jenkins
would automatically trigger my second
job in a minute's time from now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific role I can
have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
all right so first things first let me
go ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into manage Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advanced as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins all right so let me come
back to available and I would want to
search for my role based access plugin
so I would say search for role and hit
enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I have
installed the role based access plugin I
would need to just set it up and check
that you know I would go ahead and
create some roles and ensure that I
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configure configure Global Security
is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options you click
hover over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these uh you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job I'll
check you know have read only access to
the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a role I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I would say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer one to this
particular Global Rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have gen games but I don't see a
new item I can't trigger a new job I
can't do anything I see these jobs
however I don't think so I'll be able to
start this job I don't have the
permission set for that the maximum I
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and I added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role so that the
developers don't get to configure any of
the jobs because the Jenkins instance is
owned by a cure person he doesn't want
to give developer any administrative
rights so the rights that he set out by
creating a developer role and anybody
who is tagged any user who is tagged as
a part of this developer role would get
the same kind of permissions and this
permissions can be you know fine-grained
it can be a Project Specific permissions
as well but for now I just demonstrated
the high level permission that I had set
in let me quickly log out of this user
and get back as the admin user because I
need to continue with my demo with the
developer role that was created I have
very very less privileges one of the
reasons for Jenkins being so popular as
I mentioned earlier is the bunch of
plugins that is provided by users or
Community users who don't charge any
money for these plugins but it's got
plugins for connecting anything and
everything so if you can navigate to or
if you can find Jenkins plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to bitbucket
white bucket is one of the git servers
has so many plugins that is available
okay so bottom line Jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of Jenkins for you to connect or
for in order to connect Jenkins with any
of the containers or any of the other
tool sets you would need the plugins if
you want to connect or you want to build
a repository which has got Java and
Maven you would need to install Maven
and GDK on your Jenkins instance if at
all you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build can build a
job on Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube
and get sonar Cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in Jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello.java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just
at the Java file how do I build my Java
file how do I compile my Java file I
just say Java C and the name of my class
file which is hello.java and how do I
run my Java file I would say Java and
hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here it says get job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN perforce
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
this particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I gonna do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay get job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the main GitHub repository all right
so this was the same program that was
here and Jenkins on our behalf went over
all the way to GitHub pulled this
repository from there and then you know
it brought it down to my local system or
my Jenkins instance it compiled it and
it ran this particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and it
can you can build a war file and even
deploy it into some other server for now
what we're going to use Maven is just
for building and creating a package out
of this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the
Tomcat all right so download Maven first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this my one there are
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know Maven again is is
one open source build tool so you'll
have to set in a few configurations and
set up the path so mvn hyphen iPhone
version if I specify this after setting
my path my one should work and if at all
I Echo M2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my one it is always set here so once
you unzip my one just set this m to home
variable to the directory where you
unzip your Maven also just set the path
to this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your Maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I've just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system
so I'm just gonna show you where to
download this from
this way you download Tomcat server and
um I already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
I just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration I have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost Tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080 since we
already have our Jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let Tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port Clash
so what I've done I have configured
Tomcat to use a different port so if I
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be allowed
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go tomk itself is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is up and running
that sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
mbn
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of Market repository is
uh this guy https URL
okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
setup will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now I need to grab this particular
War file and then I would need to deploy
it into Tomcat server again I would need
a small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I will see this web application War file
that is already built so I would need to
configure this plugin to pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the Tomcat
server for deploying onto the Tomcat
server I will use the credentials of the
user that I've created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a packet that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that my Tomcat server yes
configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed okay so
let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deploy credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so take the war file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
MN web app use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like a deployment went ahead
perfectly well so
the context path was in my web app so if
I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own so let's step paper into what Docker
actually is so Docker is a tool which is
used to automate the deployment of
applications in a lightweight container
so the application can work efficiently
in different environments now it's
important to note the container is
actually a software package that
consists of all the dependencies
required to run the application so
multiple containers can run on the same
Hardware the containers are maintained
in isolated environments they're highly
productive and they're quick and easy to
configure so let's take an example of
what doctor is by using a house that may
be rented for someone using Airbnb so in
the house there are three rooms and only
one cupboard and kitchen and the problem
we have is that none of the guests are
really ready to share the cupboard and
kitchen because every individual has a
different preference when it comes to
how the cupboard should be stocked and
how the kitchen should be used this is
very similar to how we run software
applications today each of the
applications could end up using
different Frameworks so you may have a
framework such as rails perfect and
flask and you may want to have them
running for different applications for
different situations this is where
Docker will help you run the
applications with the suitable
Frameworks so let's go back to our
Airbnb example so we have three rooms
and a kitchen and cupboard how do we
resolve this issue well we put a kitchen
and cupboard in each room we can do the
same thing for computers Docker provides
the suitable Frameworks for each
different application and since every
application has a framework with a
suitable version this space can also
then be utilized for putting in software
and applications that are long and since
every application has its own framework
and suitable version the area that we
had previously stored for a framework
can be used for something else now we
can create a new application and this
instance a fourth application that uses
its own resources you know what with
these kinds of abilities to be able to
free up space on the computer it's no
wonder Docker is the right choice so
let's take a closer look to how Docker
actually works so when we look at Docker
and we call something Docker we're
actually referring to the base engine
which actually is installed on the host
machine that has all the different
components that run your Docker
environment and if we look at the image
on the left hand side of the screen
you'll see see that Docker has a client
server relationship there's a client
installed on the hardware there is a
client that contains the docker product
and then there is a server which
controls how that Docker client is
created the communication that goes back
and forth to be able to share the
knowledge on that Docker client
relationship it's done through a rest
API this is fantastic news because that
means that you can actually interface
and program that API so we look here in
the animation we see that the docker
client is constantly communicating back
to the server information about the
infrastructure and it's using this rest
API as that Communication channel the
docker server then will check out the
requests and the interaction necessary
for it to be the docker Daemon which
runs on the server itself well then
check out the interaction and the
necessary operating system pieces needed
to be able to run the container okay so
that's just an overview view of the
docker engine which is probably where
you're going to spend most of your time
but there are some other components that
form the infrastructure for Docker let's
dig into those a little bit deeper as
well so what we're going to do now is
break out the four main components that
comprise of the docker environment the
four components are as follows the
docker clients and server which we've
already done a deeper dive on Docker
images Docker containers and the docker
registry so if we look at the structure
that we have here on the left hand side
you see the relationship between the
docker client and the docker server and
then we have the rest API in between now
if we start digging into that rest API
particularly the relationship with the
docker Daemon on the server we actually
have our other elements that form the
different components of the docker
ecosystem so the docker client is
accessed from your terminal window so if
you are using Windows this can be
Powershell on Mac it's going to be your
terminal window and it allows you to run
the docker Daemon and the registry
service when you have your terminal
window open so you can actually use your
terminal window to create instructions
on how to build and run your Docker
images and containers if we look at the
images part of our registry here we
actually see that the image is really
just a template with the instructions
used for creating the containers which
you use within Docker the docker image
is built using a file called the docker
file and then once you've created that
Docker file you'll store that image in
the docker Hub or registry and that
allows other people to be able to access
the same structure of a Docker
environment that you've created the
syntax of creating the image is fairly
simple it's something that you'll be
able to get your arms around very
quickly and essentially what you're
doing is you're creating the option of a
new container you're identifying what
the image will look like what are the
come months and needed and the arguments
for within those commands and once
you've done that you have a definition
for what your image will look like so if
we look here at what the container
itself looks like is that the container
is a standalone executable package which
includes applications and their
dependencies it's the instructions for
what your environment will look like so
you can be consistent in how that
environment is shared between multiple
developers testing units and other
people within your devops team now the
thing that's great about working with
Docker is that it's so lightweight that
you can actually run multiple Docker
containers in the same infrastructure
and share the same operating system this
is its strength it allows you to be able
to create those multiple environments
that you need for multiple projects that
you're working on interestingly though
within each container that container
creates an isolated area for the
applications to run so while you can run
multiple containers in an infrastructure
each of those containers are completely
isolated they're protected so that you
can actually control how your Solutions
work there now as a team you may start
off with one or two developers on your
team but when a project starts becoming
more important and you start adding in
more people to your team you may have 15
people that are offshore you may have 10
people that are local you may have 15
Consultants that are working on your
project you have a need for each of
those developers or each person on your
team to have access to that Docker image
and to get access to that image we use
the docker registry which is an Open
Source server-side service for hosting
and distributing the images that you
have to find you can also use Docker
itself as its own default registry and
Docker Hub now something that has to be
bear in mind though is that for publicly
shared images you may want to have your
own private images in which case you
would do that through your own Regis
history so once again public
repositories can be used to host the
docker images which can be accessed by
anyone and I really encourage you to go
out to Docker and see the other Docker
images that have been created because
there may be tools there that you can
use to speed up your own development
environments now you will also get to a
point where you start creating
environments that are very specific to
the solutions that you are building and
when you get to that point you'll likely
want to create a private repository so
you're not sharing that knowledge with
the world in general now the way in
which you connect with the docker
registry is through simple pull and push
commands that you run through terminal
window to be able to get the latest
information so if you want to be able to
build your own container what you'll
start doing is using the pull commands
to actually pull the image from the
docker repository and the command line
for that is fairly simple in terminal
window you would write Docker pull and
then you put in the image name and any
tags associated with that image and use
the command pause so in your terminal
window you would actually use a simple
line of command once you've actually
connected to your Docker environment and
that command will be Docker pull with
the image name and any Associated tags
around that image what that will then do
is pull the image from the docker
repository whether that's a public
repository or a private one now in
Reverse if you want to be able to update
the docker image with new information
you do a push command where you take the
script that you've written about the
docker container that you define and
push it to the repository and as you can
imagine the commands for that are also
fairly simple in terminal window you
would write Docker push the image name
any Associated tags and then that would
then push that image to the docker
repository again either a public or a
private repository so if we recap the
docker file creates a Docker image
that's using the build commands a Docker
image then contains all the information
necessary for you to be able to execute
the project using the docker image any
user can run the code in order to create
a Docker container and once a Docker
image is built it's uploaded to a
registry or to a Docker Hub where it can
be shared across your entire team and
from the docker Hub users can get access
to the docker image and build their own
new containers I'm Julie from Simply
learn and I'll be taking you through the
installation process for Docker so now
let's begin with the demo we'll be
installing Docker on an Ubuntu system so
this is my system I just opened the
terminal so the first thing you can
start with is removing any Docker
installation that you probably already
have present in your system if you want
to start from scratch so this is the
command to do so sudo app get removed
docker
dock engine Docker dot IO enter your
password
and Docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install Docker
once again before that I'll just clear
my screen
okay so before I install Docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo app get update
great so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type Docker install
and that by itself will give you the
command you can use to install docker so
as it says here sudo apt install doc dot
IO is a command that we will need to
execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the sudo
snap install Docker so sudo apt install
Docker dot IO first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have sudo snap
install Docker so snap install Docker
installs a newly created snap package
there are basically some other
dependencies for Docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire Docker i o it
will take some time
great so our Docker is installed the
next thing we do as I mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install talk
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for Docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for Docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is Docker
version
and as you can see Docker version
17.12.1 CE has been installed next thing
we do is we pull an image from the
docker Hub so Docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a Docker image which
is present on the docker Hub Docker Hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker image hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
is pseudo Docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository this is present on our system
currently so the image has been
successfully pulled onto the system and
this means that a Docker is working now
we'll try out another command
pseudo Docker PS minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so I did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for Docker PS
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running State you can
simply execute sudo Docker PS
pseudo docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running State and with that we come to
an end of our Docker installation this
is Matthew from Simply learn in this
presentation we're going to go through a
number of key things we're going to
compare Docker versus traditional
virtual machines and what are the
differences and why you'd want to choose
Docker over a virtual environment we'll
go through the advantages of working
with Docker and the structure and how
you would build out a Docker environment
and during that structure we'll dig
through the components and the advanced
components within Docker at the end of
the presentation we'll go through some
basic commands and then show you how
those basic commands can be used in a
live demo so with all that said let's
get started so let's first we'll compare
Docker with a traditional virtual
machine so here we have the architecture
on the left and right of a traditional
Virtual Machine versus a Docker
environment and there are some things
that you'll probably see immediately
that are big differences one is that the
virtual environment has hypervisor layer
whereas the docker environment has a
Docker engine layer and then in addition
to that there are additional layers
within the virtual machine each of these
really start compounding and creating
very significant differences between a
Docker environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with Docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and the is just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
Docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build Solutions in a
Docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
the bit up time for a virtual machine is
fairly slow in comparison to the boot up
time for a Docker environment which is
almost instantaneous so we look at these
in a little bit more detail one of the
other challenges that you have with a
virtual machine is that if you have
unused memory within the environment you
cannot reallocate that memory so if you
set up an environment that has nine gigs
of memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with Docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that Docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment can
lead to instability and performance
issues whereas Docker is designed to run
multiple containers in the same
environment and actually gets better the
more containers you run in that hosted
single Docker engine portability issues
with a virtual machine is the software
can work on one machine but then when
you move that VM to another machine
suddenly some of the software won't work
because there are some dependencies that
haven't been inherited correctly whereas
Docker itself is designed specifically
to be able to run across multiple
environments and to be deployed very
easily across systems and again the
actual boot up time for a VM it just
takes a long time you're talking about
minutes in contrast to the milliseconds
that it takes for Docker environment to
boot up so let's dig into what Docker
actually is and what allows for these
great performance improvements over a
traditional VM environment so Docker
itself is an OS virtualized software
platform and it allows it organizations
to really easily create deploy and run
applications as what are called Docker
containers that have all the
dependencies within that container very
easily and the container itself is
really just a very lightweight package
that has all the instructions and
dependencies such as Frameworks
libraries bins Etc all within that
container and that container itself can
then be moved from environment to
environment very easily if we to look in
our devops life cycle the place where
Docker really shines is in deployments
because when you're actually at the
point of deploying Your solution you
want to be able to guarantee that the
code that has been tested will actually
work in the production environment but
in addition to that what we have to find
is that when you're actually building
the code and you're actually testing the
code having a container running the
solution at those stages is also a
really good plus because what happens is
that the people building the code and
testing the code are able to validate
their work in the same environment that
would be used for the production
environment so really you can use Docker
in multiple stages within your devops
cycle but it becomes really valuable in
the deployment stage so let's look at
some of the key advantages that you have
with Docker some things that we've
already covered is that you can do rapid
deployments and you can do it really
fast the environment itself is highly
portable and was designed for that in
mind the efficiencies that you'll see
will allow you to run multiple Docker
containers in a single environment as
compared to more traditional VM
environments the configuration itself
can be scripted through a language
called yaml which allows you to be able
to write out and describe the docker
environment that you want to create this
in turn allows you to be able to scale
your environment very very quickly but
with all of these advantages probably
the one that is most critical to the
type of work that we're doing today is
security you have to ensure that the
environment you are running is a highly
secure but highly scalable environment
and I'm very pleased to say that Docker
takes security very seriously so you'll
see it as one of the key tenants for the
actual architecture of the system that
you're implementing so let's look at how
Docker actually works within your
environment so Docker works there is a
what's called a Docker engine the docker
engine is really comprised of two key
elements that you have a server and a
client and the communication via the two
is via rest API the server as you can
imagine has the instructions that are
communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do the
the connection between the client and
the server the communication is via a
rest API on older systems you can take
advantage of the docker toolbox which
allows you to go ahead and control the
docker engine the docker machine Docker
compose and kitomatic so let's now go
into what the actual root components
though of Docker are so let's have a
look at those key components there are
four components that we're going to go
through we have the docker clients and
server we have Docker images we have the
docker registry and the docker container
we're going to step through each of
these one by one so let's look at the
docker clients and server first so the
docker clients and server is a command
line instructed solution where you would
use terminal on your Mac or command line
on your PC or Linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker Daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest API so you can do Sim communicate
such as a Docker pool command which
would send an instruction to the Daemon
which would then form the interaction of
pulling in the correct components such
as an image or container or registry to
the docker client the docker Daemon
itself is actually a service which
actually performs all sorts of operating
and Performance Services and as you'd
imagine the docker Daemon is constantly
listing across the rest API to see if it
needs to perform any specific requests
if you want to trigger and start the
whole process what you want to do is use
the command dockered within your Docker
Daemon and that will start all of your
performances and then you have a Docker
host which actually runs the docker
Damon and registry itself so now let's
look into the actual structure of a
Docker image so a Docker image itself is
a template which contains instructions
for the docker container and that
template is written with a language
called yaml and yaml stands for yet
another markup language it's very easy
to learn the docker image itself is
built within that yaml file and then
hosted as a file in the docket registry
the image is really comprised of several
key layers and you start with your base
layer which will typically have your
base image in this instance is your base
operating system such as Ubuntu and then
you then have layer of dependencies
above that this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your Docker file so let's
just go through and look at what one of
those in sets of instructions would look
like so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from pull run and
then command so what does that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down the from creates a layer which is
based on Ubuntu and then what we're
doing is we're adding in files from the
docker repository onto That Base command
that base layer and then what we want to
be able to do is then say okay what are
the wrong commands so we can actually
then build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of the
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your Docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a Docker image and so
the base layer are in read-only format
the layers can be combined in a union
file system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on right the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a Docker container the
docker environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make Docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for Docker it's just this
constant ability to be able to keep
improving the efficiency within the
actual system itself all right so let's
go on to item number three which is the
docker registry so the docker registry
itself is the place where you would host
and distribute the different types of
images that you have created or you want
to be used within your environment the
actual repository itself is just a
collection of Docker images and those
Docker images are built on instructions
that you would write with yaml and are
very easily stored and shared and what
you can actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual Docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see is we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifying how we actually
use it to actually create the actual
little container itself one of the
things you can do to as start off how
you would manage a registry is you can
actually use the publicly accessible
Docker Hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you'd
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect the registry are both push and
pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and has been shared so again
pull command and it pulls and retrieves
a Docker image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you've
created and push it to the red registry
whether it's Docker Hub or whether it's
your own private registry and allow it
to be shared across your teams some key
did you knows in Docker registry
deleting a repository is not a
reversible action so if you delete a
repository it's gone so let's go into
the final stage here which is the actual
Docker container itself so the docker
container itself
um is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
bundled together so it gets all the
instructions that you would have for the
solution that you're looking to run it's
actually really lightweight and again
this is because of the redundancy that's
built into how you structure the
container and the container itself is
then inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does run
completely in isolation so you're able
to share it very easily from group to
group and you are guaranteed that even
if you are running a container it's not
going to be impacted by any host Os
peculiarities or unique setups as you
would have in a VM or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a Docker
environment they can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vamp
you would have a defined amount of
memory for each VM environment the
challenge you start running into though
is that you can't share that memory
whereas with Docker you can easily share
the memory and for a single environment
across multiple containers the actual
container is built using Docker images
and the commands to actually run those
images is a run command so let's
actually go through a basic structure of
how you would run a Docker image so you
go into terminal window and you would
write a Docker run redis and then it
would run a container called redis so
we're going to go in and if you don't
have the redis image locally installed
it will then pull it from the registry
then the new Docker container redis will
be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so light lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within VMS and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and the
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so if you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within the docker
environment and we're going to look at
two Advanced components one is Docker
compose and the second is Docker swarm
so let's look at Docker compose Docker
compose is really designed for running
multiple containers as a single service
and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with with each
other as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the composed environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like Docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
Apache server with my SQL database and
you need to create a additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately and this is where you would
write a set of files using Docker
compose to be able to help balance out
that demand
so let's now look at Docker swarm so
Docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
Docker environments within a single
platform so what you actually are
looking at doing is within your Docker
swarm is we're treating each node as a
Docker Daemon and we're actually having
an API that's interacting with each of
those nodes there are two types of nodes
that you're going to be getting
comfortable working with one is the
manager node and the second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node is the one sending out the
instructions to all of the worker nodes
but there is a two-way communication
that is happening the communication
allows for the manager node to be able
to manage the instructions and then
listen to receive updates from the
working node so if anything happens
within this environment the major node
can react and adjust the architecture of
the worker node so it's always in sync
it was really great for a large scaled
environments so finally let's go through
what are some of the basic commands
you'd with use within Docker and once
we've gone through all these basic
commands we'll actually show you a demo
of how you'd actually use them as well
so if we're going to go in probably the
first command is to install the docker
and so if you have yam installed you
just do yum install Docker and you'll
install Docker onto your computer to
start the docker Daemon is you want to
do system CTL start Docker the command
to remove a Docker image as Docker RMI
and then the image ID itself and that's
not the image name that's the actual
alphanumeric ID number that you want to
grab the command line to download a new
image is Docker pull and then the name
of the image you'd want to pull and by
default you're going to be pulling from
the docker default registry that will
then connect to your Docker demon and
download the images from that registry
calendar the command line to run an
image is Docker run and then the image
ID and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from Docker Hub then
we would have a Docker pull and then the
image name and colon It's tag to pull
build an image from a Docker file you
would do Docker build Dash T and then
the image name and colon tag to shut
down the container you do Docker stop
container ID the access for running a
container is Docker exec it container ID
bash so we've gone through all the
different commands but let's actually
see how they would actually look and
we're going to go ahead and do a demo so
welcome to this demo where we're going
to go ahead and put together all of the
different commands that we have outlined
in the presentation for Docker first is
just to list all of the docker images
that we have so we do sudo Docker images
and we enter in our password
and this will Now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a Docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull and then the name
of the image that we want to pull which
is going to be MySQL
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest MySQL
command MySQL image that we have so it's
now going to head and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you can see the others have completed
just wait for this last file to download
almost there once that's done we're
going to go ahead and do is we'll
actually run the docking container and
create a new container using the image
that we've just downloaded but we have
to wait for this to download First
all right so the image has been pulled
from Docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
Docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run Dash D
Ash p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon 80
colon 80.
and then put in my SQL
call on latest so we have the latest
version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new Docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do sudo docker
PS
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within Docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do PS
Dash a and yes there we are we can see
that we do have our new container we
want to see called latest and it was
created 36 seconds ago but it's in the
exited mode so what we have to do is we
have to change that status so it's
actually running
so let's change that to running state
mesh
[Music]
and that's now going to be in the root
and we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the docking containers we
should see it is now an active container
pseudo docker
start
and then we'll start the scene and then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
State excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container so we're going to
do is checklist of images that we have
and so sudo Docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sqls listed and what we want to
do is delete my SQL and to do that we're
going to type in sudo Docker RM Dash F
image MySQL
foreign
that command and what we'll find is
the image now there's no such image oh
okay so what we actually have to do is
we have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
that's exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image ID as well
however if an image is running and
active we have to kill that image first
so I'm going to go ahead and we're going
to select the image ID we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to
so we do sudo Docker kill
and kill SL and that will kill the
container
and now we'll see that the container has
gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image gone
with image ID the boom easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
so here we are we've listed all of the
uh containers and they're all gone so
let's go into the next exercise final
exercise which is to actually create a
batch image and we can do a batch HTTP
image so let's go ahead and write that
out so it's going to be Docker run
Dash did
dash dash name
white is that's going to be the name of
this HTTP service Dash p
ad 8080 colon 80 Dash V
open quotes
dollar sign PWD
close quotes
colon slash USR
slash local
slash
apache2 slash htd dogs
httpd semicolon 2.4
let me run that
put in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or to see what's ports
are running so let's do pseudo images
and see which ports are being used
because so the the port or the name
hasn't been put in correctly so pseudo
Docker images
PS
pseudo docker PS Dash a
and yep that's Port 80 there
so clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because I think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila there we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser and we'll type in as
soon as Firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running today we're going to cover
what is a Docker container why you would
want to consider using it in your devops
environment so let's have a look at what
we have in our current environment so
today when you actually have your
standard machine you have the
infrastructure you have the host
operating system and you have your
applications and then when you create a
virtual environment what you're actually
doing is you're actually creating
virtual machines but those virtual
machines actually are now sitting within
a hypervisor solution that sits still on
top of your host operating system and
infrastructure and with a Docker engine
what we're able to do is we're able to
actually reduce significantly the
different elements that you would
normally have within a virtualized
environment so we're able to get rid of
the the bins and the so we're able to
get rid of the guest OS and we're able
to eliminate the hyper supervisor
environment and this is really important
as we actually start working and
creating environments that are
consistent because we want to be able to
make it so it's really easy and stable
for the environment that you have within
your Dev and opt environment now
critical is getting rid of that
hypervisor element it's just a lot of
overhead so let's have a look at a
container as an example so here we
actually have a couple of examples on
the right hand side we have different
containers we have one container that's
running Apache Tomcat in it with Java a
second container is running SQL server
and microsoft.net environment the third
container is running python with mySQL
these are all running just fine within
the docker engine and sitting on top of
a host OS which could be Linux it really
could be any host OS within a consistent
infrastructure and you're able to have a
solution that can be shared easily
amongst your teams so let's have a look
at an example that you'd have today if a
company is doing a traditional Java
application so you have your developers
working in JBoss on his system and he's
coding away and he has to get that code
over to a test and now what will happen
is that tester will then typically in
your traditional environment then have
to install JBoss on their machine and
get everything running and cool and
hopefully set up identically to the
developer chances are they probably
won't have it exactly the same but
they're trying to get it as close as
possible and then at some point you want
to be able to test this within your
production environment so you send it
over to a system administrator who would
then also have to install JBoss on their
environment as well yeah this just seems
to be a whole lot of duplication so why
go through the problem of installing
JBoss three times and this is where
things get really interesting because
the challenge you have today is that
it's very difficult to almost impossible
to have identical environments if you're
just installing software locally on
devices the developer has probably got a
whole bunch of development software that
could be conflicting with the JBoss
environment the tester has similar
testing software but probably doesn't
have all the development software and
certainly the system administrator won't
have all the tools of the developer and
tester have their own tools and so what
you want to be able to do is kind of get
away from The Challenge you have of
having to do local installations on
three different computers and in
addition what you see is that this uses
up a lot of effort because when you're
having to install software over and over
again you just keep repeating doing
really basic foundational challenges so
this is where Docker comes in and Docker
is the tool that allows you to be able
to share environments from one group to
another group without having to install
software locally on a device you install
all of the code into your Docker
container and simply share the container
so in this presentation we're going to
go through a few things we're going to
cover what Docker actually is and then
we're going to dig into the actual
architecture of Docker and kind of go
through what Docker container is and how
to create a Docker container and then
we'll go out through the benefits of
using Docker containers and then the
commands and finalize everything out
with a brief demo so what is darker so
Docker is as you'd expect because all
the software that we cover in this
series is an open source solution and it
is a container solution that allows you
to be able to containerize all of the
necessary files and applications needed
to run the solution you're building so
you can share it from different people
in your team whether it's a developer a
tester or system administrator and this
allows you to have a consistent
environment from one group to the next
so let's kind of dig into the
architecture so you understand why
Docker runs effectively so the docker
architecture itself is built up of two
key elements there is the docker client
and then there is a rest API connection
to a Docker demon which actually hosts
the entire environment within the docker
host and the docker demon you have your
different containers and each one has a
link to a Docker registry the docker
client itself is a rest service so as
you'd expect a rest API and that sends
command line to the docker Daemon
through a terminal window or command
line interface window and we'll go
through some of these demos later on so
you can actually see how you can
actually interact with Docker the docker
Dem then checks the request against
um the docking components and then
performs the service that you're
requesting now the docker image itself
all it really is a collection of
instructions used to create container
and again this is consistent with all
the devops tools that we have the devops
tools that we're looking to use
throughout this series of videos are all
environments that can be scripted and
this is really important because it
allows you to be able to duplicate and
scale the environments that you want to
be able to build very quickly and
effectively the agile container itself
has all of the applications and the
dependencies of those applications in
one package you kind of think of it as a
really effective and efficient zip file
it's a little bit more than that but
it's one file that actually has
everything you need to be able to run
all of your Solutions the actual Docker
registry itself is an environment for
being able to host and distribute
different Docker images among your team
so say for instance you had a team of
developers that were working on multiple
different solutions so say you have a
team of developers and you have 50
developers and they're working on five
different applications you can actually
have the applications themselves the
containers shared in the docker registry
so each of those teams at any time check
out and have the latest container of
that latest image of the code that
you're working on so let's dig into what
actually is in the container so the
important part of a docking container is
that it has everything you need to be
able to run the application it's like a
virtualized environment it has all your
Frameworks and your libraries and it
allows the teams to be able to build out
and run exactly the right environment
that the developer intended what's
interesting though is the actual
applications then will run in isolation
so they're not impacting other
applications that using dependencies on
other libraries or files outside of the
container because of the architecture it
really uses a lot less space and because
it's using less space it's a much more
lightweight architecture so the files
and the actual folder itself is much
smaller it's very secure highly portable
and the boot up time is incredibly fast
so let's actually get into how you
actually create a Docker container so
the docker container itself is actually
built through command line and it's
built out of a file and Docker image so
the actual Docker file is a text file
that contains all the instructions that
you would need to be able to create that
Docker image and then we'll actually
then create all of the project code with
inside of that image then the image
becomes the item that you would share
through the docker registry you would
then use the command line and we'll do
this later on select Docker run and then
the name of the image to be able to
easily and effectively run that image
locally and again once you've created
the document you can store that in the
docker registry making it available to
anybody within your network so something
to bear in mind is that Docker itself
has its own registry called Docker Hub
and that is a public restroom so you can
actually go out and see other dock
images that have been created and access
those images as your own company you may
want to have your own private repository
so you want to be able to go ahead and
either do that locally through your own
repository or you can actually get a
licensed version of Docker Hardware you
can actually then share those files now
something that's also very interesting
to know is that you can have multiple
versions of a Docker image so if you
have a different version control
different release versions and you want
to be able to test and write code for
those different release versions because
you may have different setups you can
certainly do that within your Docker
registry environment okay so let's go
ahead and we're going to create a Docker
image using some of our basic Docker
commands and so there are essentially
really you know kind of just two
commands that you're going to be looking
for one is the build command another one
is to actually put it into your registry
which is a push command so if you want
to get a image from a Docker registry
then you want to use the pull command
and a pull command simply pulls the
image from the registry and in this
example using ngi next as our registry
and we can actually then pull the image
down to our test environment on our
local machine so we're actually running
the container within our Docker
application on a local machine we're
able to then have the image run exactly
as it would in production and then you
can actually use the running command to
actually use the docker image on your
local machine so just say you know a few
interesting tidbits about the docking
container once the container is created
a new layer is formed on top of the
docker image layers called the container
layout each container has a separate
read write container layer and any
changes made in that docking container
is then reflected upon that particular
container layout and if you want to
delete the container layer the container
layer also gets deleted as well so you
know why with using Docker and
containers be of benefit to you well you
know some of the things that are useful
is that containers have no external
dependencies for the applications they
run once you actually have the container
running locally it has everything it
needs to be able to run the application
so there's no having to install
additional pieces of software such as
the example we gave with JBoss at the
beginning of the presentation now the
containers are really lightweight so it
makes it very easy to share the
containers amongst your teams whether
it's a developer whether it's a tester
whether it's somebody on your operations
environment it's really easy to share
those containers amongst your entire
team different data volumes can be
easily reused and shared among multiple
containers and again this is another big
benefit and this is a reflection of the
lightweight nature of your containers
the container itself also runs in
isolation which means that it is not
impacted by any dependencies you may
have on your own local environment so
it's a completely sandboxed environment
so some of the questions you might ask
us you know can you run multiple
containers together without the need to
start each one individually and you know
what yes you can with Docker compose
docking compose allows you to run
multiple containers in a single service
and again this is a reflection on the
lightweight nature of containers within
the docker environment so we're going to
end our presentation by looking at some
of the basic commands that you'd have
within Docker so we have here on the
left hand side we have a Docker
container and then the command for each
item we're actually going to go ahead
and use some of these commands and the
demo that we're going to do after this
presentation you'll see that in a moment
but just you know some of the basic
commands we have are committing the
docker image into the Container kill is
a you know standard kill command to you
know terminate one or more of the
running containers so they stop working
then restart those containers but
suddenly you can look at all the image
all of the commands here and try them
out for yourself so we're going to go
ahead and start a demo of how to use the
basic commands to run Docker so to do
this we're going to open up terminal
window or command line now depending
whether you're running Linux PC or Mac
and we're going to go ahead and the
first thing we want to do is see what
our Docker image lists are so we can go
sudo Docker images and this will give us
well first we'll enter in our passwords
let's go enter that in and this will now
give us a list of our Docker images and
here are the dock images I have already
been created in the system and we can
actually go ahead and actually see the
processes that are actually running so
I'm going to go ahead and open up this
window a little bit more but this will
show you the actual processes and the
containers that we actually have and so
on the far left hand side you'll see
under names we have learned simply learn
be unscore cool these are all just
different ones that we've been working
on so let's go ahead and create a Docker
image so I'm going to do sudo
docker
run
Dash Dash p
0.0.0.0 go on a t colon 80
Ubuntu and this will allow us to go
ahead and run an Ubuntu image and this
will run the latest image and what we
have here is a hash number and this hash
number is a unique name that defines the
container that we've just created and we
can go ahead and we can check to make
sure that the container actually is
present so we're going to do
pseudo docker.ps and this actually show
us some there so it's not in a running
state right now but that doesn't mean
that we don't have it so let's list out
all the containers that are both running
and in the exits see so let's do sucker
PS Dash a and this lists all the
containers that I have running on my
machine
and this shows all the ones that have
been in the running State and in the
exit State and here we see one that we
just created about a minute ago and it's
called learn
and these are all running Ubuntu and
this is the one that we had created just
a few seconds ago
let's open it up and
there we go so let's change that to that
new Doc container to a running state so
scroll down and we're going to type sudo
docker
run
Dash it Dash Dash
name my
um so this is going to be the new
container name it's going to be my
Docker so this is how we name our Docker
environment
and we'll put in the image name which is
Ubuntu
and dash bin Dash Bash
and it's now in our root and we'll exit
out of that
so now we're going to go ahead and start
the new my Docker container so sudo
docker
start
my
and we'll get the container image which
will be my docker
my docker
return and that started that Docker
image and let's go ahead and check
against the other running Docker images
to make sure it's running correctly so
sudo docker
PS
and there we are underneath name on the
right hand side you have to see my
Docker along with the other Docker
images that we created and it's been
running for 13 seconds
quite fast so we want to rename the
container let's use the command sudo
docker
rename we can take another Docker image
this let's grab this one and we'll put
it in rename
and we'll rename and put in the old
container name which is image and then
we'll put in the new container name and
let's call it
purple
so now the container image that had
previously been called image is now
called Purple
so do sudo Docker PS
to list all of our Docker images
and if we scroll up and there there we
go purple
how easy is that to rename an image
and we can go ahead and use this command
if we want to stop container so we're
going to write sudo docker
stop
and then we'll have to put in the
container name
and we'll put in my Docker the container
that we originally created
and that image has now stopped
and let's go ahead and prove that we're
going to list out all the docker images
and what you see is that it's not listed
in the active images it's uh not on the
list on the far right hand side
but if we go ahead and we can list out
all of the docker images so you actually
see it's still there as an image it's
just not in an active stage it's what's
known as in an exit state
so here we go
and there's my ducko it's in an exited
state so that happened 27 seconds ago
so if we want to to remove a container
we can use the following command
so sudo docker
RM for remove
my docker and that will remove it from
the exited state
and we're going to go ahead and we're
going to double check that
and yep
yep that's not not listed there under
exit State anymore
it's gone
and there we go
there that's where it used to be all
right let's go back
so if we want to exit a container in the
running state so we do sudo kill and
then the name of the container
I think one of them is called yellow
let's just check and see if that's going
to kill it
oops no I guess we don't have one called
yellow so let's find out name of
container that we actually have
so sudo Docker kill oh we're going to
list out of the ones that are running oh
okay there we go now yellow isn't in
that list so let's take I know let's
take simply learn and so we can actually
go ahead and let's write sudo Docker
kill simply learn
and that will actually kill an active
Docker container
boom there we go
and we list out all the active
containers you can actually see now
that's they simply learn container is
not active anymore
and these are all the basic commands for
Docker container today we're going to
dig into Docker swarm so what we're
going to do in this session is we're
going to go through what Docker and
Docker container is and why you'd want
to use it we'll then break out what are
the characteristics and structure of a
Docker swarm environment and then
finally we'll go through and do a demo
using actual code in the command line
interface to actually run and build out
the main functions and commands that you
would use for a Docker swamp environment
so with that said let's get started so
Docker is a tool that we actually use to
help automate applications in our
environment so that we have a consistent
way that we're actually building and
testing and validating codes that's been
created think of it as a virtualization
but much more sophisticated and
efficient way of doing virtualization
the thing that you have that's a huge
Advantage when you're working with
Docker is that it's a very lightweight
software package it allows you to have
all of the tools needed for actually
running the code code without having to
have the significant overhead that you
would normally have with virtualization
so one of the characteristics you have
with Docker is that you can actually run
multiple Docker environments in the same
host environment and for you to be able
to do this we had to figure out how this
would actually run and so to actually do
this we actually do what's called a
Docker swarm and a Docker swarm is an
environment where you can actually have
multiple Docker images running on the
same host operating system so you can
have running in each of those Docker
containers different solutions so let's
dig into what a Docker swarm is so a
Docker swarm is essentially a tool that
allows you to very easily create and
schedule multiple Docker nodes so really
two or more Docker nodes and you can
have quite a large number of Docker
nodes in a single swarm each node itself
is actually a Docker demon and that
demon is able to interact with Docker
API and have all the benefits of being a
full Docker environment one of the other
advantages you have is that the each
dock container within the Swarm can then
be deployed and managed but as a node in
that entire clustered environment so
what we have here is a breakdown of the
five key elements within a Docker
environment you have the docker
container you have the Daemon the docker
images and the docker client and Docker
registry so the docker Daemon itself is
what does all the work interacting with
the actual host operating system to be
able to manage the docker containers so
if we look here here we have set up an
environment where we have three Docker
containing being run with Docker and
what we want to be able to do is be able
to interact with the environment because
what would happen if we actually have
something change in our environment so
we have the environment set up as a
Docker swarm and one of our containers
fails what we're able to do is use the
Swarm to be able to correct that failure
so the docker swarm manager is able to
come in and reschedule containers and as
you would imagine the actual swarm note
has full backups and full redundancy for
any kind of failures that would happen
and we would do all of this work through
command line interface so let's go
through some of the features that you
have within the actual Docker swarm
itself so a key feature for Docker swarm
is that it is fully decentralized which
means that it makes it very easy for
teams to be able to access and manage
the environment as you would expect as
well is that the communication that
happens between the manager and client
nodes within the swamp is highly secure
and of course this is really just a
fundamental that you should have for any
kind of solution but it is good to know
that Docker swarm has that built in
there is also Auto load balancing within
your environments and you can actually
script that into how you write out and
structure your swarm environment and
that load balancing then also allows you
to then convert that swarm environment
into a highly scalable infrastructure
and then rollback task allows you to be
able to roll back environments to
previous safe environments so say
something does get pushed out and
something breaks you're able to
immediately roll back into a safe
environment so each of the containers
are pushed out and and are controlled
using services and they actually happen
to be breast Services which make it very
easy for you to be able to integrate
within your environment and each of the
different Services contains a group of
containers of the same image Now by
having this structure it allows you to
be able to scale your application
appropriate to the demands on your
server so if you have a service that
needs to have a significantly larger
number number of services for it to run
you can actually scale that
appropriately and they can be either Geo
or demand based one of the requirements
for setting up a double swarm is you
must have at least one node deployed so
the way that the architecture is set up
is that you have a major node and a
client node and there must be one of
each for the entire environment to be
able to work effectively so you know
here we are just jumping ahead of sales
a little bit we have two types of nodes
in a Docker swamp we have the major node
and we have the worker node which is the
client that does the actual execution of
the tasks the manager note very similar
to other systems that we've talked about
on simply learn allows you to actually
control and manage the actual tasks that
are being executed by the worker nodes
and the worker nodes as you can imagine
and then actually execute the
instructions that the manager are
sending out to it so here we have a
situation where we can illustrate what
would happen with a manager node sending
out commands to different workers Boots
the manager is fully aware of the status
of the entire swarm environment at all
times this is because of the two-way
secure communication that's going from
the manager to the worker environment
the workers as you'd expect are
accepting tasks that are being sent from
the manager so the manager sends out a
task saying that you need to be running
as a MySQL environment then the work and
node will then convert to a MySQL
environment and all of these
environments are scripted and controlled
by you as the manager the actual worker
nodes themselves actually have a client
agent and that client will then
communicate all different states of the
infrastructure back to the manager so
that anytime the manager node is in full
control of the entire swarm the major is
the controller of this environment and
so you always want to be able to ensure
that the manager has full access to all
the work that's happening within the
Swarm and this allows you as the manager
to be able to control roll your swarm
and very quickly be able to react to any
changes without having to rely on manual
installations of software and hardware
and as we covered earlier on there is a
rest API that uses the communication
over HTTP from the manager to the worker
node it's interesting to note that it is
a rest API because if you wanted to you
could actually integrate that API into
custom applications and even then create
automated Docker images to be created on
demand from third-party solutions that
you may want to create so one of the
things that's a really a big Advantage
with having a swarm is that once you've
actually created the form any of the
services that you create can be accessed
by any node of the same cluster one of
the things you do have to do though is
you have to specify what container image
that you're going to use when you're
creating a new service and you can do
that either through a centralized Docker
Hub environment or through your own
private Docker Hub environment one of
the things that's interesting is that
you can set up commands and services to
be either Global or replicated a global
Service will allow you to run a service
consistently on every node within the
Swarm whereas a replicated service will
only push out functionality and tasks to
specific worker nodes within a swarm so
you may be asking yourself hey is it a
service and task the same thing no that
they're kind of not in the docker world
and the difference is is a service is a
description of a task for the state
whereas the actual task is the work that
needs to get done and that's the
differentiator here so what you can do
as a Docker user is you actually create
services and then you can then Define
when you want them to start as tasks now
what's interesting is that when you do
assign a task to a node that same task
cannot be assigned to another node also
what's interesting thing is that you can
actually have multiple managers within a
Docker swarm environment if you do
however go down this path you have to
elect one manager to be the primary
manager and the other managers to be
secondary managers in many ways those
secondary managers are really similar in
concept to worker nodes in which they
have the capability of a manager but
they are dependent on that single
primary manager to be able to provide
the right instructions and for services
and tasks to the entire swarm
environment so if we kind of recap some
of these we have a command line
interface which allows us to create and
connect via apis and that those apis
that we connect to in our store
environment allows us to do
orchestration via tasks and services the
task allocation allows us to allocate
work to tasks via their IP address which
allows them to execute them on the work
and then the worker nodes themselves
have to connect to the manager note to
be able to check but when tasks come in
so that they are keeping a consistent
communication back and forth across the
entire swarm and then the final stage is
to actually execute the tasks that have
been assigned from the manager node to
the work node so that you have a
successful execution of the solution
you're looking to build right so with
that said let's go ahead and we're going
to do a demo so we're going to go ahead
and do a demo and showing how you can
run with Docker Swan for this you'll
need to have both a virtual environment
running your manager and you're working
in frame mode so here we have our worker
and here we have our manager so we're
just going to open up terminal window
and we're going to go into the manager
for terminal window so the following
command here is used to initialize
Docker swarm which is going to type this
in so sudo Docker swamp in it
and we purchased the IP address for the
network we're connecting to
open in our password
and here we have now connected
and this is our manager node and we want
to be able to highlight is the specific
token which identifies the docker swarm
environment and this is our token right
here so we're going to copy that
because we'll need to use that for our
workout environment so here we are in
the worker environment and we'll use the
token that we just copied
um as a way to be able to connect to the
manager and connect to the docker swarm
environment
and so sudo
I'll paste in the docker swarm and we'll
join that I will now here we shows that
we have joined the Swarm environment as
a worker
and now we're in the manager we can
actually show that we actually have
that worker in the environment so
there's Docker node LS to list out all
of the
items in that environment
sorry we actually did then the wrong
area so we're on the right pseudo Docker
node allows to list out all the nodes in
the Swan and there you are you see we've
actually connected the worker to the
manager node and both are active and the
manager is the leader and the worker
virtualbox is in the Swarm
okay we're going to go ahead and create
a new service so Dr Swan create and
we're going to just change the name to
hello world for the new service and
we're going to use the Alpine image from
docker.com
takes just a moment for it to run
there we go
and there we go Services converged
so what we have now is a new service
that has been created
let's go ahead and we'll list out the
services
and here we have our new Hello World
Service
and we go ahead and check the docking
containers and we're going to do Docker
PS and here's our Alpine it's running
the latest image
and that's the docker container ID
and we can see that it was just updated
and so we're going to do is use the same
command in the worker node
and make sure everything is working over
there
so go over to our worker and paste that
in
so what we see here is there is no image
or container created because it's not in
the worker node it would be in the
manager node
so we can go ahead and create the new
service
and we'll make the Mode Global and that
way the service is available across all
of the Swarm
so we're just going to execute that work
takes a moment
and
there we are
done work has been completed and we have
the two different IDs which shows that
two different Services running and if we
go back to the working mode and we run
sudo.go PS again and there we are now we
see that we have the hello world
new virtual environment has been added
with the image of Alpine and we also
have the new token ID for that
if we want to kill a node from the Swarm
we can use the following command which
is suitable Docker swamp leave dash dash
force and that will force the node to
leave the Swarm today we're going going
to cover Docker compose so in this
session what we're going to do is we're
going to go through what Docker is and
then by extension what Docker compose is
and how it improves the performance of
Docker what the benefits of working with
Docker compose is we are going to cover
as well what the difference between
Docker compose and Docker swarm is
because the two products are similar but
they have two different types of jar and
at the end of this presentation we'll
take you through some basic commands
that allow you to get up and running
working with Docker and Docker compose
finally after this presentation we'll do
a brief demo that allows you to get up
and running using some of these commands
to do your own Docker compose
environment so let's get started with
Docker compose so first of all we have
to kind of cover what Docker is so
Docker has come as an evolution of
technologies that started with virtual
machines VM machine and a VM machine
allows you to run in a complete
operating system and complete operating
system and its environment on your own
computer in your own operating system
without interfering that the problem was
the center is very heavy and complex and
in contrast Docker is a much more
lightweight and more flexible
environment that you can automate with
scripts so we have to remember that the
container itself is just software and it
has dependencies that run within that
application that are managed by Docker
so if we have a look at the way Dockers
broke now first of all we have the
docker image and we have the docker
image created by a Docker file and the
docker file is a text-based script and
that text file within dockerfile
actually has all the commands that allow
you to run the appropriate Technologies
within the docker image so the docker
image allows you to be able to have a
wide group of people and consistently
run the same environments and if you
want to be able to share that Docker
image effectively you would do so by
uploading to Docker Hub and Docker Hub
can be available either publicly through
the the public Docker Hub website or you
can actually set up your own private
Enterprise Docker Hub to share your own
images across your own network and then
from Docker Hub people can then pull
their own Docker image and build new
containers that are consistent on the
original Docker container that you've
created so it's a great way of being
able to have your entire team scale up
easily and effectively so one of the
questions that will come up though is
what if you want to use two containers
in a single service and an example of
this might be like a web server that is
using a database but the database may be
in one container and the web server may
be in another container which is very
typical for your own web and database
infrastructure so very similar I'm
scenario but how would you do this with
dark app so when I usually just Docker
itself it's actually very difficult to
do this you can do it but it's just very
time consuming and just not a very good
use of your productivity but with Docker
compose you can actually do the whole
process quite quickly and easily and
hence the reason why we have Docker
compose to allow you to have two or more
Docker containers running in the same
environment being able to communicate as
if they were running in a production
environment so let's dig into what
Docker compose is so let's consider a
scenario that you'd have today so a
Mitra is a fashion website similar to
Amazon and you go to Mantra with your
web browser and on that website you
would go through a number of activities
such as logging into your account
browsing a catalog you'd have your
checkout application server and you go
through the table process of building
out an application behind each of these
services are different products such as
you have an account database you have a
product database different checkout
processes and these would all be run
behind the scenes and each of these can
be considered a micro service so the
more microservices you build into your
environment the more complexity you're
adding and the more of value it would be
to have each of these services in their
own container but as a developer you
want to be able to jump from one
container to another container so your
login account can then be passed on to
your product catalog and then be able to
move through the whole process so the
environment that you would see today
would be small like what we're showing
right now where you'd have your server
and your database and you may have a
server running on an Apache Tomcat or a
SQL Server you'd have different
databases and you'd want to be able to
have each of those in their own
containerized environment so the way
that Docker compose runs is that it
works as a single service so you have
the docker compose running multiple
containers but exception is of a single
service right the thing that's great
though is that each of those containers
will run in their in isolation and but
they can interact with each other so
unlike a normal Docker environment where
you have multiple Docker images running
completely in isolation of each other
these are images that will run in
isolation but can interact with each
other the docker compose files are very
easy to write they're all written with a
scripting language called yaml and yaml
is an XML based language it actually
stands for yet another markup language
but it's an XML based language and it's
very easy to use the great thing about
learning yaml is that a lot of Open
Source tools in the devops environment
use yaml as the scripting way and then
finally in Docker compose as a user you
can actually go in and Trigger all your
services within the containers to start
with a single camera on as you can
imagine this dramatically reduces the
amount of work that you as a developer
have to do so let's take an example of
if you're running a container one with
the ninjix server and one with a redis
database uh you can create a yaml Docker
compose file that actually has the
instructions on the containers needed to
build out both environments and then you
can run each of those environments
separately but have them connected as a
single service so the benefits of dock
and compose is that you have a single
host deployment environment you can run
this all on one piece of Hardware you
can have a quick and easy configuration
using yaml scripts the productivity that
you get as a developer significantly
increases because you're not having to
have time wasted trying to configure
just traditional Docker containers by
themselves you now have a way of being
able to interact with those containers
and then finally security is at the
center of all of these containers so
each of those containers are completely
isolated from from each other and they
are controlled with the same level of
security that you'd have with a
traditional Docker image but there is a
question here around Docker compose
isn't it similar in concept to Docker
Swan because at a high level it kind of
seems like both do the same thing and
the answer is well actually no they're
different there are similarities but
there are also differences and
particularly for a developer these
differences will really start coming out
in scale as you start working on your
Solutions so let's look at Docker
compose right so Docker compose will
allow you to create multiple containers
on a single host and that's the
important part of having a single hose
which is maybe your development PC with
Docker swarm it also allows you to
create multiple containers however you
have to manage those multiple containers
on multiple hosts which makes a lot of
sense if you're running an operations
environment but not so much if you're
doing a development environment and
Docker compose is scripted with yaml
which is very easy for you to be able to
control your scripts Docker swarm
doesn't have a scripting technology like
yaml so it's a little bit harder to work
with so what we have here is just some
basic commands that allow you to get up
and started working with Docker compose
in our next demo we're actually going to
take you through how to use all of those
commands so we're going to go ahead and
do a demo on how to use Docker compose
and the first thing you want to do is
check that you have Docker installed so
what we're going to do is we're going to
open up the command window and we're
going to type in Docker you'll be able
to see now that we have Docker installed
if you don't have dog installed go ahead
and install Docker you can go to Google
Search to install Docker and it'll give
you the instructions for that we also
have videos that we've already done if
once you have dock installed then you
want to do a Google search on Docker
compose or go to the docker.com website
and select for the compose close section
and look for the install Docker compose
instructions so we already have another
tab which has the instructions already
installed you'll see on the left hand
side there are a number of Docker tools
you want to expand the docker compose
section select install compose and then
on the right hand side you'll have
different install options for Mac
windows and Linux if you're installing
on those platforms make sure you're
copying the correct command line so
there's a couple command ones you want
to copy copy the first one over and we
paste that in and it's going to go ahead
and download all of the files for
compose it takes a while but we have to
get another file so while it's
downloading we'll go get the other
command line just go back and grab it
real quick so it's a little faster but
we'll copy that over there was a second
command instruction and post that
command yep there's the command right
there and that will apply the
appropriate binary sorry and once you've
done that you can actually go ahead and
validate that you have the correct
version of Docker compose installed and
for that you want to write the command
Docker Dash compose space dash dash
version and that will then give you a
version build once you know that you
have a version build that means that you
have everything installed correctly on
your machine so you can see here that we
have a version number which means we
have everything installed you might see
a different version number depending on
how old the video is when you're
watching it but they're using very
content at the moment I'll just go ahead
and clear the screen and now what we're
going to do is create a folder where
we're actually going to install the yaml
file that will have the instructions for
our docking compose environment so we're
moving the cursor to the desktop and on
the desktop we're going to create a new
folder and using the MK derive command
and we'll call this one Docker compose f
for file and then we'll move the cursor
into that new folder by using CT command
and now we are in the folder called
Docker compose F and you can go look at
your desktop and you'll see it's there
and now you want to select and pound
touch Docker Dash compose Dot yml and
they'll actually create the new yaml
file for you and you can use the ls list
command LS Docker Dash compose.yaml and
they'll allow you actually now to step
in and edit that file so let's go ahead
and hit return and they'll allow us to
go in and edit the file so now I'm in
the editor and I'm going to write some
instructions
um so I'm I'm going to put a couple of
mistakes in these instructions so we can
see how Docker pose catches those
mistakes and so but most this is going
to be fairly correct so you can just
type this out so we're going to start
with Services colon then we'll do a web
colon and then we create image colon and
we'll do ninjix and then we'll do a
database colon and and we call the image
redis and so what you can see because we
have two reference images we're actually
calling two different images two
different containers that will be
created by Docker Hub uh so what we're
going to do is uh where we can actually
show you um how that's pulling in you
can go to Docker Hub and you can
actually see the references to the
images that we've just created so go to
Docker Hub which is Hub hub.docker.com
and you'll see that uh ninjix redis
those are the default names for the
images so you could do other images like
HTP for Apache web server if you wanted
to there are a lot of images in Docker
Hub so certainly have a lot of fun
building uh tools from that environment
so we're going to save those files in
the docker image and we're just going to
do colon WQ to exit this screen I save
the text and let's go and run our yaml
file and you'll see the two different
different error messages that will come
up so we're going to do cat Docker Dash
compose Dot yml and here we have a
display of the text that we just wrote
and now let's go check the validity of
the file that we just created so we'll
do Docker Dash compose config and we
should get an error message and there we
are error message and the reason why we
have an error message is because the
spacing is not correct in the yaml file
itself so let's go to the actual yaml
file that we created let's go through
and we're going to use uh just the file
finder and you'll actually open up the
yaml file in your text and see your
favorite text editor and here we have
the code that created it and let's use
the correct spacing so that everything
is spaced out appropriately in the image
and so this is the spacing that you'd
expect to see a space a line between
surfaces and the first image and the
first image is a tab in and then it
refers what the image is and let's go
ahead and clear the screen and we'll see
whether or not we've got that all
correct this clear screen and we're
going to check that everything is
running correctly and we're seeing we're
still getting an error message and the
reason why we're getting another error
is that there's still a config error in
this the actual yaml file so one of the
things you have to do when you're
creating a yaml file for Docker
composers you actually have to have the
appropriate version number in there so
what we have to do is we have to go and
find which is the appropriate version
and there are three major versions one
two and three depending on the age of
Docker that you have installed on your
computer so if you have the very latest
version of Docker 18 and newer you would
put 3.7 as the version number and what
we're going to do is we're going to just
check on the version that we have
installed and so just clear the screen
and then we'll just do Docker version
and what we have is our version of
Dockers 7
18.12 now this is the version of Docker
not Docker compose it's your main Docker
environment and so if we go back to our
web browser we'll actually see that
version 17 should align with version
number 3.5 yep there we are version 3.5
so what we want to do is go back into
our yaml file in the very first line
that we want to put in above the
surfaces is the version number and that
version number we're going to put in is
3.5 so we type in version version and
we'll put colon and then version number
is in in quotes and you save that and
now what we can actually do is we can
actually go ahead and use the single
line instruction to run both of these uh
two images that we've created because
everything is configured correctly or
just one note you'll see that the
version number is actually at the bottom
of the list and that's just the way
Docker compose words it pulls out the
services and the images that you'd
create and then puts the image the
version number at the bottom of the list
so in the presentation we talked about
how you can use one line to trigger two
or more images and so to do that we're
going to do sudo Docker Dash compose D
and it's going to create the two
environments we have the web environment
and the database environment and let's
use pseudo Docker PS to actually list
out that all the processes that are
running right now and there we are we
actually see all of the images are
running we have the names the commands
the images and everything's up and
running and if we want to close both of
those images we can actually use a
single line of command as well and that
command will be pseudo Docker Dash
compose down and that closes both of the
images and we can see that all the
databases and the web server his images
have been closed and pseudo Docker PS
will actually lists that there's nothing
running and that's how to use Docker
compose in this session we're going to
cover what kubernetes is and why you
would want to be using it within your
devops team so let's get started we're
going to break up this presentation into
four key areas we're going to talk about
life before kubernetes which some of you
are probably experiencing right now what
is kubernetes the benefits that
kubernetes brings to you particularly if
you are using containers in a devops
environment and then finally we're going
to break down the architecture and
working infrastructure for kubernetes so
you understand what's happening and why
the actions are happening the way that
they are so let's jump into our first
section of life before kubernetes so the
way that you have done work in the past
where you may be doing work right now is
really building out and deploying
Solutions into two distinct areas one is
a traditional deployment where you're
pushing out code to physical servers in
a Data Center and you're managing the
operating system and the code that's
actually running on each of those
servers another environment that you may
potentially be using is to Blind code
out to Virtual machines so let's go
through and look at the two different
types of deployment that you may be
experiencing when you have applications
running on multiple machines you run
into the potential risk that the setup
and configuration of each of those
machines isn't going to be consistent
and your code isn't going to work
effectively and there may be issues with
uptime and errors within the
infrastructure of your entire
environment there's going to be problems
with resource allocation and you're
going to have error issues where
applications may be running effectively
and not look not effectively and not
load balance effectively across the
environment the problem that you have
with this kind of infrastructure is that
it gets very expensive you can only
install one piece of software once
service on one piece of Hardware so your
Hardware is being massively
underutilized this is where virtual
machines have become really popular with
a virtual machine you're able to have
better resource utilization and
scalability a much less cost and this
allows you to be able to run multiple
virtual machines on a single piece of
Hardware the problem is is that VMS are
for virtual machines are not perfect
either some of the challenges you run
with VMS is that the actual hardware and
software need needed to manage the VM
environment can be expansive there are
security risks with virtual with VMS
there are security risks with VMS there
have been data breaches recorded about
solutions that run in virtualized
environments you also run into an issue
of availability and this is largely
because you can only have a finite
number of virtual machines running on a
piece of hardware and this results in
limitations and restrictions in the
types of of environment you want to be
running and then finally setting up and
managing a virtualized environment is
time consuming it can take a lot of time
and it can also get very expensive so
how about kubernetes well kubernetes is
a tool that allows you to manage
containerized deployment of solutions an
inherently kubernetes is a tool that is
really a Next Level maturity of
deployment so if you can think of your
maturity curve as deploying code in
directly to Hardware in a Data Center
and then deploying your solutions to
Virtual machines the next evolution of
that deployment is to use containers and
kubernetes so let's kind of go through
and look at the differences between a
virtual machine and kubernetes and we've
got a few here that we want to highlight
and you'll get an understanding of what
the differences are between the two so
first of all with virtual machines there
is inherently security risks and what
you'll find as we get dig through the
architecture later in the presentation
is that kubernetes is inherently secure
and this is largely because of the
Legacy code the legacy of kubernetes and
where it came from we will talk about
that in just a moment but kubernetes is
inherently secure virtual machines are
not easily portable now with that said
they they are technically portable
they're just not very easily portable
whereas with kubernetes it's working
with Docker container Solutions it is
extremely portable that means that you
can actually spin up and spin down and
manage your infrastructure exactly the
way that you want it to be managed and
scale it on the demands of the customers
as they're coming in to use the solution
from a time consuming point of view
kubernetes is much less time consuming
than with a virtual machine a few other
areas that we want to kind of highlight
from differences virtual machines use
much less isolation when building out
the encapsulated environment then
kubernetes does for instance with a
virtual machine you have to run
hypervisor on top of the OS and hardware
and then inside of the virtual machine
you also have to have the operating
system as well whereas in contrast on a
kubernetes environment because it's
leveraging a Docker container and or
container-like Technologies it only has
to have the OS and the hardware and then
inside of each container it doesn't need
to have that additional iOS layer it's
able to inherit what it needs to be able
to run the application this makes the
whole solution much more flexible and
allows you to run many more containers
on a piece of Hardware than versus
running virtual machines on a single
piece of Hardware so as we highlighted
here VMS are not as portable as
kubernetes and kubernetes is portable
directly related to the use of
containerization and because kubernetes
is built on top of contain is it is much
less time consuming because you can
actually script and automatically
allocate resource to nodes within your
kubernetes environment because it allows
the infrastructure to run much more
effectively and much more efficiently so
this is why if we look at our evolution
of the land of time before kubernetes
while we are running into a searching
where kubernetes had to come about
because the demand for having more
highly scalable solutions that are more
efficient was just really a natural
evolution of this software deployment
model that started with pushing out code
to physical hardware and then pushing
code out to Virtual machines and then
needing to have a solution much more
sophisticated kubernetes would have come
about at some point in time I'm just
really glad it came back when it did so
what is kubernetes does this dig into
the history of kubernetes and how it
came about so in essence kubernetes is
an open source platform that allows you
to manage and deploy and maintain groups
of containers and a container is
something like Docker and if you're
developing code you're probably already
using Docker today consider kubernetes
as the tool that manages multiple Docker
environments together now we talk a lot
about Docker and as a container solution
with kubernetes the reality is is that
kubernetes can actually use other
container tools out there but Docker
just simply is the most popular
container out there both these tools are
open source that's one of those so
popular and they just allow you to be
able to have flexibility in being able
to scale up your Solutions and they were
designed for the post-digital world that
we live in exist in today so a little
bit of background a little bit of trivia
around kubernetes so kubernetes was
originally a successor to a project at
Google and the original project was
Google book Google Blog it does exactly
what kubernetes done does today but
kubernetes was Rewritten from the ground
up and then released as an open source
project in 2014 so that people outside
of Google could take advantage of the
power of kubernetes containerization
management tools and today it is managed
by the cloud native Computing foundation
and there are many many companies that
support and manage kubernetes so for
instance if you're signing up for
Microsoft Azure AWS Google Cloud all of
them will leverage kubernetes and it's
just become the the de facto tool for
managing large groups of containers so
let's kind of Step through some of the
key benefits that you'd experience from
kubernetes and so we have nine key
benefits and the first it is highly
portable and is 100 open source code and
this means that you can actually go
ahead and contribute to this code
project if you want to through GitHub
the ability to scale up the solution is
incredible
um what's the the history of kubernetes
being part of a Google project for
managing the Google network and
infrastructure kind of really sets the
groundwork for having a solution that is
highly scalable the out of the high
scalability also comes the need for high
availability and this is the desire to
be able to have a highly efficient and
highly energized environment but also
you can really rely on so if you're
building outer kubernetes management
environment you know that it's going to
be available for the solutions that
you're maintaining and it's really
designed for deployment so you can
script out the environment and actually
have it as part of your devops model so
you can scale up and meet the demands of
your customer then what you'll find is
that the load balancing is extremely
efficient and it allows you to
distribute the load efficiently across
your entire network so your network
remains stable and then also the tool
allows you to manage the orchestration
of your storage so you can have local
storage such as an SSD on the hardware
that the kubernetes is maintaining or if
the kubernetes environment is pulling
storage from a public Cloud such as
Azure or AWS you can actually go ahead
and make that available to your entire
system and you can inherit the security
that goes back and forth between the
cloud environments and one of the things
you'll find consistent with kubernetes
is that it is designed for a cloud-first
environment um kubernetes as well is
that it's it's really a self-healing
environment so if something happens or
something fails uh kubernetes will
detect that failure and then either
restart the process kill the process or
replace it and then because of that you
also have automated rollouts and
rollbacks in case you need to be able to
manage the state of the environment and
then finally you have automatic bin
packaging so you can actually specify
the compute power that's being used from
CPU and RAM for each container so let's
dig into the final area which is the
actual kubernetes architecture I'm going
to cover this at a high level there's
actually another video that you can that
simply learn has developed which digs
deeper into the kubernetes architecture
and so the kubernetes architecture is a
clustered based architecture and it's
really about two key areas you have the
kubernetes master which actually
controls
um and all of the activities within your
entire kubernetes infrastructure and
then you have nodes that actually are
running on Linux machines
um out that are controlled by the master
so let's kind of go through some of
these areas so if we look at the
kubernetes master to begin with
um then we'll start with uh Etc this is
a tool that allows for the configuration
and the information and the management
of nodes within your cluster and one of
the key features that you'll find with
all of the tools that are managed within
either a the master environment or
within a node is that they are all
accessible via the apis server and
what's interesting about the API server
is that it's a restful based
infrastructure which means that you can
actually secure each connection with SSL
and other security models to ensure that
your entire infrastructure and the
communication going back and forth
across your infrastructure is tightly
secured scheduler goes ahead and
actually as you'd expect it actually
manages the schedule of activities
within the actual cluster and then you
have the control and the controller is a
Demon server that actually manages and
pushes out the instructions to all of
your nodes so the other tools really are
the the infrastructure and you can
consider them the administration site um
of the master whereas control is the
management it actually pushes out all of
the controls via the API server so let's
actually dig into one of the actual
nodes themselves and there are three key
areas of the nodes one is the docker
environment which actually helps and
manage and maintain the container that's
actually inside of the node and then you
have the kublet which is responsible for
information that goes back and forth and
it's going to do most of the
conversation with the API server on the
actual health of that node and then you
have the actual kubernetes proxy which
actually runs the services actually
inside of the node so as you see all of
these infrastructures are extremely
lightweight and designed to be very
efficient and very available for your
infrastructure and so here's a quick
recap of the different tools that are
available and it really breaks down into
two key areas you have your kubernetes
master and the kubernetes node now the
kubernetes Mazda has the instructions of
what's going to happen within your
kubernetes infrastructure and then it's
going to push out those instructors to
an indefinite number of nodes that will
allow you to be able to scale up and
scale down your solution in a dynamic
way hi guys in today's
form used for deployment and management
of containers so let's get started now
the first step is to install the
necessary dependencies using two of the
commands first is sudo app get update
which gets all the updates
and then you have to enter password
so this will take a few seconds
that's done the next step is to install
app transport https this is basically
used to make repositories via https so
let's go ahead with that sudo
okay that's done going ahead the next
thing we have to do is to install the
docker dependency using the command sudo
apt install Docker dot IO
you have to choose why
and this will take a few minutes
okay that's that so after installing the
docker we have to start and enable the
docker using the command sudo systemctl
start Docker and pseudo system CTU
enabledoc
so now the docker is enabled so now we
are done with the first step of
installation the next step is we have to
install the necessary components for
kubernetes before that we have to
install the curl command because curl
command is used to send data using a URL
syntax let's install the curl command
using the command sudo apt-get install
code
so you have to select Y and this will
take few minutes
[Music]
so moving on the next step we have to do
is download an add key for kubernetes
installation from a URL so let's go
ahead with that pseudo curl
so this is where we get the key and then
we have to add it using sudo app key add
and it's done so the next step is we
have to add a repository in a certain
location so before doing that we have to
change the permission of that file so we
do that using C or sudo CH mode command
okay so the permission has changed now
let's go ahead and save this file in
that location first we have to enter
this command into the file
this is a URL
save as
so we have to save it in this location
let's rename this to
kubernetes
dot list
now let's see
okay so here it is now moving forward
now we have to check for any updates
available
in the next command we are going to
install the kubernetes components that
is cubelet Cube medium cubicle and
kubernetes CNA so let's go ahead with
that
so this is going to take a few minutes
now that's done so the next step we have
to initialize the master node and to do
this we have to first use a swap of
command to disable the swapping on other
devices so let's do that sudo swap off
hyperly
now let's go ahead with the
initialization sudo
Cube ADM in it
this is going to take a few minutes
okay so before going to the next step to
start the cluster we have to use these
three commands let's just copy paste it
okay that's done
so moving forward the next step is to
deploy Parts using the following command
[Music]
now the pods have been deployed to our
Network to see all the pods you have to
use the command pseudo Q Vector get
pause
there you can see the password being
deployed hello and in this video we're
going to cover a common conversation
which is kubernetes versus darker but
before we jump into that I want you to
hit the Subscribe button so you get
notified about new content as it gets
made available and If you hit the
notification button without notification
will then pop up on your desktop as a
video is published from Simply learn in
addition if you have any questions on
the topic please post them in the
comments below we read them and we do
reply to them as often as we can so with
that said let's jump into kubernetes
versus Docker so let's go through a
couple of scenarios let's do one for
kubernetes and then one for Docker and
we can actually go through and
understand what the problems specific
companies have actually had and how
they're able to use the two different
tools to solve them so our first one is
with Bose and Bose has a large catalog
of products that kept growing and their
infrastructure had to change so the way
that they looked at that was actually
establishing two primary goals to be
able to allow their product groups to be
able to easier more easily catch up to
the scale of their business so after
going through a number of solutions they
ended up coming up with a solution of
having kubernetes running their iot
platform as a service inside of Amazon's
AWS cloud service and what you'll see
with both these products is they're very
Cloud friendly but here we have um Bose
and kubernetes working together with AWS
to be able to scale up and meet the
demands of their product catalog and so
the result is that we're able to
increase the number of non-production
deployments significantly by taking the
number of services from being large
bulky Services down to small micro
Services being able to handle as many as
1250 plus deployments every year an
incredible amount of time and value has
been opened through the use of
kubernetes now let's have a look at
marker and see what a similar problem
that people would have so the problem is
with PayPal and PayPal and processes
something in the region of over 200
payments per second across all of their
products and PayPal doesn't just have
PayPal they have Braintree and venmo so
the challenge that PayPal was really
being given is that they had different
architectures which resulted in
different maintenance cycles and
different deployment times and an
overall complexity from having a
decade-old architecture with PayPal
through to a modern architecture with a
venmo through the use of Docker paper
was able to unified application delivery
and be able to centralize the management
of all of the containers with one
existing group the net net result is
that PayPal was able to migrate over 700
applications into Docker Enterprise
which consists of over 200 000
containers this Ultra ultimately opened
up a 50 percent increase in availability
for being able to add in additional time
for building testing and deploying of
applications just a huge win for PayPal
now let's dig into kubernetes and Docker
and so kubernetes is an open source
platform and it's designed for being
able to maintain a large number of
containers and what you're going to find
is that your argument for kubernetes
versus Docker isn't a real argument it's
kubernetes and Docker working together
so kubernetes is able to manage the
infrastructure of a containerized
environment and Docker is the number one
container management solution and so
with Docker you're able to automate the
deployment of your applications being
able to keep them in a very lightweight
environment and being able to create a
nice consistent experience so that your
developers are working in the same
containers that are then also pushed out
to production so with Docker you're able
to manage multiple containers running on
the same Hardware much more efficiently
than you are with a VM environment the
productivity around Docker is extremely
high you're able to keep your
applications very isolated the
configuration for dark here is really
quick and easy you can be up and running
in minutes with Docker once you have it
installed and running on your
development machine or inside of your
devops environment so if we look at the
deployment between the two and the
differences kubernetes is really
designed for a combination of PODS and
services in its deployment whereas with
Docker it's around about deploying
services in containers so the the
difference
um here is that kubernetes is going to
manage the entire environment and then
and that environment consisting of PODS
and inside of a pod you're going to have
all of your containers that you're
working on and those containers are
going to control the services that
actually power the app applications that
are being deployed kubernetes is by
default an auto scaling solution it has
it turned on and is always available
whereas Docker does not and that's not
surprising because Docker is a tool for
building out Solutions whereas
kubernetes is about managing your
infrastructure kubernetes is going to
run health checks on the liveness and
Readiness of your entire environment so
not just one container but tens of
thousands of containers whereas Docker
is going to limit the health check to
the services that it's managing within
its own containers now I'm not going to
kid you kubernetes is quite hard to set
up it's it's of the tools that you're
going to be using in your devops
environment it's it's not an easy setup
for you to use and for this reason you
want to really take advantage of the
services within Azure and other similar
Cloud environments where they actually
will do the setup for you Docker in
contrast is really easy to set up you
can as I mentioned earlier you can be up
and running in a few minutes as you
would expect the fault tolerance within
kubernetes is very high and this is by
Design because the architecture of
kubernetes is built on the same
architecture that Google uses for
managing its entire Cloud infrastructure
in contrast Docker has lower full
tolerance but that's because it's just
managing the the surfaces within its own
containers what you'll find is that most
public Cloud providers will provide
support for both kubernetes and Docker
here we've highlighted Microsoft Azure
because they were very quick to jump on
and support kubernetes but the realities
is that today Google Amazon and many
other providers are having first level
support for kubernetes it's just become
extremely popular in a very very short
time frame the companies using both
kubernetes and Docker is vast and every
single day there are more and more
companies using it and you should be
able to look and see whether or not you
can add your own company to this list
hello and welcome to Simply learn today
we're going to be giving you a
kubernetes tutorial we'll provide the
overview of how and why you should be
using kubernetes but before we get
started don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button and the like button if
you want to get notified about
additional content from Simply learn and
as always if you have any comments about
the material that you're about to see
and you have any questions please post
them in the comments below we do read
them and we do reply to them so with
that said let's jump in so we're going
to go through a bunch of things today
around kubernetes we're going to cover
what kubernetes is and why you should be
using it along with the features of
kubernetes we're also going to take a
little bit of a look at kubernetes
versus Docker swarm as the two
technologies do tend to get referred to
quite frequently and then we're going to
do a deep dive into the actual
kubernetes architecture itself and how
kubernetes runs and operates within your
network and then finally we're going to
look at some kubernetes these use cases
of how you can actually apply best
learnings that other companies have used
with kubernetes we'll finish everything
off with a demo where we actually step
through and use some of the actual codes
that you can actually use to run uh from
your terminal window to actually
activate kubernetes itself so with that
said let's jump in so why kubernetes
well kubernetes is really being built
from allowing you to be able to have a
more reliable infrastructure the tool
itself is designed to manage the
containers you have within your network
it's very modular in architecture which
allows it to be very easy to be able to
maintain and to be able to scale and
meet the demands that your current
customers are offering you today the
actual ability for you to be able to
deploy and update software at scale is
really at the heart and center of
kubernetes it's really well the one of
the reasons why kubernetes was created
was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into 10 tens of
thousands of networks and servers within
a Data Center and then finally when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building Cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of
kubernetes which we'll get to in a
little bit but it's good to know that as
you're using kubernetes and
containerized solutions that you're
really building out an infrastructure
that's designed for cloud-centric
solution delivery so let's dig into why
what kubernetes is so the history of
kubernetes is that it was originally
developed by Google Google actually used
the precursor to kubernetes to manage
and maintain the data structure and data
infrastructure that they had within
their Network they really liked it and
one of the big benefits that kubernetes
that Google provided is that they
converted their code into an open source
program that they released as kubernetes
in 2014 and made an open source this
means means that any company can use
kubernetes there's no charge for it all
you have to do is know how to use the
command line to actually get up and
running the benefit of kubernetes being
open source is that most Cloud providers
now support kubernetes so whether you're
using Microsoft Azure you're using
Google cloud or AWS you'll find that you
can actually use kubernetes and
kubernetes and at a core really helped
eliminate manual processes so it allows
for deploying and scaling your
container-based Solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of Step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes Within
your network or whether you're managing
10 000 it doesn't matter you have the
ability to scale that something you
simply didn't have before kubernetes is
also will manage the actual containers
themselves including the security and
the storage and the networking within
those containers the great benefit of
working with kubernetes is that not only
is it a cloud-centric solution but it
was really built from a core need of a
secure solution so security is at the
heart and center of all the work you're
doing which really helps benefit any
teams scaling out containers your
kubernetes environment will be
constantly monitored so that when you
have nodes that have your containers the
health of those nodes has been
constantly communicated back to the
kubernetes environment so that the
entire environment is always being
managed and checked so if you have any
additional hosting and launching that
needs to be done kubernetes will help
you automate those manual process
accesses if something does go wrong you
can actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll back
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then finally kubernetes will allow
you to mount and add the storage needed
to run your apps so whether you have
storage such as a local SSD storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage fire the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and Docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and Docker often
get connected with each other and
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and Docker is really famous
for creating the most popular container
management solution which is called
Docker if you're a developer you're
probably already using Docker today so
one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale and just massive
volume of containers Docker swarm is
docker's alternative to kubernetes it's
a tool that allows you to also manage
large number large numbers of containers
there are differences between the two of
them and right now without doubt the
most popular open source solution out
there is kubernetes from Google it just
has a massive Community behind it and
the community really have embraced
kubernetes and yes the original product
was by developed by Google but Google
has been great stewards and they've
allowed the community to drive the
future evolution of the product Docker
swarm is actually managed and developed
by Docker there is a smaller Community
but it is also a very passionate
community and the reason being is that
both products are actually pretty good
and you just really kind of have to
choose which one you want to go with
without doubt there is more
customization and extensions built for
kubernetes simply because the community
is just so much bigger than the docker
swarm Community
um but with that said Docker swarm is
really easy to set up so if you are used
to working within the docker environment
you'll be able to set up Docker swarm
very very quickly whereas kubernetes
does require some heavy lifting to get
up and running now with that said if you
are using Microsoft Azure or Google
Cloud very often those environments will
actually set up kubernetes for you so
you don't have to do it and you can
actually then focus on writing the
instructions to maintain your kubernetes
environment kubernetes has extremely
high voltage tolerance again it's
because kubernetes is has been Road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on man managing sites such as
Gmail google.com YouTube I mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to Docker swarm which has lower fault
tolerance
um and this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes does
guarantee strong clusters management
just a really reliable environment Dr
swarm however is able to take containers
to deploy them into large casters very
very quickly two interesting differences
is that with kubernetes the load
balancing is still manual and be
interesting to watch how kubernetes
matures that skill set in contrast load
balancing is automatic within Docker
swarm so let's dig into the kubernetes
architecture and just kind of expose
some of those key elements um if you're
interested in actually having a very
deep dive into kubernetes architecture
we have already got another video and we
should have a link in the comments that
you can see select that will take you to
that video as well but this will provide
you an overview as well um so the way
that kubernetes runs is that it uses
nodes to actually manage all the
individual Hardware within a specific
unit and so a node is really a physical
machine in a data center or a virtual
machine and when you're setting up an
environment on a cloud environment such
as Microsoft Azure or Google cloud or
AWS kubernetes will be managing the
containers within that node so it's
important to know that kubernetes itself
doesn't work with the individual nodes
but actually works with the cluster as a
whole and and why that's important is
that it's a tool to manage your entire
environment it's not going to come down
and manage the individual node itself
it's going to match the entire
environment the actual control of data
within a cluster and it's very flexible
within kubernetes you can have local
storage such as an SSD card or a
traditional log local storage or you can
actually connect to the cloud and use
cloud-based storage and the benefit that
cloud-based storage offers you is that
you are increasingly Moving Your
solution into more of a hardware free
environment cloud-based architecture
where you're not reliant on a physical
piece of Hardware within your data
center and why that's important is that
it gives you the opportunity to scale up
your Solutions much more effectively so
if you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud whereas local hardware is a
little bit harder to manage great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from and so the the next
layer down is the actual management of
the application and that's within a
container and as mentioned earlier
Docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
Docker as it was a natural maturity from
using a virtual machine but kubernetes
itself will actually manage the
containers that you have within your
nodes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes will
actually manage the health of that pod
so if a container or a pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pods themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to let kubernetes um do this
because it's allowing you to step away
from the manual management of Parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to from Services outside of
your kubernetes and this is done through
a process called Ingress and going back
earlier we talked about how security is
a key part of all the work that goes
into kubernetes and this is a great
example of where you can use an external
service but still have that layer of
security that is vital for your solution
because to be able to provide the
Ingress connection kubernetes requires
an SSL connection which automatically
allows for a secure data transfer
absolutely fantastic so here we have an
overview of the actual architecture on
the right hand side we have our nodes
and the pods within our nodes and within
those pods are the containers on the
left hand side we have the master
architecture and the master architecture
is the actual brains behind the work
that you're doing it's actually managing
the schedules the controllers for all of
the nodes and then at the bottom left
hand side we have commands which are
written on a local workstation and those
commands are pushed up to the master so
let's kind of dig a little bit further
into the architecture of the master so
the master itself is comprised of a
number of key components again this is
the tool that's going to manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the etcd
control manager scheduler API server and
the key for components are Etc or the
cluster store the controller manager the
scheduler and the API server the cluster
store is the tool where all the details
of the work that you're doing is stored
now it's going to manage the rules it's
going to manage all the instructions and
this is where you're going to post that
information the controller is actually
going to then perform the tasks that are
stored in the cluster store and as you'd
expect the schedule is the tool that
actually controls when instructions and
tasks are pushed out to all the pods and
nodes within your network and then
finally you have an API server which
allows you to be able able to control
all the operations the actual operations
themselves are all the instructions
written as rest instructions and which
allows you to take advantage of the
security that has been built into rest
and so you end up with a worker slave
architecture and slaves are all the
different nodes and pods within your
network and so a pod itself will have
multiple one or more multiple containers
and then each container and then each
pod will have a Docker container a
kublet and a kubernetes proxy and the
these are tools to allow you to
communicate back up to the master layer
so the docker is the actual container
itself and this is going to actually run
your application and the instructions
here are to pull down the correct
container from the docker images that
you have within your library the cubelet
is going to manage your containers and
your container instructions that will be
deployed to the cubelet are going to be
written in either yaml or Json format
yaml is just great if you haven't had a
chance to start working with yaml I
certainly encourage you to do so it's
very easy to pick up if you know any XML
you'll pick up yaml very quickly and
finally the kubernetes proxy is the tool
that interacts with the master
environment within the kubernetes
network and allows all the instructions
from that are pushed to the cubelete and
to Docker to be able to perform
effectively so let's have a look at some
of the companies using kubernetes there
are a lot and if you're doing any work
today in the cloud and even if you're
just starting off and doing some simple
work in the cloud there's a really good
chance that you are using kubernetes for
some of the companies that you would are
probably not surprised at using
kubernetes are Spotify sap eBay and of
course some of the the big companies out
there Google with their entire network
of solutions and Microsoft with office
and their tools so let's take a step
into to a you now let's have a look at a
kubernetes use case and in this example
we're going to look at the New York
Times and how they use kubernetes to
solve a problem that their IIT
Department was struggling with so when
New York Times started working after
their data centers their their actual
deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMS but
the problem is is that as New York Times
became more of a digital company they
started building more digital Solutions
and at some point they realized that
what they needed to do was to embrace
the cloud and move all their solutions
to the cloud however their first step of
using the cloud and this is I think
typical for a lot of companies is that
they treated a the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
Data Center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team I
came in and they said look how about we
stop thinking of our Solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
Amazon and start thinking of them as
Cloud first solution and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using Google Cloud platform with
kubernetes as a service and to provide
greater efficiency and so by using
kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
Solutions at a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they were able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployments it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the New York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having going to do Solutions through a
more traditional ticket based system it
just really speed up the efficiency of
the New York Times website so that's
finally kind of look into some of the
important terminologies before we take
our time to do a demo so we have six
terms that we're going to look through
um and uh we'll let you uh read through
this but uh we have a cluster which is a
set of machines physical vertical in
which applications are managed and run
we have a node that are the working
machines that run containerized
applications and other workloads there
is the pod which is within a node and
there's a group of containers that are
deployed together on the same host we
have replication controllers and a
replication controller is used to define
a pause life cycle rather than to create
the pods directly we have a selector
which is an expression matched label to
filter specific resources labels are key
value pairs that are attached to objects
such as pods and the key value pair or
the label can be filtered organize and
perform operations on resources
replication sense Define how many
replicas of each pod will be running and
managed when you want to either replace
a pod when it dies annotation is a label
with much larger data capacity a name is
a resource as it is identified volume is
the director which data is accessible to
a container namespaces provide
additional qualification to a resources
name and then finally service is an
abstraction of a top-tier pods which
provide a single IP address and DNS Name
by which the pods can be accessed so
this time what we want to do is take you
through kubernetes demo actually runs
through some of these basic controls so
I'm going to take you through a video of
how to actually install kubernetes and
to use some of the basic instructions so
kubernetes is the most wildly used
platform for container management the
first step is to actually install the
necessary dependencies so let's see if
there's any updates first so so the
first so to check if there's any updates
we use the command sudo app dash get
update we're entering our password and
this looks like it's going to take a few
minutes because we've got a few updates
that need to be running all right we're
done all right next we're going to write
sudo apt-get install Dash y
apt-transport https and this will
install all of the dependencies we need
to actually start installing the
solutions needed for kubernetes all
right that was quick now we're going to
put in the docker dependency and the way
we do that is write the command sudo apt
install Docker dot IO I've got a typo
correct that quickly and put in y so vs
and we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install Docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have Docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start Docker and
able Docker using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start enable Docker we're going to be
using so we're going to use sudo
systemctl start Docker and sudo
systemctl enable Docker this will be
quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to install the curl command and
then kubolate Cube C and then cubeadm
and we're going to install all the
necessary tools we'll do the call
command cubelet cubic C2 and Cube ADM
and so let's go ahead and put in the
sudo apt-get install Curl we're going to
get a prompt we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudocal dash s and
then we have a long URL which is https
packages.cloud google.com apt dark
apt-key.gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go create my typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of a folder so we do that
with sudo chmod 777 slash Etc apt slash
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit and we're going to
create a simple file and so what we're
going to type in is the the following
command DB hey cgbt apt dash dot
kubernetes dot IO slash kubernetes Dash
zenial Main and we're going to save this
file in the ETC folder and then look for
and then a APT which is going to be down
a little bit and there we have it and
we're going to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as kubernetes dot list and
we'll save that and then we can close
out the notepad and go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
see if there are any updates again so
we're going to go ahead and run apt-get
update and it's going to run any updates
from what we've created and we want to
check what's in the folder and so we do
cat slash X at ATT Etc apt
sources.d kubernetes dot list and there
we are that shows what we have in that
text file and so we're going to go ahead
and we're going to install uh cubelet
cubic cubic 2 and Cube ADM but first
we're going to have to initialize the
master I'm going to show you what an
error you would get if you were to
install cubelet and the other files too
quickly you get a fine error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm qbx2 and kubernetes CNN and so
we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap up Dash a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo Cube ADM in
it and this will take a few minutes for
it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the Pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cuboo
Cube CTL apply and
we have a long Pathway to type out which
is dash out of hqbs raw githubs
content.com choreos flannel Master
documentation Cube Dash file Dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by now
creating mktr Dash p and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot Cube I'm going
to create that new directory and sudo CP
Dash I and then the path will be
Etc kubernetes
admin.conf and then dollar sign home
slash dot Cube dot slash config
and then final one will be pseudo
c-h-o-w-n dollar sign open Brain ID Dash
U closed paren colon dollar sign a brand
ID slash Dash G close paren dosing home
slash dot Cube config all right now
we're going to go ahead and deploy and
uh let's see and oh yeah I think I have
a typo in my command here yep oh yeah I
did have a typo and so
um I've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spell or the T
not an S and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic Cube CTL
apply dash dash F and then we're just
going to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
pods that we have in our Network and so
we're going to do that by writing the
commands sudo cubic TCL get pods Dash or
all dash dash name spaces and it should
list all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all of our content
now we're going to so there's only one
note so let's see what we have here so
we're going to use the command sudo you
know Quebec TL get nodes there we are
just one node so our final step is to
actually go ahead and deploy a service
and so what we're going to go ahead is
deploy the ngi and access service and
we're going to do that with the command
sudo cubic CTL run Dash Dash image
equals nginx and we're going to put this
into Port 80 so it's going to be nginx
Nash app dash dash Port equals 80 dash
dash environment EMV equals
open quota domain equals cluster close
quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo Cube CTL expose
deployment nginx Dash app dash dash Port
equals 80 dash dash name equals nginx
Dash HTTP and once we've done this we'll
be able to then run the command to
actually see our services and there'll
be quite a few of them
and our final command is sudo docker
ps-a
there we have quite a lot of lists quite
a lot of services listed so there you
are that's the instructions on how to
get Docker up and running and uh with
some basic commands and it is worth
going through a few times to again get
right
um but uh once you actually have
um the uh kubernetes environment up and
running and managing your Docker
environment and containers it's
extremely powerful we're going to take a
deep dive into the kubernetes
architecture so we're going to break out
the presentation into the following
areas we're going to cover what
kubernetes is and why you'd want to be
using it we're going to introduce the
actual architecture and provide an
overview of how it contains the
containers and the other components that
you'd have within the architecture we'll
also compare kubernetes with Docker
swarm and one of the things that you
hear with kubernetes almost in the same
breath as Docker and we have to be
careful not to confuse Docker from a
container point of view and Docker swarm
which is a container management tool and
kubernetes is also a container
management tool so compared to to those
and then we'll look at the hardware and
software components and then finally do
a deep dive into the architecture of
kubernetes and provide a case study of
where kubernetes is being used
successfully in the past so let's jump
into this so what actually is kubernetes
so kubernetes is a tool that was
designed to actually help manage and
contain large groups of containers it
was developed originally by Google out
of the Google book solution and then
Open Source by Google the actual
environment allows you to manage large
groups of containers so if you are a
developer and devops and you're working
with Docker then you're used to the
concept of a container and you'll also
know that containers and Cloud
Technologies tend to be almost breathed
in the same breath so the work that
you're doing with kubernetes is to be
able to manage large groups of
containers inside of the cloud the thing
that's great about working with
kubernetes is that it is incredibly
flexible and allows you to have
incredibly complex applications run
efficient efficiently so let's step into
why you'd want to use kubernetes so a
couple of key points kubernetes itself
is an open source solution originally
developed by Google but it is available
on most Cloud platforms today so AWS
Google Cloud Microsoft Azure all of them
support kubernetes and what you'll find
is as you're setting up your
infrastructure particularly if you're
using containers you'll see that the
support for kubernetes is flooded up
very very efficiently and effectively by
all three vendors it's extremely um
useful for being able to manage large
modular environments and that's really
kind of these I think one of the big
benefits of kubernetes is its modularity
is that it really breaks down uh
containers into their smaller parts and
once you do that it becomes much more
efficient for you as an administrator to
be able to manage that entire
environment the reproductibility of
kubernetes is extremely high you can
build out infrastructures very quickly
and have them being able to manage and
have containers coming on and off and
killed and created to be able to help
load balance your entire environment and
so again you know we keep talking about
containers but that's really what
kubernetes is all about is being able to
manage your applications that are
managed through containers and being
able to do that in a virtualized
infrastructure and the thing that's also
really good with kubernetes is it's
really easy to deploy Solutions you just
have to use a simple curl call and you
can actually push out your kubernetes
infrastructure so let's have an overview
of the kubernetes architecture so
kubernetes has really broken up into
three key areas you have your work
session where you develop your commands
and you push out those commands to your
master and the master is comprised of
four key areas which essentially control
all of your nodes and the node contains
multiple pods and each pod has your
Docker container built into it so
consider that you could have a really
almost an infinite number of PODS I'm
sorry infinite number of nodes are being
managed by the master environment so you
have your cluster which is a collection
of servers that maintain the
availability and the compute power such
as RAM CPU and disk utilization and you
have the master which is really
components that control and schedule the
activities of your network and then you
have the node which actually hosts the
actual Docker virtual machine itself and
be able to actually control and
communicate back to the master the
health of that pod and we'll get into
more detail on the architecture later in
the presentation so you know you keep
hearing me talk about containers but
they really are the center of the work
that you're doing with kubernetes and
can the concept around kubernetes and
containers is really just a natural
evolution of where we've been with
internet and digital Technologies over
the last uh 10 15 years so before
kubernetes you had two tools where
you're either running virtual machines
or you're running data centers that had
to maintain and manage and notify you of
any interruptions in your network
kubernetes is the tool that actually
comes in and helps address those
interruptions and manages them for you
so the solution to this is the use of
containers so you can think of
containers as that Natural Evolution
from you know uh 15 20 years ago you
would have written your code and posted
it to a Data Center and more recently
you probably posted your code to a
virtual machine and then move the
virtual machine and now you actually
just work directly into a container and
everything is self-contained and can be
pushed out to your environment and the
thing that's great about containers
they're they're isolated environments
very easy for developers to work on them
but it's also really easy for operations
teams to be able to move a container
into production so let's kind of step
and back and look at a competing product
to kubernetes cities which is Docker
swarm now one of the things we have to
remember is that darker containers which
are extremely popular are built by the
company Docker and made open source and
Docker actually has other products one
of those other products is Docker swarm
and Docker swarm is a tool that allows
you to be able to manage multiple
containers so if we look at some of the
uh the benefits of using Docker swarm
versus kubernetes now one thing that
you'll find is that both tools have
strengths and weaknesses but it's really
good that they're both out there because
it helps keep it really kind of
justifies uh the importance of having
these kind of tools so kubernetes was
designed originally from the ground up
to be Auto scaling whereas took a swarm
isn't the load balancing is automatic on
Docker Swan whereas with kubernetes you
have to manually configure load
balancing across your nodes the
installation for Docker swarm is really
fast and easy I mean you can be up and
running within minutes kubernetes takes
a little bit more time is a little bit
more complicated eventually you'll get
there um I mean it's not like it's going
to take you days and weeks but it's it
is a tool that's a when you compare the
two Docker swarms much easier to get up
and running now what's interesting is
that kubernetes is incredibly scalable
and it's you know that's it's real
strength is its ability to have strong
clusters whereas with Docker swarm it's
cluster stream isn't um as strong when
compared to kubernetes now you compare
it to anything else on the market it's
really good um so this is kind of a
splitting hairs kind of comparison but
kubernetes really does have the
advantage here if you're looking at the
two compared to each other for
scalability kubernetes was designed for
by Google to scale up and support Google
Cloud Network infrastructure they both
allow you to be able to share um storage
volumes with Docking you can actually do
it with any container with that is
managed by the docker swamp whereas with
kubernetes it may manages the storage
with the pods and a pod can have
multiple containers within it but you
can't take it down to the level of the
container interestingly kubernetes does
have a graphical user interface for
being able to control and manage the
environment the reality however is that
you're likely to be using terminal to
actually make the controls and Commands
to control your either Docker swarm or
kubernetes environment it's great that
it has a GUI and to get you started but
once you're up and running you're going
to be using terminal window for those
fast quick administrative controls that
you need to make so let's look at the
hardware components for kubernetes so
and what's interesting is that
kubernetes is extremely light of all the
systems that we're looking at is
extremely lightweight
um it's allows you to have if you
compare it to like a virtual machine
which is very heavy you know kubernetes
is extremely lightweight and other uses
any resources at all interesting enough
is that if you are looking at the usage
of CPU it's better to actually take it
for
um the cluster as a whole rather than
individual nodes because the nodes will
actually combined together to give you
that whole compute power again this is
why kubernetes works really well in the
cloud where you can do that kind of
activity rather than if you're running
in your own data center
um so you can have persistent volumes um
such as a local SSD or you can actually
attach to a cloud data storage again
kubernetes is really designed for the
cloud I would encourage you to use cloud
storage wherever possible rather than
relying on physical storage and the
reason being is that if you connect to
cloud storage and you need to flex your
your storage the cloud will do that for
you I mean that's just an inherent part
of why you'd have cloud storage whereas
if you're connecting to physical storage
you're always restricted to the
limitations of the physical Hardware so
that's um kind of pivot and look at the
software components as can compared to
the hardware components so the main part
of the components is the actual
container and all of the software
running in the container runs on Linux
so if you have documents stored as a
developer on your machine it's actually
running inside of Linux and that's what
makes it so lightweight and really one
of the things that you'll find is that
most data centers and Cloud providers
now are running predominantly on Linux
inside of the um the the container
itself is then managed inside of a pod
and a pod is really just a group of
containers bundles together and the
kubernetes scheduler and proxy server
then actually manage what how the pods
are actually pushed out into your
kubernetes environment the the pods
themselves can actually then share
resources both networking and storage so
the pods aren't pushed out manually
they're actually managed through a layer
of abstraction and part of their
deployment and and this is the strength
of kubernetes you use to find your
infrastructure and then kubernetes will
then manage it for you and there isn't
that problem of manual management of
PODS if you have to manage the
deployment of them and you that's simply
taken away and it's completely automated
and the the final area of software
Services is on Ingress and this is
really the secure way of being able to
have communication from outside of the
cluster and passing of information into
that cluster and again this is done
securely through SSL layers and allows
you to ensure that security is at the
center of the work that you have within
your kubernetes environment so let's
dive now into the actual architecture
before we start looking at a use case of
how kubernetes is being employed so
kubernetes again is um we looked at this
uh diagram at the beginning of the
presentation and there are really three
key areas there's the workstation where
you develop your commands and then you
have your master environment which
controls the scheduling communication
and the actual commands that you have
created and pushes those out and manages
the health of your entire node Network
and each node has various pods so we
like break this down so the masternode
is the most vital component with the
master you have four key controls you
have Etc the controller manager schedule
an API server the cluster store Etc this
actually measures the details and values
that you've developed on your local
workstation and then we'll work with the
out the control schedule and API server
to communicate that out those
instructions of how your infrastructure
should look like to your entire network
the control manager is really an API
server and again this is all about
security so we use restful apis which
can be packaged in SSL to communicate
back and forth across your pods and the
master and indeed the services within
each other them as well so at every
single layer of extraction the
communication is secure the schedule as
the name would imply really schedules
and when tasks get sent out to the
actual nodes themselves the nodes
themselves are are dumb nodes they just
have the applications um running on them
the master and the scum is really doing
all of the work to make sure that your
entire network is running efficiently
and then you have the API server which
has your rest commands and the
communication and back and forth across
your networks that is secure and
efficient so your node environment is
where all the work that you do with your
containers gets pushed out too so
um a work is really a it's a combination
of containers and each container will
then logically run together on that node
so you'd have a collection of containers
on a node that all make logical sense to
have together within each node you have
a Docker and this is your isolated
environment for running your container
uh you have your cubelet which is a
service for conveying information back
and forth to the service about the
actual health of the kubernetes node
itself and then finally you have the
proxy server and the proxy server is
able to manage the nodes the volumes the
the creation of new containers
um and actually helps pass the community
the the health of the container back up
to the master to see whether or not the
containers should be either killed
stop-started or updated so finally let's
look at see where kubernetes is being
used by other companies so you know
kubernetes is being used by a lot of
companies and they're really using it to
help manage complex existing systems so
that they can have greater performance
and with the end goal of being able to
Delight the customer increase value to
the customer and enhance increased value
and revenue into the organization so
example of this is a company called
BlackRock where they actually went
through the process of implementing
kubernetes and so they could so
BlackRock had a times where they need to
be able to have much more Dynamic access
to their resources they were running
complex installations on people's
desktops and it was just really really
difficult to be able to manage their
entire infrastructure so they actually
went and pivoted to using kubernetes and
this allowed them to be able to be much
more scalable and expansive in the in
the management of their infrastructure
and as you can imagine kubernetes was
then hooked into their entire existing
system and has really become a key part
of the success that BlackRock is now
experiencing of a very stable
infrastructure and the bottom line is
that BlackRock is now able to have
confidence in their infrastructure and
be able to give their confidence as back
to their customers through the
implementation and more rapid deployment
of additional features and services but
what it is specific to AWS Cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at the offset I like to cover the
basics of orchestration tools as most of
you would know kubernetes is one of the
most popular orchestration tools in
recent times specifically for
applications which are Cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
orchestration tools why would one need
to use orchestration tools what are the
facilities of features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that I'm going to cover after that
I will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management Docker
swarm vs kubuntis I am going to compare
them with regard to the features that
they provide the use cases that they
cover what facilities that they provide
and when to use what after that I will
get into little bit details of the
kubernetes architecture what exactly is
required for setting up a kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that I will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on AWS platform I will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting up
production grade kubernetes cluster so I
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on AWS all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools the
application development and the life
cycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault tolerance self-healing
capabilities Auto scaling all this as
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all these
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you'll have to just
let them know what are the kinds of tool
sets that is required what are the fault
tolerance mechanisms that it has to be
adopted to what kind of a self-healing
capabilities that application will have
to need and if at all there is any auto
scaling features that is required if at
all you can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a One-Stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where this orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management Docker swarm and
kubuntus many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with Apache
me Source there are many other container
management systems but I am pick Docker
swarm and kubernetes for comparing the
features that is provided by these two
Frameworks for the sake of comparison I
picked up Docker swarm and kubuntis just
because of the reason that both of them
operate in the space of container
management they do something very very
similar to Containers that's the
similarity that exists between these two
orchestration tools however there's a
big difference that exists when it comes
to the types of containers that both of
them cater to and also the capacity of
workloads they can be used for Docker
swarm is a cluster management solution
that is provided by Docker container
Docker is one of the very very popular
containers of recent times and in case
you have your applications that is
totally powered by only Docker
containers if you have a need where you
want to run a cluster of servers which
are running only Docker containers
Docker swarm should be your choice for
your orchestration tool kubernetes this
on the other hand can cater to any other
types of containers other than Docker
and including Docker as well so in case
you have your applications which have
got Docker in them which I've got rkt in
them which they have got Alex in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a Docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 Max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in Docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is about 50 60 nodes Docker
swarm should be a choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is something that was open
sourced by Google and the kind of the
scale of operations that kubernetes can
cater to is Google scale so if in case
your applications are more than a
thousand nodes that is where kubernetes
comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between Docker
swarm and kubernetes putting those
differences aside let me compare docos
form and kubernetes based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first and important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as Auto scaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and an
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMS or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the Fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify few
of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the of less
of Auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in Docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application load balancing so Docker
swarm gives you an application Level
Auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as I
mentioned earlier Docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loose coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the Swarms on the fly so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many Master known
so many conflict planes that you want
how many nodes that you want it's a
pretty tough thing to bring up a
kubernetes scalability kubernetes
strength is very very strong they are
very tightly coupled and even they have
the capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the Fly based upon the requirement on a
Docker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to kubernetes worker
nodes can be added to a swarm worker
nodes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
Loosely coupled architecture for Docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docus warm
runs only Docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and a
lot of other things with each other
because they all have the same signature
they are all from the same family so
it's very easy for them to share not
just volumes but a lot of other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if
application as to share some data across
different containers there's a little
bit of a complexity in how you would
want your containers to share data also
when it comes to kubernetes kubernetes
groups containers in something called as
pods while a pod can have either one
container that's the preferred choice or
multiple containers and the idea of pod
is like each pod can run in any other
node it's not guaranteed that you would
want to have two or three parts to be
running on the same node that makes data
sharing a little bit of a different
thing compared to docus form uh GUI so
there's not a good enough UI tool in
Dockers form at least the CE edition of
it which will allow you to get to know
what is running on your containers what
is the size of the containers what is
the volume of the containers and all
that stuff there are some free and open
source tools like portainer which gives
you a good visibility into your running
Docker containers however there's
nothing at a swarm level that is
provided by docker abilities gives you
an out of the box dashboard which is
easy to configure and set up you can
also Club it with some metrics services
and you can also get information about
the size of the cluster that is running
what is the load on the nodes and stuff
like that all this across your cluster
in a very beautiful dashboard
perspective so that way this is little
bit of a good UI for kubernetes file for
Dockers form there isn't anything that
is provided out of the box let me spend
some time in explaining a little bit
about the kubernetes architecture what
comprises of the kubernetes cluster what
resides in a master or a control plane
and what resides in a worker node this
is a very high level depiction of a
kubernetes cluster so this is the master
node which has got something called as a
cluster store a controller a scheduler
component and an EPA server and these
are the bunch of nodes that are
connected or administered by the master
node the master node can be 1 3 Phi
typically an odd number this is as per a
typical cluster management thing where
you would need the master nodes to be in
odd numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to whom and stuff like that all the
Masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubic
CTL or the command from using which
anybody can assign some workloads to the
cluster can also be run either on the
same node or on a separate node so Cube
CTL is the command line tool that we
will be installing and using in order to
fire up our commands to our cluster so
if at all I have to put up a job on our
cluster if I have to give out any
specific commands to my cluster all this
is done using cubic CTL there's a bunch
of rest apis which is used by Q CTL and
Cube CTL will talk to the API server and
fire up the commands specific to my
cluster what runs in the master node
Master node without saying it's the most
important component of any of the
cluster if at all you're running
um cluster with only one must node if
your master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so Master node is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's a bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store be 4
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
Daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of workload that is
running based upon the configuration
that the user has set in so if at all if
you are aware of something called as a
replication controllers endpoint
controllers namespace controllers all
these controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
Pod goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the Pod
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what and in the cluster and
places the workload on whoever is the
available resource at that time all
right APA server this is one other
important component in in our kubernetes
cluster where how would the end user
deploy or give out any sort of a
workload onto your cluster all the
requests come to the aps server so this
is an entry point for all your requests
that come into your cluster anybody who
wants to deploy something anybody want
to scale up a controller anybody who
wants to bring down few Services anybody
wants to put in a service all this will
have to come in as a part of a rest API
endpoint and API server is the entry
point in case you don't want want you
know somebody to access your cluster in
case you want only specific people or
specific users to be running some
specific workloads you can set all those
role-based access control for this API
server so this is the entry point for
anyone who wants to submit any job to
your cluster so that's a quick overview
about the master node what what are the
important components of a master node
now let's go over to what runs in a
worker or a slave node as I mentioned
earlier slave nodes are something where
the job that is submitted to your
cluster is eventually run as a pod as a
service as a container so in kubernetes
world there's something called as a pod
a pod is nothing but a combination of a
container it is a wrapper around your
running containers so slave nodes are
the worker nodes typically run these
parts so that is where the whole
workload typically gets run but there
are a bunch of other components in the
in the node which also manages what runs
in the Pod who has to have access to the
Pod what is the state of the Pod is it
in a running state is it going down for
some reason and all this stuff so let's
quickly go over those components that is
there in the slave node the most
important component in my opinion that
should be on the on the Node should be
the container runtime as I mentioned
earlier kubernetes can run any different
types of containers not just Docker so
in case you want to have a node which
wants to have Docker running on it rkt
running or at LKC running on it or any
other container environment that is
running on it you have to ensure that
the specific container runtime
environment is available on that
specific node so that whenever a job is
submitted description of what needs to
be run as a part of the Pod what should
be the image with it should be powered
and what kind of a container to spin up
so that's what you know when the job is
finally assigned to this particular node
it would definitely need a container
runtime to be up and running so that
exists only if at all the container
runtime is installed and running on your
kubernetes worker node okay now that we
know what our kubernetes node can run
how would somebody assign a job to our
node that is using something called as a
cube alert as the name says cubelet or
cube alert is a small subset which talks
to the cube API server so any node which
has to run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qvps server to the cubelet and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um Affinity
towards any node on which these parts
are running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere so how would somebody
reach out to these applications that is
running in some pod which is running in
one container now and running in
probably another container another node
all together tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy contains a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these spots and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a DNS server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the pod on which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a network proxy now that at
a very high level we know what are all
the components that make up of our
kubernetes cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on AWS platform finally we
get to the demo section of my two
tutorial now that you guys are aware as
to what is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node probably
you're thinking that it's going to be
pretty hard to kind of set this up so
let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple three node kubernetes cluster
using a tool called cops and I will be
doing this whole setup on my AWS Cloud
okay so what is cops cops is nothing but
a simple tool is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as I said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
which I'll spin up on my AWS instance so
I have an AWS account and what I'll do
first is I will first spin up an ec2
server I will power this with one of the
Linux Amis and I will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where I'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case I'll try to keep
it little small I don't want too many
nodes in my Thruster I'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know AWS is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what I
would do is I will create an IAM role
which will attach to my S2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that I'm going to specify
all right so once I have my cluster set
up I will also install cubic CTL which
you would probably know by now is
nothing but a command utility using
which I can kind of connect to my
cluster give out some jobs put some
parts and stuff like that so I will use
Cuba CTL I will also have a pair of SSH
keys so that from this machine I would
be able to successfully get onto the
master node and submit jobs on my behalf
so let me Begin by first logging into my
AWS account all the steps that I will be
following to bring up my AWS cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and I'll be sharing you this document in
a GitHub repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that I would need is to
launch an AWS ec2 instance now this is
an instance where I am going to install
cops and I will use it as a base server
from where I'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
AWS account and let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
um it doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire I would recommend choose free tire
only and choose an Ami of your choice
let me choose this instance I will make
it T2 micro that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
I don't want to change anything here so
that looks good maybe I will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance I will name this as
my cops server alright I would need a
bunch of ports to be opened up so what I
will do is I'll create a new security
group called open to the word I would
not recommend that you do this since I
don't want to it will take a long time
for me to specifically just pick and
choose the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster I don't want to do
that I will open up all the HTTP and
https ports so that it's quicker so I
will say all TCP I would say from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open HTTP and https and I will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me I will say review on launch
alright so I chose rt2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness I've
opened up all the ports and the instant
details are you've seen what is that
I've chosen all right now important part
is like I would need a keypad I need to
create a new keypad I will call this as
simply learn keys I will download this
key pair and then I will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what I'll do is I will convert I have
this pem file which is the pair of keys
the SSH keys with which I need to log
into my ec2 instance so I'll need to
convert this because I'm trying to
connect from my Windows box I would need
to convert this into a VPK file so I
have put engine I am going to load my
set of keys here and convert that key
into a ppk3 all right open all right I
would say save hang on Save privately
yes I would say simply learn or simply
non-private private key I will save this
here and that that's all so this is my
public key which is the pem file and
this is my PPK or my private key Now
using the private key I will log into my
ec2 instance okay now my ec2 instance is
up and running it is running in this
Ohio region and this is the IP address
of my public IP address of my machine so
let me connect to it so I use mobile
exterm which is nothing but an SSH
emulator you can use putty or any of
these sessions which allow you to do an
SSH and this is my ipe address of my
machine and since I've spun up an Amazon
Ami the user this is the default user I
would need to specify the private keys
for my session and this is the private
key for my session say okay I am in my
Amazon ec2 instance so let me look at
what are the other things that I need to
do all right so as I said I just brought
up my ec2 instance but I would need my
ec2 instance to run few things on my
behalf so that it can spin up easy to
other ec2 instances it can also talk to
an S3 bucket where I'm going to store
the instant state of my kubernetes
cluster also some sort of an auto
scaling group because I want to spin up
more and more instances I also want to
have a private hosted Zone using my
Route 53 so I would need my ec2 instance
to have all these sort of permissions
for my server so what I would do is I
will go and create a permission a role
in the ec2 or rather in the AWS IM role
and I will attach this I am role to my
ec2 instance all right so let me go to
my IAM which is nothing but the iron
entity and access management I'll create
a role called as possibly cops role I
will create a role this role will be
used by my ec2 so I'm going to click on
ec2 I will say next permissions they
would need a lot of permissions uh
specific permissions to be very honest
and the permissions are all listed out
here S3 ec2 and all this stuff just to
keep it pretty simple what I would do is
I'll create a role with the
administrative axis all right so I don't
want any tags I'm going to review I'll
create a role name I will say cops fold
for ec2 all right so I'm going to create
a rule which has got administrative
access rules I'm going to create a role
so this would ensure that my ec2
instance from which I am going to run a
my cluster would have all the
prerequisite permission so that it can
go and spin up instances talk to S3
buckets and all that stuff all right now
let us have our running instance get
powered by this role so I will connect
this role to my running instance all
right so this is my easy to instant that
is running I will say action attached
attach attach attach replace IM roles so
there is no rule as of now I would want
my cops roll for easy to zero that I
created so I want this new room to be
assigned to my ec2 all right great now
my ec2 instance which is my cop server
has got all the required permissions so
that he can create a cluster on my
behalf great now before this let me do a
sudo yum update hyphen y so that any of
the because this is a newly provisioned
VM I just want to ensure that all my
library system libraries are all updated
so that when I do install cop and Cube
CTL and all those things none of them
will fail because of some dependency or
package issues so I'm just running a
sudo update iPhone y so that all the
libraries are updated okay looks like it
is done so let me go ahead and install
cops cops is a pretty simple
installation it is available in a
particular location I have to just copy
this and ensure that I do a curve and I
install this particular stuff all right
so it is fetching the cops tool it's
installing for me once it is copied down
let me change the mode so that I can
execute it and then also let me move it
to my user local bin so that it is
available for me in my path okay that's
pretty much the cops installation let me
also do one other thing let me install
something called as cubic CTL so this is
what would be you know a tool using
which I'm going to be firing my commands
to my kubernetes cluster once it comes
up right this is a pretty smaller
executable so keep sitting on all right
so I have Cube CTL as well as cops
installed on my ec2 server now okay now
what I'll do next is I'm going to create
an S3 bucket in AWS so that the
equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name S3
bucket with this name so let me go to S3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name I will just say create a
bucket okay so this simply learn dot
kubernetes is the bucket that I created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
go and create a DNS entry or a DNS zone
or AWS Route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know I can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that I'm coming up so
I will create a private hosted Zone and
possibility possibly I will call this as
simply learn.in so this will be my name
of my private hosted Zone in case you
already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
Route 53 hosted Zone specific for your
domain name since I don't have any one
I'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to Route 53 click on any of these and
you'll get these hosted zones out here
so I'm going to create a hosted Zone
here I'm going to create a hosted Zone
click on create hosted Zone
um this would be simply learn.in I want
to create a public no I don't want it
public I want a private hosted Zone and
I'm going to associate my VPC ID for
this hosted Zone since I'm going to try
out all my exercises in the Ohio region
I will associate the VPC of the Ohio
region for this all right so this is the
one that is specific to the Ohio region
so I will say this one I'll say create a
hosted so great now let me come back to
my ec2 box my ec2 is all powered with
whatever it needs in order to go out
with the installation of my cluster only
few things that I need to take care of
is that you know now that I put a name
for my cluster I also have an S3 bucket
that I've configured for my cluster I
will have to ensure that I need to put
in these two configurations as a part of
my cluster building activity so I will
open my bash RC file and I'm going to
export these two variables if at all you
remember well these two variables are
nothing but the cluster name which is
nothing but the public or sorry the
private hosted Zone that it created and
the S3 bucket where I'm going to create
or rather I'm going to store my cluster
state so let me copy these two and open
up my bash RC file all right so I will
just add these two and copy these and
Export them out as my variable I'm going
to save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right I've got
these two that have configured and I've
also ensure that this environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of SSH keys this is to ensure that
I can log into the box that I'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
SSH iPhone Keygen I don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so I
created a bunch of my key pair now I'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how I would Define my
cops command I kind of copy here so cops
create cluster the state of the cluster
will be stored in this particular
variable which is what I have exported
out the number of node count is two node
count is the worker node count if at all
I don't specif there's a configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if I don't specify that the
default one is one so I'm going to
create one primary or the master node
and to worker nodes uh size of my master
Note size of the worker nodes or what
are the zones where I want this to be
created and where do I store the cluster
information and okay I've already added
this must account this is actually not
required but this is the command that
I'm going to fire off so that I bring up
my cluster all right that went off very
fast but this actually did not create a
cluster it is just the definition of a
cluster and that's why this came out
very fast now that everything looks good
with whatever configuration that is
specified now let me go ahead and create
the cluster base in cops update cluster
hyphen iPhone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good five to ten minutes for
it too because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as I
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration I'm going to come up with
one master server and two notes or the
worker nodes all right so this is the
command for me to validate the cluster
and I'm going to try it out first I'm
pretty sure that will fail because all
my servers are not up yet it is taking
some time the validation everything
failed but let me try to look at my ec2
instances and see how many servers do I
have running as of now if you see I had
only one server that had started which
was my cop server and automatically the
other three instances one is called
notes dot simply not in and this these
two are the nodes and this is the master
node so these three got automatically
provisioned by the cops command that I
ran all right so this may take a while
for it to get validated and good 5-10
minutes so what I'll do is I'll pause
the video now and I'll come back once
the server the cluster is up and running
it's been a good uh eight to nine
minutes since I started my cluster so
let me validate now okay seems good so
this is a master node uh minimum One Max
one some nodes which are nothing but the
slave nodes or the worker nodes there
are two of them due to micro uh subnet
so my clusters seem to be up and running
and my cluster name is billon.in so what
I would want to do is now let me just
log into the master and see if I can run
some parts so let me get back to my
installation steps here the validation
cluster is done so let me log into my
since my cluster name is simply learn.n
this is the way to log into my box so
let me get into my logs so if you see
here this is the host name of the
machine that I'm currently in if you see
this this is nothing but our this cop
server this is now from here I'm trying
to get into this Master box all right so
if you see the IP address has changed I
was in a different box I'm in a
different box now if I see host name
you'll find our different host name so
this is 153 which is nothing but the
master node yep that's 153 this is the
particular host so I'm getting into this
machine now so I started the cluster
from my cop server here it ran and
brought up three nodes so I'm actually
getting into my master node and see if I
can run some parts on it alright so let
me try cubic CTL get cluster info right
Cube CTL get nodes all right so there
are three nodes here Master node and one
master node and two worker nodes so let
me see if I have some pods here give the
CTL get pods there's no Port as of now
so what I'll try to do is let me just
pin up a very very simple Pawn just to
check if my connections is everything is
correct or not correct I have a simple
node.js application that I have built
and I've got a container for that this
is already pushed to the docker up
registered is called simply run Docker
Hub and the image name that I have here
is called my node app and I will use
this image to power one of my parts that
I will run so this is the way in which I
am going to launch my pod let me show
you this commands Cube CTL run the name
for my deployment that I'm going to run
hyphen iPhone image and this is the
image that is going to be powering my
container so this is simply learn Docker
rub forward slash my node app hyphen F1
replica is equal to I want two replicas
to be running and the port that I want
to expose this particular part is on
8080. so let me run this as soon as this
is run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
I'm not really interested in the
deployment I'm interested in checking
effect all the parts are up and running
so I will say Cube CTL get what all
right so that was pretty fast so I have
two parts that are running here these
are two replicas because I asked for two
replicas these parts are running so I
can run Cube CTL describe pod pickup all
right I can pick up any of the name and
see what is the Pod what is the
information does it contain from what is
the image that is pulling what is the
image image Name ID this is actually
running my thought which is actually
spinning up a container great so first
of good so in kubernetes the pods can
are ephemeral so they can be there at
any time cannot be runtime if I need to
expose my Pawn outside I will have to
create a service for my pod so what I'll
do is I'll create a very very simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that you check Cube
CDL get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so I
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as um yeah I'll just expose this let
me see all right I'm not specifying what
type and all I don't want to get into
the complications of what are the
different types of exposing this service
and all that stuff so if I don't specify
anything it gives me something closer
cluster ID so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this pod is up and running I'll
just try a simple curl command curl HTTP
colon this is my cluster IP and the port
is 880. if at all I hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me uh whatever I put a simple uh
sys dot out kind of a thing where I'm
just printing
um the container ID of whatever pod is
serving uh mix out of so I'm actually
eating my container and I'm getting this
output from the content so everything
looks good my content is up and running
so let me just go and clean it up I will
say Cube CTL delete deployment simply
learn app this should get rid of all the
parts that I created Cube CTL get pod
all right these parts are interminating
things let me just check Cube CTL get
Services there's one service I don't
want this service let me delete that
keep CTL delete service I want this all
right that sounds good so let me come
back to my host my cop server from where
I'm running so I managed to successfully
verify this part see if everything is up
and running so what I'll do is I'll just
go ahead and complete this demo by going
and getting rid of my cluster so cops
delete cluster hyphen iPhone yes all
right so this will ensure that it will
clean up my complete cluster that I
created so I had three or four running
instances if you see then all the three
are shutting down because you know the
cop server which had cops installed on
it uh has now got a mandate to go ahead
and shut down and clean up the whole
instances and all those things that are
created as a part of my deployment
hello this is Matthew from Simply learn
we're going to focus specifically on
puppet so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to cover what
and why you would use puppets what are
the different elements and components of
puppet and how does it actually work and
then we'll look into the companies that
are adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write and manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where publish shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
Ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out and to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working States or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out Solutions so let's dig deeper into
what pubbit actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like Chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software automatically you can deploy
your software to all of your systems or
to specific systems and this is all done
with code this means you can test the
environment and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed accurately so let's go
through those components of Puppets so
here we have a breakdown of the puppet
environment and on the top we have the
main server environment and then below
that we have the client environment that
would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network so if we look at the top
part of the screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
their clients we have templates that
combine our codes together to render a
final document and you have files that
will be deployed as content that could
be potentially downloaded by the clients
wrapping this all together is a module
of manifest templates and files you
would apply a certificate authority to
sign the actual document so that the
clients actually know that they're
receiving the appropriate and authorized
modules outside of the master server
where you'd create your manifest
templates and files you would have
public clients as a piece of software
that is used to configure a specific
machine there are two parts to the
client one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the master server to
ensure that the certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact that the current state of the
client that is used and communicated
back to through the agent so now that we
know what puppet is
architecture so puppet has a Master
Slave architecture as you as you see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and Below we have the puppet
clients so the Puppet Master is a system
where your system administrator sits the
clients are those systems which require
configuration you can have n number of
clients connected to the puppet master
so don't worry we look into each of
these components in detail firstly we
have the puppet master so the Puppet
Master is where the system administrator
sits and he or she types in the codes
here so the codes are not only written
in the system but they are also stored
here and whenever the client requires
these codes for their configuration they
simply request it so manifest is the
first sub-competent of the Puppet Master
these are the actual files where the
codes are written so in case of puppet
these are Ruby files module style
manifest templates and files into a
single unit now these codes dictate the
instructions for performing various
tasks on your client the next component
is templates so if manifests are your
code templates are the data so let me
explain this to you with an example
consider you want to create a file
called index.html on one of your client
machines so what you do is you write the
code for creating this file in your
manifest and the content of this file is
written in your templates then you
simply link them but here's the thing
when you divide your code and data in
this way it's a very clean structure so
it's prefer to do it in this manner
files are your static contents so the
files are basically sent to your client
and they are simply downloaded at the
client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the passer at the master itself
modules ties the Manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
Puppet Master CA which stands for
certificate Authority now as we will see
later in this video The Puppet Master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of SSL certificates
so when the client sends over the
certificate to the master CA provides
the master the authority to sign these
certificates the minute the master signs
a certificate the master is basically
saying that yes this client is
registered with me and I agree to
exchange data with this client a next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have Factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our clients
and sending this data over to the Puppet
Master at the master this data is
compared against the Manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
Master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the SSL
certificates SSL stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted Channel between two components
what this encrypted Channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete Security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the puppet master or the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with Master Slave
architect texture so the client so far
is not a client it is just a system and
we will refer to the system as system a
so system a sends over a client
certificate to the master associated
with this client certificate is the host
name of system a now Master goes through
this certificate it's easy host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
this signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
I am willing to exchange information
with this system and I do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master Sciences certificate
sends it back and the client requests
for data now by data here of course we
mean the configuration data those are
the manifests or even could be your
files so what happens after this request
after this request the factor service
which is present on your clients
collects all the information regarding
the present state of your client so this
information could include the operating
system that's installed on them the
various number of software present on
them the versions of these software now
all this information is collected it's
called the fat and it's sent over to the
master at the master this information
that is the facts is compared against
the Manifest so why does the master do
this the master basically compares the
facts against the Manifest to know if
what the Manifest is about to perform is
already performed on these systems so if
the Manifest has some additional
functionality they are compiled into
catalogs and then these catalogs are
sent over to the client now remember
those agent Services which existed in
your clients here's where they come in
the agents take the catalog and execute
them on the client once executed these
catalogs make the required changes on
the client and a report is generated
this report is then sent back to the
master so the master keeps record of all
the changes that's made in the system
and this comes very handy when one of
the systems fail and it's required to be
rolled back to its previous working
state so this entire procedure can be
repeated n number of times and can be
repeated at regular intervals so if you
have a scenario where a system needs to
be configured every 30 minutes what you
can do is you can set your interval and
automatically every 30 minutes your
systems will be configured so today I'll
be showing you how you can use puppet to
install Apache on one of your client
machines so we'll be using two machines
here we'll have a server and we'll have
a node machine the server is essentially
your master the node is your client I'm
just using the term server and node
instead because I want to keep it very
close to as they are used in the command
now both these machines are going to be
sent to as seven machines and I have
Oracle VM virtualbox installed on my
machine so on that I've simply created
two virtual boxes both Center S7 of
course so before we move on to the
actual demo I'll just take you through
the various steps so first we'll install
the puppet server on our server or
Master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start this service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service and SSL certificate is created
so this certificate will have the host
name of your node attached to it and
this is how the master or the server
will recognize this certificate and then
it'll sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifest
so the Manifest has just the codes for
configuration and once that too is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the Asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your catalogs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course it's the client
so let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the Master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our Master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you missed this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the host
name the last word you see there that's
the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our
hostname is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the IP of this
machine so for that you just type if
config
enter
so this is your IP guys
under enp 0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the IP will
differ for you guys needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is sudo because
we want the root permission
system
CTL
top
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the Puppet
Labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net also you won't
be getting an IP if it's not for the
first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lab
oh
foreign
again
okay so the Puppet Labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppet server on the
Master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so I just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change in
our system config puppet server file so
let's just move to the file first
this file will open in VI editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2GB
so we are going to reduce the size
512 MB should be enough
so guys notice here I did not type the B
okay so I just changed this to XMS
512 m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite Troublesome okay so
now we can start a puppet server service
foreign
okay so that's done so basically our
puppet server service has started it's
running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our Etc
host file with sudo because you need to
make a few changes and save it open this
in the vi terminal
foreign
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the IP for your puppet server
machine
puppet
Dash master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading Puppet
Labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
all right
so Puppet Labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent Services
installed we'll start this service so
I'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
thank you foreign
stop to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the servers start running but
an SSL certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the
hostname of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's localhost.local domain so a
certificate should have this attached to
it so guys the first time your client
sends a certificate the name of the
certificate itself is usually the host
name of the machine so a certificate's
name should be localhost.local domain
we'll check this on our Master System
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client and we just started the
client we should have technically just
one certificate and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain we'll now sign the
certificate
okay sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
yeah as you can see here the certificate
is signed
signed Certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
This is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we are just checking here we are just
creating this file and then we'll go to
our client machine and just check there
if we can access this file from there
thank you
so now we'll move to our client machine
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on a client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our Master server put some
content into this file and see how the
execution takes place
so we'll open our file sample.pp which
we created earlier in the vi editor
let's type our code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
now the Apache service package on Centos
is called the httpd
so this line that I just typed in is the
action it'll ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so the suckline machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so I just cleared the screen now we'll
start the Apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and add localhost you must have the
testing page for your Apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
Apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
Apache service on our puppet light
and this is the end of our demo so let's
have a look at companies that are using
puppets today there are a number of
companies that have adopted puppet as a
way to manage their infrastructure so
companies that are using puppy today
include Spotify Google ATT so why are
these companies choosing to use puppet
as their main configuration management
tool the answer can be seen if we look
at a specific company Staples so Staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private Cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow
them to experiment with other and new
projects and assignments a real tangible
benefit to a company so let's look at
how you write a manifest in puppets so
so manifests are designed for writing
out in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the manifests are written in the
language of Ruby without dot PP
extension if we step through the five
key steps for writing a manifest they
are one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator to
compile your manifest and it's compiled
into a catalog three deploy the catalog
is then deployed onto the clients for
execute the catalogs are run on the
client by the agent and then five and
clients are configured to a specific and
desired state if we actually look into
how manifest is written it's written
with a very common syntax if you've done
any work with Ruby or really
configuration of systems in the past
this may look very familiar to you so we
break out the the work that we have here
you start off with a package file or
service as your resource type and then
you give it a name and then you look at
the features that need to be set such as
IP address then you're actually looking
to have a command written such as
present or start the Manifest can
contain multiple resource types if we
continue to write our manifest and
puppets the default keyword applies a
manifest to all clients so an example
would be to create a file path that
creates a folder called sample in a main
folder called Etc the specified content
is written into a file that is then
posted into that folder and then we're
going to say we want to be able to
trigger an Apache service and then
ensure that that Apache service is
installed on a nerved so we write the
Manifest and we deploy it to a client
machine on that client machine a new
folder will be created with a file in
that folder and an Apache server will be
installed you can do this to any machine
and you will have exactly the same
result results on those machines now
let's have a look at the puppet
community
the puppet Community is a rich community
of a lot of people officially there is
no count but counting the various
channels where people collaborate there
are a little over 2 900 committers to
GitHub projects who are directly or
indirectly associated with Puppet Labs
there are 4893 modules on the official
puppet Forge these include modules from
the Puppet Labs and also from open
source contributors to GitHub
so that's nearly 5 000 modules of
ready-made code available on the puppet
Forge so before you write any code for
puppet you can check to see if it's
already been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has
6588 participants apart from this on
slack overflow you have a big tag of
Puppet Labs in puppet which gives you a
list of only puppet questions that's a
good playground for you to interact with
people who are already using puppet and
who are contributing and helping others
now let's have a look at puppet Forge so
puppet Forge is a GitHub client for a
repository which is hosted by Puppet
Labs that has almost 5 000 modules of
puppet code so these are both Puppet
Labs and Community contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize so when you
have a requirement for anything you're
doing with your infrastructure you can
just grab one of those 5000 modules and
then you can customize it according to
your needs one of the other benefits is
they have built-in tests so they follow
all of the best practices now if you
write your own module you also have to
write your own tests and you have to
spend extra time writing best practice
code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go so that's the
benefit you get from such a large
community where people contribute to the
modules and the code and share with the
community the puppet DSL puppet DSL is a
puppet domain specific language it's the
puppet's primary programming language
it's just like plain English and you
don't really need to be a programmer to
write code in it it's kind of a
sub-child of Ruby because it approaches
and uses is equal to and greater than
marks to Define things so it's very easy
to learn you can specify packages that
you want to install you can specify
services to be managed you could do
things based on the operating system you
have so we'll be writing a small puppet
module which will be using this puppet
DSL we will do that after we install the
puppet server and the client and then we
will write a simple puppet module to
show how to use the puppet DSL let's
have a look at the demo we are going to
do so you will be setting up the
machines using sudo DNS because we want
to have a resolvable DNS because only by
having a resolvable DNS can we use
puppet because puppet uses the SSL
certificates now we'll be installing the
puppet server and the client we'll be
signing the certificates of the client
on the server side and then we'll
proceed with writing an ntp module which
we'll be using for installation of ntp
on the client and then we'll look at the
puppet programming language or DSL now
we are going to look at a demo here so
we will be setting up the machines we'll
set up a pseudo DNS locally because
puppet requires a fully qualified domain
name in order to run since there is a
certificate communication taking place
here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client we'll be signing the
certificate and finally we will write an
ntp module and make it run
[Music]
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client I have two machines
here one is a puppet master and the
second is the puppet client the puppet
master has got almost four gig of RAM
and four vcpus which I can show you here
because it's a Ruby on Rails application
it requires a lot of CPU and RAM
for the client I don't need that much
RAM and CPU so I've allotted one
gigabyte of RAM and one vcpu I will
start both of these machines and find
out the IP addresses right click normal
start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing I'll do is log in using root
and red hat password and then I will
change the host name so I'll say Vim
Etc host name
this will open a hostname file in a text
editor which is vim
then we'll do a DD which will delete
that existing hostname
and then I press I for insert mode and
finally I'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine I'll save this file by doing
Escape semicolon WQ exclamation mark
and I'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the Puppet Master
I'll say root red hat
I'll open the hostname file
say DD then I'll say puppet hyphen
master
I'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect the host name change does not
take effect unless you reboot the
machine
now both of these machines are ready
I'm going to find out the IPS and use
the Mac terminal to log into these
so this is 23 and 21. so 23 is my server
and 21 is my client
I'll SSH to 23 first
now in order for the Puppet Master to be
installed I need a fully qualified
domain name here and a fake DNS which
means a fully resolvable DNS name so if
I do hostname here you see my host name
is Puppet Master in order to set up a
fake DNS I need to go to the ETC host
file
go to the end
then I say IP address hostname local
then space hostname now this is one of
the techniques which makes the Linux
server believe that there's a fully
qualified domain name on this machine
I'll save this
then I do a hostname hyphen f you see it
has a fully qualified domain name now
so now we will be downloading the Puppet
Labs repository for Ubuntu 16.04 which
is zenial
so I'll say curl hyphen 0 https
apps dot Puppet Labs
.com
slash Puppet Labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenyl.deb
you can see there's a Debian file which
has been downloaded here I will import
this using the dpkg command so I'll say
dpkg hyphen I Puppet Labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphen xenial dot dab
and then I'll say apt-get update which
will update my apt package indexes on
this machine
and now I'll install the puppet server
so I'll say apt-get install puppet
hyphen
puppet server hyphen y
EP so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server so I'll
say Etc default puppet server so by
default it has only
uh got two gigabyte allocated we'll give
it three gigabyte because it's jvm I'll
make this three and I'll change this to
three as well and I'll save this file
I'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows Port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port
the rules have been updated to allow
that I'll now start the puppet server so
I'll say a system CTL
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running
I'll also enable it at boot time so I'll
say system CTL enable puppet the server
it will enable at boot time
now I also need to configure a fully
qualified domain name here so okay so
I'll do that by going into the hosts
file
I'll go to the end and I'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen server.local and then puppet
hyphen server
if I do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master
so the trick is to have the
hostname.local in front of the IP
address in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go to the client setup
the client setup is almost the same with
just a small difference
the package which we need to install on
the client is puppet agent so we will go
to the client
so you see this has got a host name
now we also need to set up the fake DNS
here so I'll copy this hostname
open the host line
go to the end write the IP address
and then dot local and then hostname
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name so when I do a hostname it
says puppet Ivan client when I do a
hostname hyphen f it says puppet client
local to install the puppet agent on
this machine I will need to download the
zenio packages so I'll say wget https
apt.puppetlabs.com
Puppet Labs
hyphen release hyphen pc1 hyphen
zenial.deb
I'll download this and then I'll say
dpkg hyphen I Puppet Labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphen xeniel.dap
so this is the repository package which
I'll be downloading here and then I'll
say apt-get
update hyphen y this will update my apt
caches on this machine
and now I'll finally install the puppet
agent
so I'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here I'll start
the puppet agent and I'll enable it at
boot time so I'll say system control
start puppet
then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server but each of them
should know each other so we'll have to
do a cross certificate host mapping so
we will be copying the host file entry
of the client and adding it to the
server so I'll go to the ETC hosts on
the server side go to the end paste it
there
okay and I'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now because one of
them has the host entry of the other
so if if I do from the master ping
puppet hyphenagent dot local
if I ping the agent from a server
hyphen client.local
it is able to Ping it and if I ping the
master from the client
if I say ping puppet hyphen master dot
local
both of them will be able to Ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request so I'll go
to my to this directory which is opt
Puppet Labs puppet bin
and I'll say puppet agent hyphen T
hyphen hyphen server
is equal to
and I'll give the fully qualified domain
name of the Puppet Master
then I'll say hyphen f
when I do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if I go to the server and I do an
opt
I'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a public client
certificate which is pending to be
signed which is denoted by the absence
of a plus sign here
I'll be signing the certificate so I'll
say puppet search sign and then the name
so puppet hyphen client
dot local this will sign the
certificates and when I go to the server
on the client side if I run the puppet
agent again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from Puppet Forge
puppet Forge is a big collection of Open
Source modules which are free to use as
a first step we will be using a
ready-made module and that would be a
demonstration for how to actually get up
and running with a module so search for
Apache module here
this is the Puppet Labs Apache module
I'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install this is the
command for that but I will make sure I
run this command from the puppet home so
I'll go to the master I'll go to Etc
Puppet Labs code environments production
in this I'll do modules
now I will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt to Puppet Labs bin
puppet
and then module install
Puppet Labs hyphen Apache and then this
version so we are specifying the latest
version and I'll hit enter
when I press enter it starts downloading
from the forge API
so you see the module is downloaded in
addition to the dependencies so there is
concat STD lib and Apache so now I'll go
to a folder here which is one level up
called manifest so this is the file here
Etc Puppet Labs code environments
production manifest so in this there's a
file which I'll be creating called
site.ppe the site.pp will specify and
this is the main controller of how the
infrastructure looks in the site PP
I specify
that I want puppet
hyphenclient.localnode to have the
Apache module included I'll save this
file and the only thing I need to do now
is since all is set on the server side I
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the Apache module and compile
it and it may then make sure the server
is in a state so when I press enter we
see a lot of output it tries to
configure Apache on this machine
and done now when I go to the front end
of this machine on this port I should be
able to see apache's default page so
this is apache's default page
so the module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that Apache would be installed and run
at boot time so that is why it is
running here
and that is all we have from the uh
puppet module and this concludes the
demo today we're going to go through a
real tough battle we're going to decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it Chef puppet and
support or salt stack all four are gonna
go head to head so let's go through the
scenario of why you'd want to use these
tools so let's meet Tim he's our
assistant administrator and Tim is a
happy camper putting and working on all
of the systems in his network but what
happens if a system fails if there's a
fire a server goes down well Tim knows
exactly what to do he can fix that fire
really easily the problems become really
difficult for Tim however if multiple
servers start failing particularly when
you have large and expanding networks so
this is why Tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool and we
need to now decide what would be the
best tool for him because configuration
management tools can help make Tim look
like a superstar all he has to do is
configure the right codes that allows
him to push out the instructions on how
to set up each of the servers quickly
effectively and at scale all right let's
go through the tools and see which ones
we can use the tools that we're going to
go through are Chef puppet and support
and salt stacks and we have videos on
most of these software and services that
you can go and view to get an overview
or a deep dive in how those products
work so let's go and get to know our
contestants so our first contestant is
Chef and Chef is a tool that allows you
to configure very large environments it
allows you to scale very effectively
across the entire ecosystem and
infrastructure Chef is by default an
open source code and one of the things
that you find is a consistent metaphor
for the tools that we recommend on
simply learn is to use open source code
code the code itself is actually written
in language of Ruby and erline and it's
really designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature solution the way that Chef works
is that you write recipes that are
compiled into cookbooks and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up a node and a node is a
selection of servers that you have
configured in a specific way so for
instance you may have Apache Linux
servers running or you may have a MySQL
server running or you may have a python
server running and Chef is able to
communicate back and forth between the
nodes to understand what nodes are being
impacted and need to have instructions
sent out to them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to the nodes to make a
significant update or a minor update so
there's great communication going back
and forth if we look at the pros and
cons the pros for Chef is that there is
a significant and following for chef and
that has resulted in a very large
collection of recipes that allow you to
be able to quickly stand up environments
there's no need for you to have to learn
complex recipes the first thing you
should do is go out and find the recipes
that are available it integrates with
Git really well and provides for really
good strong Version Control some of the
consoles are really around the learning
speed it takes to go from beginner user
with Chef to being an expert there is a
considerable amount of learning that has
to take place and it's compounded by
having to learn Ruby as the programming
language and the main server itself
doesn't really have a whole lot of
control it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network alright let's look at our second
Contender puppet and puppet is actually
in many ways very similar to Chef there
are some differences but again puppet is
designed to be able to support very
large heterogeneous organization it is
also built with Ruby and uses DSL for
writing manifests so there are some
strong similarities here to Chef as with
a chef there is a Master Slave
infrastructure with puppets and you have
a master server that has the manifests
that you put together in a single
catalog and those catalogs are then
pushed out to the clients over an SSL
connection some of the pros with public
is that as with Chef there is a really
strong Community around puppies and
there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very well
developed reporting mechanism that makes
it easier for you as an administrator to
be able to understand your
infrastructure one of the cons is that
you have to really be good at learning
Ruby again as with shav you know the
more advanced tasks really need to have
those Ruby skills and as with Chef the
server also it doesn't have much control
so let's look at our third Contender
here ansible and so ansible is slightly
different it is the way the ansible
works is that it actually just pushes
out the instructions to the server
environment there isn't a client server
or Master Slave environment where
ansible would be communicating backwards
and forwards with its infrastructure it
is merely going to push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yowel stands for yaml a markup language
yaml is actually pretty easy to learn if
you know XML and XML is pretty easy if
you know XML you're going to get yaml
really well ansible does work very well
on environments where the focuses are
getting servers up and running really
fast it's very very responsive and can
allow you to move quickly to get your
infrastructure up quick very fast when
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick so again the way
that ansible works is that you put
together a Playbook and an inventory all
you have a Playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
Playbook and the Playbook it then goes
against the inventory of servers and
will push out the instructions for that
Playbook to those servers so some of the
pros that we have for ansible we don't
need to have an agent installed on the
remote notes and servers it makes it
easier for the configuration yaml is
really easy to learn you can get up to
speed and get very proficient with yaml
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure up and
running is less than other tools that we
have on our list now I do have to add a
Proviso this is a relative less it's
still very fast it's going to be a lot
faster than individuals manually
standing up servers but it's just not as
fast as some of the other tools that we
have on this list and yaml itself as a
language while it's easy to learn it's
not as powerful as Ruby Ruby will allow
you to do things that at an advanced
level that you can't do easily with the
ammo so let's look at our final
Contender here salt stack so salt stack
is a CLI based tool it means that you
will have to get your command line tools
out or your terminal window out so you
can actually manage the entire
environment via salt sack the
instructions themselves are based on
python but you can actually write them
in yaml or DSL which is really
convenient and as a product it's really
designed for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient the
way that sort stat works is that you
have a master environment that pushes
out the instructions to what they call
grains which is your network and so
let's step through some of the pros and
cons that we have here with salt stag so
salt stack is very easy to use once it's
up and running it has a really good
reporting mechanism that makes your job
as an operator in your devops
environment much much easier the actual
setup though is a little bit tougher
than some of the other tools and and
it's getting easier with the newer
releases but it's just a little bit
tougher and related to that is that salt
stack is fairly late in the game when it
comes to actually having a graphical
user interface for being able to create
and manage your environment other tools
such as ansible have actually had a UI
environment for quite some time all
right so we've gone through all four
tools let's see how they all stack up
next with each other so let the race
begin let's start with the first stage
architecture so the architecture for
most of our environments is a server
client environment so for Chef puppet
and salt snack so very similar
architecture there the one exception is
ansible which is a client Only Solution
so you're pushing out the instructions
from a server and pushing them out into
your network and there isn't a client
environment there isn't a two-way
community education back to that main
client for what's actually happening in
your network so let's talk about the
next stage ease of setup so if we look
at the four tools there is one tool that
really stands out for ease of setup and
that is ansible it is going to be the
easiest tool for you to set up and if
you're new to having these types of
tools in your environment you may want
to start with ansible just to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration before looking
at other tools now and so with that said
Chef puppet and sauce stack aren't that
hard to set up either and you'll find
there's actually some great instructions
on how to do that setup in the online
community let's talk about the languages
that you can use in your configuration
so we have two different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural and that they actually
specify at how you're actually supposed
to do the task in your instructions with
puppet and salt stack it's decorative
where you specify only what to do in the
instructions let's talk about
scalability which tools scale the most
effectively and as you can imagine all
of these tools are designed for
scalability that is the driver for these
kind of tools you want them to be able
to scale to massive organizations what
do the management tools look like for
our four contenders so again we have a
two-way split with ansible and salt
stack the management tools are really
easy to use you're going to love using
them they're just fantastic to use with
puppet and Chef their management tools
are much harder to learn and they do
require that you learn some either the
public DSL or the Ruby DSL to be able to
be a true master in that environment but
what does interoperability look like
again as you'd imagine with the similar
to scalability interoperability with
these products is very high in all four
cases now let's talk about Cloud
availability this is increasingly
becoming more important for
organizations as they move rapidly onto
cloud services well both ansible and
salt stack have a big fail here neither
of them are available in the most
popular Cloud environments and puppet
and Chef are actually available in both
Amazon and Azure now we've actually just
haven't had a chance to update our Chef
link here but Chef is now available on
Azure as well as Amazon so what does
communication look like with all of our
four tours so the communication is
slightly different with them Chef has
its own knife tool and whereas puppet
uses SSL to secure sockets layer and
ansible and soul stack use secure socket
hashing SSH as their communication tool
bottom line all four tools are very
secure in their communication so who
wins well here's the reality all four
tools are are very good and it's really
dependent on your capabilities and the
type of environment that you're looking
to manage that will determine which of
these four tools you should use the
tools themselves are open source so go
out and experiment with them there's a
lot of videos our team has done a ton of
videos on these tools and so feel free
to find out other tools that we have
then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have Ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows Ruby your
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider yaml based tools again the
final answer is going to be up to you
and we'll be really interested on what
your decision is please post in the
comments below which tool you have
decided to go with and what are the
challenges that you're coming up with
because we'll help answer those
challenges for you a very warm welcome
to all our viewers I'm Anjali from
Simply learn and today I'll be showing
you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
yaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
States so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager I'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the Master System so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my Master System guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike
Chef or puppet ansible is a push type of
configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
Creator ansible tool is installed now we
need to open our ansible host file and
there we'll specify the details of our
node or client machine
so this are ansible host file as you can
see here the entire file is commented
but there's a certain syntax that you'd
observe for example here we have a group
name web servers under which we have the
IP addresses or certain host name so
this is about how we'll be adding the
details for our client system first we
need to give a group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the IP address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the IP address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your IP address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for a client machine
so all Communications between the server
or the Master System and the client or
the node system takes place through SSH
ssh basically provide a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the roots password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this file and go back to our terminal
so now that our host file is written the
next thing we do is we write a Playbook
so Playbook is the technical term used
for all the configuration files that we
write in ansible now playbooks are
written in yaml yaml's extremely simple
to both write and understand it's in
fact very close to English
so now we'll write our Playbook The
Playbook or any code in yaml first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our Playbook
so name
and I'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is Root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
Playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation next we need to
specify our tasks so these are basically
the actions that the Playbook will be
performing so you would have noticed
everything so far is aligned that is
name host remote user become and task
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under task will be
shifted slightly towards the right
although yamil is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a Apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest date of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task could be running our
Apache service
so name run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied to a node
system at a particular file location
that will provide
a Content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our HTML files
and that's it we are done writing our
Playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the Playbook or push
the Playbook onto our node system let's
check the syntax of our Playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the Playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the Syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed and next task was running httpd
now Although our system had the Apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything is fine here we can
move on to our node system
and we'll just go to a browser so if our
Playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running State and the
webpage that we created should be hosted
so let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible
ansible today as one of the key tools
that you would have within your devops
environment so the things that we're
going to go through today is we're going
to cover why you'd want to use a product
like ansible what ansible really is and
how it's of value to you in your
organization the differences between
ansible and other products that are
similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and I
want to dig into the architecture for
ansible we're going to look at how you
would create a Playbook how you would
manage your inventory of your server
environments and then what is the actual
workings of ansible there's a little
extra we're going to also throw in
ansible Tau one of the secret Source
solutions that you can use for improving
the Speed and Performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
Case by looking at HootSuite social
media a management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the servers and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the devops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of Sam and like
yourselves Sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
Apache they could be database servers
running my Sequel and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain I mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it will we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where ansible
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system Solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and set up of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is so you know this is all great
but you know how do we actually use
these tools in our environment so
ansible is a tool that really allows you
to create and control three key areas
that you'd have within your operations
environment first of all there's it
automation so you can actually write
instructions that automate the it setup
that you would typically do manually in
the past the second is the configuration
and having consistent configuration
imagine setting up hundreds of Apache
servers and being able to guarantee with
Precision that each of those Apache
servers is set up identically and then
finally you want to be able to automate
the deployment so that as you scale up
your server environment you can just
push out instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about pull configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
different environments for Server Farms
one is to have a key server that has all
the instructions on and then on each of
the servers that connect to that main
Master server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main Master server
and then would periodically either
update or change the configuration of
the slave server this is known as a pull
configuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the push configuration
is slightly different the main
difference is as with a pull
configuration you have a master server
where you actually put up the
instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second
environments where it's a push
configuration server and this contrasts
with other popular products like chef
and puppet which have a Master Slave
architecture with a master server
connecting with a client on a remote
slave environment where you would then
be pushing out the updates with ansible
you're pushing out the service and the
structure of the server to remote
hardware and you are just putting it
onto the hardware irrelevant of the
structure that's out there and there are
some significant advantages that you
have in that in that you're not having
to have the extra overhead weight of a
client installed on those remote servers
having to constantly communicate back to
the master environment so let's step
through the architecture that you would
have for an ansible environment
so when you're setting up an ansible
environment the first thing you want to
do is have a local machine and the local
machine is where you're going to have
all of your instruction and really the
power of the control that you'd be
pushing out to the remote server so the
local machine is where you're going to
be starting and doing all of your work
connected from the local machine are all
the different nodes pushing out the
different configurations that you would
set up on the local machine the
configurations that you would write and
you would write those in code within a
module so you do this on your local
machine for creating these modules and
each of these modules is actually
consistent playbooks the local machine
also has a second job and that job is to
manage the inventory of the nodes that
you have in your environment the local
machine is able to connect to each of
the different nodes that you would have
in your Hardware Network through SSH
clients so a secure client let's dig
into some of the different elements
within that architecture and we're going
to take a first look at playbooks that
you would write and create for the
ansible environments so the core of
ansible is the Playbook this is where
you create the instructions that you
write to define the architecture of your
Hardware so the Playbook is really just
a set of instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called yamo and this is a
standard language used for configuration
server environments did you know that
yaml actually stands for yaml a markup
language that's just a little tidbit to
hide behind your ear so let's have a
look or one of these playbooks it looks
like and here we have a sample yaml
script that we've written so you start
off your gamma script with three dashes
and that integrates the start of a
script and then the script itself is
actually consistent of two distinct
plays at the top we have play one and
below that we have play two within each
of those plays we Define which nodes are
we targeting so here we have a web
server in the top play and in the second
play we have a database server that
we're targeting and then within each of
those server environments we have the
specific tasks that we're looking to
execute so let's step through some of
these tasks we have an install patchy
task we have a starter patchy task and
we have it installed my SQL task and
when we do that we're going to execute a
specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
Apache and then setting the state of the
Apache environment or starting the
Apache environment and setting up and
running the MySQL environment so this
really isn't too complicated and that's
the really good thing about working with
yaml is it's really designed to make it
easy for you as an operations lead to be
able to configure the environments that
you want to consistently create so let's
take a step back though we have two
hosts we have web server and database
server why do these names come from well
this takes us into our next stage and
the second part of working with ansible
which is the inventory management part
of ansible so the inventory part of
ansible is where we maintain the
structure of our Network environment so
what we do here is part of the structure
in creating different nodes is we've had
to create two two different nodes here
we have a web server node and a database
server node and under web server node we
actually have the names that were
actually pointed to specific machines
within that environment so now when we
actually write our scripts all we have
to do is refer to either web server or
database server and the different
servers will have the instructions from
the yamascript executed on them this
makes it really easy for you to be able
to just point to new services without
having to write out complex instructions
so let's have a look at how ansible
actually works in real world so the real
world environment is that you'd have the
ansible software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
SSH connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
bigger that server remotely the end goal
is to have an environment that is
consistent so this asks you a simple
question what are the major
opportunities that ansible has over chef
and puppet really like to hear your
answers in the comments below pop them
in there and we'll get back to you and
really want to hear how you feel that
ansible is a stronger product or maybe
you think it's a weaker product as it
compares to other similar products in
the market here's the bonus we're going
to talk a little bit about ansible Tower
so ansible Tower is an extra product
that red hat created that really kind of
puts the cherry on the top of the ice
cream or is the icing on your cake add
ible by itself is a command line tool
however as well Tower is a framework
that was designed to access ansible and
through the ansible tower framework we
now have an easy to use GUI this really
makes it easy for non-developers to be
able to create the environment that they
want to be able to manage in their
devops plan without having to constantly
work with the command prompt window so
instead of opening up terminal window or
a command window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes alright so we've
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
going to look at HootSuite now HootSuite
if you've not already used their
products and they have a great product
HootSuite is a social media management
system they are able to help with you
managing your pushes of social media
content across all of the popular social
media platforms they're able to provide
the analytics they're able to provide
the tools that marketing and sales teams
can use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really great tool and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
HootSuite the chance they had at
HootSuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that now has tens of
thousands to hundreds of thousands of
users this is where ansible came in and
really helped the folks over at
HootSuite today the devops team at
HootSuite write out playbooks that have
Specific Instructions that Define the
architecture and structure of their
Hardware nodes and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of seconds the bottom line is
ansible has been able to provide
HootSuite with it automation consistent
configuration and free up time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company
ansible is currently the most trending
and popular configuration management
tool and it's used mostly under the
devops approach so what will you be
learning today you learn why you should
use ansible what exactly is ansible the
ansible architecture how ansible works
the various benefits of ansible and
finally we'll have a demo on the
installation of Apache or the httpd
package on a client systems we'll also
be hosting a very simple web page and
during this demo I'll also show you how
you can write a very simple playbook in
Yemen and your inventory file so let's
begin why should you use ansible let's
consider a scenario of an organization
where Sam is a system administrator Sam
is responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator Sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task Sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where Sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
Sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes Sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for Innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible Sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct States so
now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an IIT engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically means bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next ansible automates
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired state are the tools
that automate configuration management
include puppet and Chef and finally
ansible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals now that we
know what exactly ansible is let's look
at ansible's architecture ansible has
two main components you have the local
machine and you have your node or the
client machine so the local machine is
where the system administrator sits he
or she installs ansible here and on the
other end you have your node or the
client systems so in case of ansible
there's no supporting software installed
here these are just the systems that
required to be configured and they are
completely controlled by the local
machine at your local machine you also
have a module a module is a collection
of your configuration files and in case
of ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your notes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the Playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with the client and
how is this done this is done through
SSH ssh is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
Communication in an unprotected
environment okay so we saw the various
components of ansible now how does
ansible exactly work you have your local
machine on one end this is where you
install ansible if you've gone through
any previous material on ansible you
would have come across the term
agentless often being associated with
this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
support building software or Plugin
being installed on your clients this
means that you have no agent on the
other end the local machine has complete
control and hence the term agentless
another term that you would come across
with ansible is push configuration so
since a local machine has complete
control here it pushes the playbooks
onto the nodes and thus it's called a
push configuration tool now the
playbooks and the inventory are written
at the local machine and the local
machine connects with the nodes through
the SSH client this step here is
optional but it's always recommended to
do so it's where the facts are collected
so facts are basically the current state
of the node now all this is collected
from the node and sent to the local
machine so when the Playbook is executed
the tasks mentioned in the Playbook is
compared against the current status of
the note and only the changes that are
required to be made further are made and
once the playbooks are executed your
notes are configured to the desired
States so as I mentioned before ansible
is currently the most trending tool in
the market under the configuration
management umbrella so let's have a look
at the various benefits of ansible which
gives it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple important and provides automated
reporting how does it do all this let's
have a look at that agentless as I
already mentioned before you require no
supporting software or Plugin install a
new node or the client system so the
master has complete control and
automatically this means that ansible is
more efficient because now we have more
space in our client and node systems for
other resources and we can get ansible
up and running real quick ansible is
also flexible so an infrastructure is
prone to change very often and ansible
takes no amount of time to adjust to
these changes ansible cannot get any
simpler with your playbooks written in a
language such as Yama which is as close
to English as you can possibly get
it important basically means that if you
have a Playbook which needs to be run n
number of systems it would have the same
effect on all of these systems without
any side effect and finally we have
automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these tasks are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
Hands-On before we move on to the actual
Hands-On let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so I'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both Centos 7
Operating Systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first
I'll install ansible we then write the
inventory and the Playbook and then
simply deploy this Playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configurations that we
mentioned in our Playbook are made right
so we'll now begin our demo this is my
Oracle virtual box here I have my master
system which is the local machine and
this is the client machine so let's have
a look at these two machines this is my
client machine the terminal is open
right now so the client machine terminal
has a black background with white text
and the Master machine terminal has a
white background with black text just so
you can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the Master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen Y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our host file so host file
here is basically the inventory it's
where you'll specify all your nodes
in our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes
so I'm going to name it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the IP address
of our client machine so my client
machines IP address is
192.168.2.127 so before you come to this
it's advice that you check the IP
address on your client machine the
simple command for that is ifconfig now
once you type the IP address put a space
and here we need to mention the username
and the password for our client
so I'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is Root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our Playbook we need
to write the Playbook
so the extension for our Playbook is yml
which stands for yaml
and as you can see here I have already
written my playbook but I'll just
explain to you how this is done so a
yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire Playbook
so I have named it sample book host is
basically where this would be executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory I
mentioned client's group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your client so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called the
privilege escalation now A playbook
consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task I've named it to install httpd so
what we are doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the Apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome and the
destination of the file will be via
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our HTML files now as you can see
here there's quite a lot of indentation
and when it comes to yaml although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first Dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
Playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentations absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of a yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
Playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is sample
dot yml which is the name of your
playbook
so our Playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the Playbook is
ansible Playbook
and the name of your playbook
so a playbooks executed as you can see
here Gathering facts that's where all
the facts of the note at the present
state of the note is collected and sent
to the local machine so it's basically
to check that if the configuration
changes that we are about to make is
already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay State this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so I made it this way so
that you can at least see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on a client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it is open your browser
and type in localhost
so there you go your Apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
hey there are you exploring test
automation are you wondering why
everyone is talking about selenium
around you do you want to know what
selenium is all about if yes this is the
video for you what should you expect
from this video before you start
understanding any automation tool it's
good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation tool selenium
Suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execute solution of test cases against
various applications and to do what to
detect bugs and errors in your product
it is one of the Primitive methods of
testing a software this was the only
method which we knew of earlier it is
execution of test cases without using
any automation tools it does not require
the knowledge of a testing tool
obviously because everything is done
manually also you can practically test
any application since you are doing a
manual testing so let's take an example
so say we have a use case you are
testing say a Facebook application and
in Facebook application let's let's open
the Facebook application and say create
an account this is your web page which
is under test now now as a tester what
would you do you would write multiple
test cases to test each of the
functionalities on this page you will
use multiple data sets to test each of
these fields like the first name the
surname mobile number or the new
password and you will also test multiple
links what are the different links on
this page like say forgot account or
create a new page so these are the
multiple links available on the web
pages also you look at each and every
element of the web page like your radio
buttons like your drop down list apart
from this you would do an access ability
testing you would do a performance
testing for this pitch or say a response
time after you say click on the login
button literally you can do any type of
tests manually once you have this test
cases ready what do you do you start
executing this test cases one by one you
will find bugs your developers are going
to fix them and you will need to rerun
all these test cases one by one again
until all the bugs are fixed and your
application is ready to ship now if one
has to run test cases with hundreds of
transactions or the data sets and repeat
them can you imagine the amount of
effort required in that now that brings
us to the first demerit of the manual
testing manual testing is a very time
consuming process and it is very boring
also it is very highly error Pro why
because it is done annually and human
mistakes are bound to happen since it's
a manual executions tester's presence is
required all the time one is to keep
doing manual Steps step by step again
all the time he also has to create
manual reports group them format them so
that we get good looking reports also
send this reports manually to all
stakeholders then collection of logs
from various machines where you have run
your test consoliding all of them
creating repositories and maintaining
them and again since it's all is a
manual process there is a high chance of
creating manual errors there scope of
manual testing is limited for example
let's say regression testing ideally you
would want to run all the test cases
which you have written but since it's a
manual process you would not have the
luxury of time to execute all of them
and hence you will pick and choose your
test cases to execute that way you are
limiting the scope of testing also
working with large amount of data
manually is Impractical which could be
the need of your application what about
performance testing you want to collect
metrics on various performance measures
as a part of your performance testing
you want to simulate multiple loads on
application under test and hence
manually performing these kind of test
is not feasible and to top it all up say
if you're working in an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers testers are building their
test and they are executing them as and
when the bills are available for testing
and this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run this test multiple
times during your development cycle and
doing this manually definitely becomes
very tedious and burning and is this the
effective way of doing it not at all so
what do we do we automate it so this
tells us why we automate one for faster
execution two to be less error prone and
three the main reason is to help
frequent execution of our test so there
are many tools available in the market
today for automation one such tool is
selenium birth of selenium much before
selenium there were various tools in the
market like say rft and qtp just to name
a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentlemen called Jason
Huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks and he was
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing he realized the
inefficiency in manually testing this
web application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a JavaScript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and he named it as
JavaScript test run later he made this
open source and this was renamed as the
selenium Coke and this is how selenium
came into existence and since then
selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in Speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate No human errors since your
test cases are automated Human Resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
Market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like Internet Explorer Chrome Firefox
Safari Edge Opera and even the Headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as I said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium ID which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like Java python
c-sharp Ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in depth or Advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has purpose for Windows Macs
Linux even Ubuntu as well so you can run
your selenium test on any platform of
your choice and hence selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tools for automating your web
applications selenium set of tools so
let's go a little more deeper into
selenium as I said selenium is not a
single tool it is a suite of tools so
let's look at some of the major
components or the tools in selenium and
what they have to offer so selenium has
four major components one selenium ID
it's the most simplest tool in the suite
of selenium it is integrated development
environment earlier selenium IDE was
available only as a Firefox plugin and
it offered a simple record and Playback
functionality it is a very simple to use
tool but it's mainly used for
prototyping and not used for creating
Automation in the real-time projects
because it has its own limitations like
any other record and replay tool
selenium RC this is nothing but selenium
remote control it is used to write web
app application test in different
programming language what it does it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as RC
server and how it interacts is it uses a
simple HTTP post get request for
communication this was also called as
selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by Webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
Webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium Suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute test cases it is obviously the
successor of the selenium RC which we
talked about because of certain
drawbacks which RC hat so what Webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike RC where the RC required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium Webdriver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test Automation and we will
go in detail about each of this
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an IDE RC and grid and as I said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
RC so RC was on its path of deprecation
and web driver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of Webdriver and also
the RC so they coexisted from three dot
onwards RC was completely remote code
and Webdriver took its place there is
also a four dot version around the
corner and it has more features and
enhancements some some of the features
which are talked about are w3c Webdriver
standardization improved ID and improved
grid now let's look at each of the
components in the selenium Suite
selenium IDE is the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is nothing
but an integrated development
environment for creating your automation
scripts it has a record and Playback
functionality and is a very simple and
easy to use tool it is available as a
Firefox plugin and a Chrome extension so
you can use either of this browser to
record your test scripts it's a very
simple user interface using which you
can create your scripts that interact
with your browser the commands created
in the scripts are called selenis
commands and they can be exported to the
supported programming language and hence
this code can be reused however this is
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitation which any other recorded
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium ID so earlier selenium ID was
only a Firefox extension so we saw that
IDE was available since the selenium
version one selenium ID died with the
Firefox version 55 that was ID was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium ID has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on Chrome as well as as an
add-on on Firefox browser so they
completely revamped this IDE code and
now they have made it available on the
GitHub under the Apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new ID now with this new ID also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports pattern test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side Runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using IDC
on Chrome or Firefox but through command
prompt using your site Runner you can
execute these test cases on any browser
thus by achieving your cross browser
testing control flow statement so
initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while Loops the switch cases and so on
it also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this ID looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the Firefox browser so on
this browser I already have the ID
installed so when you already have an ID
installed you will see an icon here
which says selenium ID and how do you
install this you simply need to go to
your Firefox add-ons here whether it
says find more extension so just type in
selenium ID and search for the second so
in the search results you see the
selenium ID just click on that and now
since I've already installed here it
says remove otherwise for you it is
going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ID icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this ID so when I
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so I already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so I'll go ahead and open that
so I'll say open existing project and I
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
Facebook using a dummy user mail sorry
username and password that's all it's a
very simple script with few lines and
this is what it's going to do so what we
will simply do is we'll just run the
script and see how it works for that I'm
just going to reduce the test execution
speed so that you should be able to see
every step of execution here all right
so what I'll do now here is I'll just
adjust this window and I'll just simply
say run current test all right so I'll
just get this side by side so that you
should be able to see what exactly the
script is doing okay so now you are able
to see both the windows okay so now it's
going to type in your user email here
there you go and now it will enter the
password and it is Click clicked on the
login button so it's going to take a
while to say login and since these are
the dummy IDs it is you are not able to
log in here and you're going to see this
error window fine that is what is the
expected output here now on the ID if
you look here after I execute the test
case every statement or every command
which I have used here is color coded in
green so that means this particular step
was executed successfully and then here
in the log window it will give you a
complete lock of this test case right
from the first step till the end and
your end result is it says FB login
which is my test case name completed
successful let's look at few components
of this ID the first one is the menu bar
so let's go to our ID all right so the
menu bar is right here on the top so
here is your project name so either you
can add a new project here or rename
your project so since we already have
this project which is named as Facebook
and then on the right you have options
to create a new project open an existing
project or save the current project and
then comes on toolbar so using the
options in this toolbar you can control
the execution of your test cases so
first one here is the recording button
so this is what you use when you start
recording your script and then on the
left you have two options here to run
your test cases the first one is run all
tests so in case you have multiple test
cases written here you can execute them
one by one sequentially by using this
run all test else what you can do is if
you just want to run your current test
this is what you would use then idea has
this debugger option which you can use
to do a step execution so say for
example now whenever I run the script
it's going to execute each and every
command here sequentially so instead if
I just select the first command and say
do step execution all right so what it
does is the moment it finishes the First
Command which is opening of Facebook
right I think which is already done here
yeah all right so once this is done it
is going to wait immediately on the
second command and it says paused
debugger so from here you can do
whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is it's just going to Simply go
ahead and complete the com complete the
test case now there is another option
here which is you see the timer there
which says test execution speed so to
execute your test cases in the speed you
want say whenever you're developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
Fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which I showed was I
control the speed and then I executed it
so that we could see every command how
it is being executed all right so what's
the next this is called as an address
bar so whatever Wherever Whenever you
enter an URL here that is where you want
to conduct your test and another thing
what it does is it gives a history of
all the URLs which I've used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded So each and every
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as log and
reference so now log is an area where it
records each and every step of your
command as in when they get executed
right so if you see here it says open
https facebook.com and ok so that means
this command was executed successfully
and after the complete test case is done
it gives you whether the test case
passed or failed so in case there is a
failure you will immediately see this
test case is filled in red color also
there is something called as reference
here for example say if I click on any
of this command the reference tab what
it is going to to show me is a details
of this command which I have used in the
script it gives you the details of the
command as well as what the arguments
have been used or how how is that you
need to be using this particular command
okay so now what we'll do is let's go
ahead and write a simple script using
this ID so with this you'll get an ideas
how do we actually record scripts in ID
so for that I have a use case here a
very very simple use case so whatever
we'll do is we will open amazon.in then
we'll search simply search for say a
product iPhone and once we get that
search page where all your iPhones are
displayed we will just do an assert on
the title of the page simple all right
so let's do that so first thing what I
need is an URL okay so first let me go
to my Firefox browser here and say
amazon.in so why I'm doing this just to
Simply get the right URL absolute URL
path here and so that I don't make any
mistakes while typing in the URL okay so
I got this so let me close all this
windows I don't need any of this let's
minimize this all right so here what I
will do in the tests tab I'll say add a
new test and name this test as uh Amazon
search done I'll say add now I'll enter
this URL which I just copied it from my
browser okay and then I'll just say
start recording so what it did was since
I've entered the URL in this address box
it just opened the amazon.in URL now
let's do the test case so in my test
case what I said was I want to search
for iPhone once I have this I'm just
going to click on my search button so
now this gives me a list of all iPhones
and then I said I want to add an
assertion on the title of this page so
for me to do that what id gives me an
option is I have to just right click
anywhere on this page and you'll see the
selenium ID options here so in this I
will select assert title and then I will
close this browser so that kind of
completes my test case so now take a
look at all the steps which is created
for me so it says open slash because
I've already provided the URL here so
either you can replace it with your
regular URL or you can just leave it as
it is so what I will do since this is
going to be a proper script and I might
be using this to run it from a command
prompt also so I'll just replace this
target with the actual URL and then what
it is doing it is setting a window size
then there are whatever I did on that
particular URL on that website it has
recorded all the steps for me so this is
where it says type into this particular
text box which is my search box and what
did it type iPhone this was the value
which I entered now there was one more
feature which I told you in this new ID
which had which I said it has a failover
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this ID is equal to two tab search
textbook this is nothing but the search
box where we entered the text iPhone and
it has certain identification through
which this IDE identifies that web
element and that has multiple options to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is ID is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
CSS and the XPath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if Amazon dot
in website changes the ID of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular ID fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the ID it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of this becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
assert Title Here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then I've also
given a closed browser so right now what
I will do is I'll just comment this out
why because if I just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now I'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now I'll just say run the
current test so your Amazon in is
launched okay it is typed in the iPhone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the lock so it's going to be
running log so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
Facebook is also in the same lock so we
all have to see the log from running
Amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right it was executed success fully
assert title was also done and your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title I'll just modify this and
let's say just add some text I'll just
add double s here now this by
intentionally I am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the ID behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so I'll just
run the test test case again so before
that let's close the previous window all
right done and now here I'll also
uncomment the close because anyway it's
a failure which I'm going to see which I
should be able to see it in the logs so
I'll close the browser after the
execution of test case Okay so let's
simply go and run the test case Okay
amazon.in is launched it should search
for iPhone now yeah there you go all
right now it should also close the
browser yes it is close the browser and
it has failed now see here now this is
the line where our Command fit why
because the expected title was not there
and if you look in the logs it says your
assert title on Amazon dot in failed at
actual result was something different
and it did not match with what we had
asked it for so this is how simple it is
to use your ID to create your automation
scripts so we saw all the components of
ID we saw the record button then I
showed you the toolbar I showed you the
editor box and also the test execution
log so now let's come to what are the
limitations of this ID with IDE you
cannot export your scripts your test
scripts to web driver scripts this
support is not yet added but it is in
The Works Data driven testing like using
your Excel files or reading data from
the CSV files and passing it to the
script this capability is still not
available also you cannot connect to
database for reading your test data or
perform any kind of database testing
with selenium Webdriver yes you can also
unlike selenium Webdriver you do not
have a good reporting mechanism with the
ID like say for example test NG or
report NC so that brings us to the next
component of The Suite which is selenium
RC selenium remote control so selenium
RC was developed by Paul Hammond he
refactored the code which was developed
by Jason and was credited with Json as a
co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in Java it is used to write
web application tests in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
Java C sharp Pearl Python and Ruby it
interacts with the browser with the help
of an RC server so this RF save server
uses a simple HTTP get and post request
for communication and as I said earlier
also selenium RC was called as selenium
1.0 overshill but it got deprecated in
selenium 2.0 and was completely removed
in 3.0 and it got replaced by what web
driver and we'll see why this happened
and what was that issue which we had
with the RC server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when Jason
Huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as JavaScript program
and then that was also called as
selenium core so every HTML has a
JavaScript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a JavaScript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this RC had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say test dot
JavaScript here which you are trying to
access a limits from anywhere from the
google.com domain so what used to happen
is every element which is accessible are
the elements which can belong only to
google.com domain like say for example
mail the search or the drive so any
elements from this can be accessible
through your test scripts however
nothing outside the domain of say
google.com in this case was accessible
say for example if your test scripts
wanted to access something from
yahoo.com this was not possible and this
is due to the security reasons obviously
now to overcome that the testers what
they had to do was they had to install
the selenium core and the web server
which contained your web application
education which is under test on the
same machine and imagine if you have to
do this for every machine which is under
test this is not going to be feasible or
even effective all the time and this
issue is called as the same origin
policy now what the same origin policy
issue says is it prohibits a JavaScript
from accessing elements or interacting
with scripts from my domain different
from where it is launched and this is
purely for the security measure so if
you have written a scripts which can
access your google.com or anything
related to google.com these scripts
cannot access any elements outside the
domain like as we said in the example
yahoo.com this was the same origin
policy now to overcome this what this
gentleman did was he created something
called as selenium remote control server
to trick the browser in believing that
your course your selenium core and your
web application under test are from the
same domain and this is what was the
selenium remote control so if you look
at again high level architecture or how
did this actually work first you write
your test scripts which is here right in
any of the supported language like your
PHP or your Java or Python and before we
start testing we need to launch this RC
server which is a separate application
so this selenium server is responsible
for receiving the Cellini's commands and
these Cellini's commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your RC server the browser interaction
which happens through RC server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple HTTP post and
get request and that is how your RC
server and your browser communicate and
how exactly this communication happens
this RC server it acts like a proxy so
say your test scripts asked to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your RC
server launches the browser it injects
the JavaScript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your test script right from your
test scripts to your browser goes
through your RC and now upon upon
receiving these instruction your
selenium core executes this actual
commands as JavaScript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
RC to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
JavaScript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the RC server to the browser
collecting the results again from the RC
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so RC had definitely a lot of
shortcomings and what are those so RC
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your selenis commands
and your browser the architecture of RC
is complicated it why because of its
intermediate RC server which is required
to communicate with the browser the
execution of commands takes very long it
is slower we know why because every
command in this takes a full trip from
the test script to your RC server to the
core engine to the browser and then back
to the same route which makes your
overall test execution very slow lastly
the AP is supported by RC are very
redundant and confusing so RC does have
a good number of apis however it is less
object oriented so they are redundant
and confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commas
using a click or a mouse door both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is the kind of
confusion which developers use to create
hence
selenium RC got deprecated and is no
more available in later selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls web driver was
introduced so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver was introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. It's a class platform
testing platform so Webdriver can run on
any platform like say Linux Windows Mac
or even if you have a Ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ID and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver method so
when I do a demo you will understand
what this Webdriver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like RC so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the RC hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs and this
driver is responsible to make the
browser understand the commands which
you will be passing from the script like
say for example click of a button or you
want to enter some text so through your
script you tell which browser you want
to work with say Chrome and then the
Chrome driver is responsible for
interpreting your instructions and to
execute it on the web application
launched on the Chrome browser so like
RC Webdriver also supports multiple
programming languages in which you can
write your test Scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various Frameworks like test NG
junit and unit and Report entry so when
we talk about the limitations of
Webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various Frameworks and tools
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
Webdriver at a high level what is in
Webdriver so Webdriver consists of four
major components the first one is we
have got client libraries right or what
we also call it as language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if I go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your Bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all the
stabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that I'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you're
working with Java here what you need to
do is you need to download your Java
language binding so let's go back to the
presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser and when we do
the demo I'll be showing you some of
this APS right and these are nothing but
the rest apis and everything whatever we
do through the script happens through
the rest course then we have a Json wire
protocol what is Json JavaScript object
notation it is nothing but a standard
for exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
Json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as I said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation so does selenium so let's
look at what these limitations are and
if there are any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like APM
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool however what
selenium provides is a support for
integrating this APM tool which is
nothing but a mobile application
automation tool and using APM and
selenium you can still achieve mobile
application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium I said that with Webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of web driver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video on simply
learn website on selenium grid third
limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium Webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test engine report NG and even extend
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it also there are other
challenges with selenium like selenium
is not very good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like autoit
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium RC and the Webdriver
so RC has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
RC server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser web driver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed
it is slower in RC and much faster in
Webdriver why because in Webdriver we
have eliminated that complete layer of
selenium server right that's the RC
server and we established a direct
communication with the browser through
browser drivers it requires an RC server
to interact with the browsers we just
talked about it and whereas Webdriver
can directly interact with the browser
so RC again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant ABS which kept developers
guessing as which API to use for what
functionality however Webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
asay did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in Webdriver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website then type the
selenium in search bar and click on it
and click on the selenium 3.0 training
so we are basically searching for
selenium 3.0 training on the simply
learn website first let's do the steps
manually and then we will go ahead and
write the automation script so let's go
to my browser on my browser what I'll do
is let me first launch the simply learn
website
okay and here what my use case step says
is I need to search for selenium and
click on the search button so once I do
that it is going to give me a complete
list of all kind of selenium trainings
which is available with simpler and what
I'm interested in is the selenium 3.0
training here once I find this on the
web page I need to go and click on that
all right so this is all the steps which
we are going to perform in this use case
okay now so for writing the test cases
I'll be using an ID which is Eclipse
I've already installed my eclipse and
also I have installed selenium in this
instance of my Eclipse all right so if
you can see the reference library folder
here you will see all the jars which are
required for the selenium to work next
another prereq which is required for
selenium and that is your driver files
now every browser which you want to work
with has its own driver file to execute
your selenium scripts and since for this
demo I'll be working with the Firefox
browser I will need a driver file for
Firefox now driver file for Firefox is
the gecko driver which I have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers now where did I download
this from let's go ahead and see that so
if I go back to my browser and if you go
to your selenium HQ dot website you have
to go to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this
you'll see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
I am working on Mac this is the file
which I'm using if you are a Windows
user you need to download this ZIP file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
Firefox or a chrome driver for your
Chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class I already have a
package created in this project so I'll
use this project and create a new class
so I'll say create new Java class and
let's call this as
search training I'll be using a public
static wordman and I'll click on finish
so let's remove this Auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your code is what you need
to do is you need to define or declare
your driver variable using your class
web driver so what I would do is I'll
say Webdriver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this ID is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import Webdriver
from
org.opensq.cellaneous this is the
package which we will need all right so
you have a driver created which is of
the class web tracker and now after this
I'm going to create three methods all
right so first method I will have for
launching the Firefox browser okay and
then I will write a simple method for
searching selenium training and clicking
on it this is the actual use case what
we'll be doing and then third method I'm
going to write is just to close the
browser which I'm going to be opening
right so these are the different methods
which I'll be creating and from the
public static wordman I will just call
these methods one after the other okay
so let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the Firefox browser so I'll say public
void since my return type is null or
there is no return type for this let's
call it as launch browser okay all right
now in this for launching any browser I
need to mention two steps now the first
step is where I need to do a system.set
property okay let's do that first and
then I'll explain what this does I'll
just say system dot set property so this
accepts a key and a value pair so what
is my key here my key here is Webdriver
dot gecko dot driver and I need to
provide a value so value is nothing but
the path to the gecko driver and we know
that this gecko driver which I'm going
to use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
correct and that is what the path which
I'm going to provide here so here simply
I need to say drivers slash gecko driver
gecko all right done and let me close
this sentence all right now since I am a
Mac User my gecko driver installable is
just the name gecko driver if your
windows user and if you are running your
selenium scripts on the Windows machine
you need to provide a complete path to
this including dot exe because driver
executable on your machines is going to
be gecko driver.exe all right so just
make sure that your path which you
mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is I
need to just say driver is equal to new
Firefox driver okay so this command new
Firefox driver creates an instance of
the Firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the Firefox driver class is
present okay we did that now these two
lines are responsible for launching the
Firefox browser form so this is done so
what's my next step in the use case now
I need to launch the website simply
learn so for that we have a command
called driver dot get driver dot get
what it does is whatever URL you're
going to give it here in this double
quotes as an argument it is going to
launch that particular website and for
us it's a simply learn website so what I
do as a best practices instead of typing
out the URL I go to my browser launch
that URL which I want to test and I
simply copy it come back to your eclipse
and just simply paste it so this ensures
that I do not make any mistakes in the
URL okay so done so our first method is
ready where we are launching the browser
which is our Firefox browser and then
launching the simply learn website now
the next method what is my next method
in my next method I need to give the
search string to search selenium
training on this particular website now
for that we need to do few things what
are those few things let's go to the
website again all right so let me
relaunch this let's close this okay let
me remove all this and let's go to the
home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when I did a manual
testing of this I entered the text here
so now since I have to write a script
for this first I need to identify what
this element momentous for that what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to say
right click here and I'll say inspect
element all right now this element let's
see what attribute it has which I can
use for finding this element so I I see
that there is an ID present so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to Simply
use this ID and then I'll just copy this
ID from here go back to Eclipse let's
write a method first so I'll say public
void and what do we give the method name
say search training or just search all
right now in this I need to use a
command called driver dot find element
by ID is what I'm going to use as a
locating technique and in double quotes
the ID which I copied from the website
is what I'm going to paste here okay and
then what am I going to do on this
element is I need to send that text the
text which I'm going to search for which
is selenium so I'll just say send keys
and whatever text I want to send I need
to give it in double quotes So for that
selenium so this is done so now I've
entered the text texture and after
entering the text I need to click on
this button so for that I need to first
know what that button is so let's
inspect that search button okay now if
you look at the search button other than
the tag which is span and the class name
I do not have anything here all right so
what I can do is I can either use the
class name or I can write an X path
since this is a demo which we have
already used ID locating technique I
would go ahead and use the X path here
so for me to construct an X path I will
copy this class first okay and then I
already have a crow path installed on my
Firefox so I'll use the crow path and
first test my X bar so I'll just say
double slash let's see what was that
element it has a span tag okay so I'll
have to use span and at class equal to
and I'll just copy the class name here
and let's see if it can identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so I'll just use this x path in my code
so I'll go back to eclipse and I'll say
driver dot find element buy Dot X path
and the X path which I just copied from
cropath is what I'm going to paste here
and what is the action I need to do here
I need to say click done so I have
reached a stage where I have entered
this selenium okay and then I have
clicked on the search button once I do
this I know that expected result is I
should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3.0 training okay and
I should be able to click on that so for
that again I need to inspect this so
let's inspect this selenium 3.2 all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag H2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so I would again would like
to use a x path here now this time while
using the X path I am going to make use
of a text functionality so that I can
search for this particular text so I'll
simply copy this I'll go to my Crow path
the tag is H2 so I'll say simply H2 okay
and here I'll say text equal to and this
is the text which I copied I'm installed
that yes there so I'm just going to add
an S okay so let's first test here
whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see your blue dotted line it
is able to show us which element it is
identified so I'll copy this x path now
and let's go to my ID Eclipse so now
here what I need to do is I'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot X path and paste the X path which
we just did and then again I have to do
a click operation done all right so
technically we have taken all the steps
of the use case and we have written the
commands for that now let's add an
additional thing here say after coming
to this page after finding this we want
to uh say print the title of this page
now what is the title of this page if
you just hover your mouse on this it
says online and classroom training for
professional certification courses
simply now so what I will do is after
doing all these operations I will just
print out this page title on our console
so for that I have to just do this try
fiber dot so let's do a sys out so I'll
say sys out
system.out.println okay and here I would
say let's add a text here the page title
is and then let's append it with driver
dot get title so this is the command
which we'll be using to fetch the page
title done now what is the last method I
need to add just to close the browser
all right so let me add a method here
I'll say public void close browser and
it's a one single command which I need
to call I'll say driver dot quit Okay
and then I need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so I let me use my class name which is
this so I'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is I need to
call the method launch browser and then
I'll call the method search right and
then I'll call the method close browser
so technically our script is ready with
all the functionality which we wanted to
cover from our use case now there are
few other tweaks which I need to do this
and I'll tell you why I need to do this
now for example after we click here
right after we click on the search if
you observed on your website it took a
little while before it listed out all
the selenium trainings for us and
usually when you are actually doing it
you wait for the selenium 3.0 training
to be available and then you click on
that now same thing you also need to
tell your scripts to do that you need to
tell your scripts to wait for a while
until you start seeing the selenium 3.0
training or it appears on your web page
there are multiple ways to do that in
your script and it is a part of overall
synchronization what we call where we
use kind of implicit and explicit kind
of image now since this is a demo for
demo purpose what I'm going to do is I
am going to use a command called
thread.sleep and I'm just going to give
an explicit weight of say three seconds
so you can use this Main only for the
demo purposes you can use a thread.sleep
command now this thread.sleep command
needs us to handle some exceptions so
I'm just going to click on ADD throws
declaration and say interrupted
exception now same thing I'll have to do
it in my main function also okay so
let's do that and complete it all right
so this is done so by doing this what am
I doing I'm ensuring that before I click
on the selenium three dot training we
are giving enough time for the script to
wait until the web page shows this link
to the selenium 3.0 training that's one
thing I'm doing all right and also now
since you are going to be seeing this
demo through the video recording the
script when it starts running it is
going to be very fast so you might just
miss out saying how it does the send
keys and how did it click on the search
button for us to enable us to see it
properly I'll just add some explicit
weights here just for a demo purpose so
after entering the keys right so what
I'll do is I'll just give a simple
thread.sleep here now
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds which should be good enough okay
at three seconds weight should be good
enough here so that we should be able to
see how exactly this works on your
browser when we execute this okay now
our complete script is ready so what
I'll do is I'll just save the script and
then we will simply run the script so to
run the script I just say right click
run as Java application okay it says ask
me to select and save I have saved the
script now so let's observe how it runs
okay the simply learn.com the website is
launched so the selenium text has been
entered in the search box it has clicked
on the search okay all right so now it
did everything whatever we wanted it to
do all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what I have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what I'll do
since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3. training or
not I'll just comment out the closed
browser the command okay so we will not
call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we don't need this Firefox window
close all tabs and then I'll just
re-execute this script so I'll say run
as Java application so save the file
okay simplylearn.com is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes all right
so we have got the search results it
should click on selenium 3.0 training
and yes it is successfully able to click
on that all right so now it's not going
to close the browser because we have
commented on that line however it did
print us the title here all right so
this is a simple way of using the
selenium Scripts selenium grid so grid
is used to run multiple test scripts on
multiple machines at the same time with
Webdriver you can only do sequential
execution but in real time environment
you always have the need to run test
cases in distributed environment and
that is where selenium grid comes into
picture so grid was conceptualized and
developed by Patrick the main objective
is to minimize test execution type and
how by running your test parallelly so
design is in such a way that commands
are distributed on multiple machines
where you want to run tests and all
these are executed simultaneously what
do you achieve by this methodology of
course the parallel execution on
different browsers and operating system
grid is pretty flexible and can
integrate with many tools like say you
want a reporting tool integrated to pull
all the reports from the multiple
machines where you're running your test
cases and you want to present that
report in a good looking format so you
have an option to integrate such report
okay so how does this grid work so grid
has as a hub and node concept which
helps in achieving the parallel
execution let's take an example say your
application supports all browsers and
most of the operating system like as in
this picture you could say one of them
is a Windows machine one of them is a
Mac machine and another one is say a
Linux machine so your requirement is to
run the test on all supported browsers
and operating system like the one which
is depicted in this picture so what you
have to do is first thing is you
configure a Master machine or what you
also call it as a hub by running
something called a selenium Standalone
server and this Talent Standalone server
can be downloaded from the selenium HQ
website using the server you create a
hub configuration that is this node and
then you create nodes specific to your
machine requirement and how are these
nodes created you again use the same
server which is your Standalone selenium
server to create the node configuration
so I'll show you where the selenium
server can be downloaded so if we go
back to our selenium HQ website so you
can see here right on the top it says
selenium Standalone server and this is
the latest version available so you just
need to download once you download this
keep a version of this one on your
master machine that is your Hub and this
should also be present on your node
machines and there is a certain command
which you can use to install the server
as a node and as a master depending on
your configuration so once that is done
you have your master and your master or
the Hub and the notes created your
master can control on which nodes you
want to execute test now say if this is
a Mac machine this is a Windows machine
through your master or your Hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what is then also you could have
a multiple combination of tests like say
for example smoke test to be run on all
these nodes that's the kind of
configuration you can create or a
certain component and test to be run on
say only Windows 10 with an edge browser
or say regression test on Mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the Hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the Node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the Node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does is grid have now
the first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to vary this
you'll need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow on any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on Virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of test within a
very short time frame let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second Advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support So this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping in achieving a
very broad test coverage and we also saw
that really easy to use tool right so
you can check out all our videos and you
can it's just a matter of time that you
can Master the skill of writing your
automation scripts reusability of course
like any programming language it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy well again
let's see an overall what are the
limitations of selenium itself now since
selenium is open source that is one of
the biggest Advantage now there is a
little disadvantage which comes with
that and what is that you do not have
much technical support because it's an
open source code however there are loads
and loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like APM for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like autoit and securely which can be
integrated with selenium selenium
Webdriver has limited a limited
reporting capability but again it does
provide us support for integrating tools
like test NG report NG and extend report
it does not have test management
capabilities it need not right not one
tool need not have each and everything
what is required but there is always a
way to integrate it so selenium does
provide a way to integrate any of the
test management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as an disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation today we're going
to go through interview questions that
you are likely to be asked if you are
interviewing for a job that focuses on
devops so there are approximately seven
sections that we cover in devops we go
from general devops questions source
code management with tools such as git
continuous integration and here we'll
focus on Jenkins continuous testing with
tools such as selenium and then you also
have the operations side of devops which
is your configuration management with
tools such as Chef puppet and ansible
containerization with Docker and then
continuous monitoring with tools such as
nagios so let's just get into those
general devops questions so one of the
questions that you're going to be asked
is how is devops different from agile
and the reality is is that devops is a
cultural way of being able to deliver
Solutions that's different from agile if
we look at the evolution of delivery
Over The Line five to ten years we've
gone from waterfall based delivery to
Agile delivery which is on Sprints to
where we are with continuous integration
and continuous delivery around devops
the whole concept of devops is
culturally very very different from
agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and op team
another area in which I see that devops
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app to your
chatbot or any digital solution that you
have and has an expectation when you're
going through and actually doing a
devops paradigm the old model would be
that you would capture requirements from
the customer then you do your
development then you do your testing and
there'd be these barriers between each
of those as we move faster through from
waterfall to Agile what we saw is that
with agile we're able to respond much
faster to customer demand so instead of
it being weeks or months sometimes in
some cases years between releases of
software what we saw it would was a
transition to weeks and months for
releases on software now we see with
devops is that the release cycle has
shrunk even further with the goal of
continuously delighting the customer how
further has that release cycle shrunk to
there are companies that have gone from
having releases of once a week week or
once every two weeks or once a month to
now having multiple releases a day
indeed some companies have up to 50
releases a day this isn't something to
also bear in mind is that each of those
releases are tested and verified against
test records so that you can guarantee
that the code that's going to production
is going to be good continuous code so
what are the differences between the
different phases of devops so
effectively there are two main phases of
devops there's the planning and coding
phase and then there's the deploying
phase and you have a tool such as
Jenkins that allows you to integrate
between both environments some of the
core benefits that you may have to
devops are going to be some technical
benefits and some business benefits so
when somebody asks you what are the
benefits of devops you can reply that
from a technical point of view you're
able to use continuous software delivery
to constantly push out code that has
been tested and verified against scripts
that have been written and approved you
can be able to push out smaller chunks
of code so that when you have an issue
you're not having to go through massive
blocks of code or massive projects
you're going through just very small
micro services or small sections of code
and you're able to detect and correct
problems faster on the business side the
benefits are absolutely fantastic from a
customer that's coming to your website
and or to your mobile app they're going
to see responses happening continuously
so that the customer is always aware
that you as a company are listening to
their demands and responding
appropriately you're able to provide a
more stable environment and you're able
to scale that environment to the demands
of the number of customers that are
using your services so how you approach
a project that needs to implement devops
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in so there are effectively
three stages when it comes to actually
working in a devops the first stage is
an assessment stage and think of this as
the back of the napkin ideation stage
this is where you are sitting with a
business leader and they're giving you
ideas of what they would like to see
from feedback that they've had from
their customers this is Blue Sky
opportunity this is thinking of Big
Ideas that second stage and this often
comes as a fast follow to stage one it's
actually proving out that concept so
developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be a
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering will really depend on
how complicated you want the POC to be
but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the POC so that when you
present this to a customer they're able
to respond to that creation that you've
developed and able to give you feedback
to be able to validate that you are
going with the right solution and able
to provide the right product to your
customers that third stage is where you
get into your devops stage and this is
just the exciting part this is where the
rubber hits the road and you start
releasing code based on a backlog of
features that are being requested for
the solution in contrast to doing agile
delivery where you just continuously
work through a backlog with devops what
you're also looking at is putting an
analytics and sensors to be able to
validate that you are being successful
with the solution that's being delivered
so that once you've actually start
delivering out code that customers can
interact with you want to be able to see
what are the pieces of the solution that
they are using what do they like what is
complicated where are the failure points
and you want to use that data and feed
that bag into your continuous
integration and have that as a means to
be able to backfill the demand of work
that gets completed in the bank log so
what is the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment so continuous delivery is
based on putting out code that can be
deployed safely to production and
ensures that your businesses and
functions are running as you would
expect them to be so it's going through
and completing the code that you would
actually see continuous deployment in
contrast is all about ensuring that
you're automating the deployment of a
production environment so you're able to
go through and scale up your
environments to meet the demands of both
the solution and the customer this makes
software development and release
processes much more faster and more
robust so if we look here we can
actually see where continuous
integration and continuous deployment
come hand in hand so when you actually
start out with the initial pushes of
your code that's where you're doing your
continuous integration and your
continuous delivery and then at some
point you want to get very comfortable
with deploying the code that you're
creating so it's been pushed out to your
production environment so one of the
things that's great about working with
the tools that you use in a devops
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment and
what this means is that when you
actually come to deploying solutions to
production there are no surprises
because your development team have been
working against that exact same
environment all the way through so a
question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of a
configuration management and devops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas and the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences
because the ability manage and handle
large changes to multiple systems in
seconds rather than days hours or weeks
as that may have happened before the
second area is that you want to also
demonstrate the business reasons for
having configuration management and the
business reason here is that it allows
it and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability ability to
scale so if you have configuration
management tools you're able to manage a
significant number of servers and
domains that may have multiple servers
in it allows you to effectively manage
servers that are deployed on cloud or
private cloud and allow you to do this
with high accuracy so how does
continuous monitoring help in maintain
the entire architecture of the system so
when this question comes up you want to
dig in and show your knowledge on how
configuration and continuous monitoring
is able to control an entire environment
so the number one topic that you want to
bring up when it comes to continuous
monitoring is that worth being able to
effectively monitor your entire network
24 7. for any changes as they happen
you're able to identify and Report those
thoughts or threats immediately and
respond immediately for your entire
network work instead of having to wait
as it happens sometimes for a customer
to email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self-audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for devops is Amazon's
web Services AWS and they have a really
five distinct areas that you can zero in
on board services so when the question
comes up what is the role of AWS in
devops you want to really hold out your
hand and list of five areas of focus
using your thumb and finger so you want
to have flexible Services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that AWS and
and other Cloud providers but AWS is 70
the leader in this space are great for
being able to provide support for the
role of devops so one of the things that
we want to be able to do effectively
when we're releasing any kind of
solution is to be able to measure that
solution and so kpis are very important
so you will be asked for three important
Dev of kpis and so three that really
come to mind that are very effective the
first one is mean time to fail earlier
recovery and what this talks about is
what is the average time does it take to
recover from a failure and if you have
experience doing this then look at the
experience you have and use a specific
example where you are able to
demonstrate that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy Solutions and
what actually happens when you're
actually doing those deployments and
what does the impact to your network
look like when you're doing those
deployments and then the third one is
really tied to that deployment frequency
which is around what is the percentage
of failed deployments and so how many
times did you deploy to a server and
something happened where the server
itself failed what we're looking for
when you're going through and being
asked for these kpis is experience with
actually doing a devops deployment and
being able to understand what devops
looks like when you're pushing out your
infrastructure and then this second is
being able to validate that
self-auditing ability and one word of
caution is don't go in there and say
that you have a hundred percent success
the reality is that servers do degrade
over time and you maybe want to talk
about a time when a server did degrade
in your environment and use that as a
story for how you're able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
going to be asked to explain
infrastructure as code and really it's
it's something that actually becomes a
byproduct of the work you have to do
when you're actually putting together
your devops environment and
infrastructure's code really refers to
the writing of code to actually manage
your environment and you can go through
many of the other tools that we've
covered in this series but you'll see
that XML or Ruby or yaml are used as
languages to describe Drive the
configuration for your environment this
allows you to then create the rules and
instructions that can be read by the
machines that are actually setting up
the physical Hardware versus a
traditional model which is having
software and installing that software
directly onto the machine this is really
important when it comes to cloud
computing there really is a strong
emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental to
the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as yaml to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
Technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
source code management with Git is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to git is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
Version Control and if we look at the
way that the two are set up older
Technologies such as older versions of
Team Foundation server though the
current version does actually have get
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in
and check out of code the developer in
the centralized system does not have all
the files for the application and if the
centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly onto your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows for
scalability when it comes to building
out your team so if you have a team that
may be in Europe you can actually then
scale that team with people from Asia
from North America or South America very
easily and not have to worry about
whether or not they have the right code
or the wrong code and in addition to
that if the actual main server where
you're checking in your code does crash
it's not a big deal because you actually
have each person has a copy of the code
so as soon as the server comes back up
you have to check back in and
everybody's running back as if there was
nothing had happened at all so one of
the questions you'll be asked is to give
the answer to some of the commands you
use for working with Git so if you were
to be asked the question is what is the
command that downloads any repository
from GitHub to your computer on the
screen you have four options we have git
push get Fork get clone and get commit
the answer in this instance would be get
clone now if you want to be able to push
code from your local system to a GitHub
repository using git then first of all
you want to be able to do is connect the
local opacity to a remote repository and
in the example you may want to talk
about using the command get remote ad
origin and then the actual path to a
GitHub repository you could if you
wanted to actually at this point also
talk about other repositories such as
get lab that you can also work with or a
private get repository that would be
used just for the development team once
you've actually then added the local
repository into your local computer then
the second action you want to use is a
push which is to actually push your
local files out to the master
environment so you use the command on
git push origin master so one question
you may be asked is what is the
difference between a bear repository and
a standard way of initializing a git
repository so let's look through what is
the standard way so the standard way
using get init allows you to create a
working directory using the command git
in it and then the folder that creates
is the folder that creates all the
revision history related to the work
that you're doing in contrast using the
bear way you have a different command
for setting that up so it would be git
init dash dash bear and it does not
contain any working or checked out
source files locally on your machine in
addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you'd have with
the normal get in its initialization so
which of the following CLI commands
would you be used to rename a file so we
have get RM get MV git RM Dash r or none
of the above well in this instance it
would be gate MV a question that you'll
be asked around commit is going to be
what is the process to revert a commit
that has already been pushed and made
public and there are two ways you can
address this the first is to actually
address the bad file in the new commit
and you can use the command git commit
Dash M and then put in a comment for why
that file is being removed the second is
to actually create a new commit that
actually undoes all the changes that
were made with the bad commit and then
to do that you would use git revert and
then the commit ID and the commit ID and
it could be something such as
560e0938f but you'd have to find that
from the the commit that you had made
but that would allow you to revert any
bad files that you had submitted so the
two ways of being able to get files from
a get repository and you're going to be
asked to explain the difference between
get fetch and get Paul so get fetch
allows you to fetch and download only
new data from a new repository it does
not integrate any of the new data into
your working files and it can be undone
at any time if you want to break out the
remote tracking branches in contrast get
pull updates the current head Branch
with the latest changes from the remote
server so you get all of the files and
downloaded it downloads new data and
integrates it with the current working
files you have on your system and it
tries to merge remote changes with your
local ones so one of the questions
you'll get asked about get is what is a
get stash so as a developer you will be
working on the con Branch within a
solution but what happens if you come up
with an idea where it's something that
will take a different amount of time for
you to be able to complete but you don't
want to interrupt the main Mainline
Branch so what you can actually do is
you can actually create a branch that
allows you to start working on your own
work outside of the mainline branch and
this is called git stash allows you to
be able to modify your files without
interrupting the mainline Branch so you
once you start talking about branching
in git be prepared to answer and explain
the concept of branching so essentially
what it allows you to do is have a
Mainline Master branch that has all the
code that the team is checking in and
checking out against but allows you to
have an indefinite number of branches
that allows for new features to be built
in parallel to the mainline branch and
then at some point be reintroduced to
the mainline Branch to allow the team to
add in new features and so if we look
through the merge and get rebase these
are the two features that you'd be using
can continuously to be able to talk
about how you take a branch and merge it
back into the mainline Branch so on the
left hand side we have get merge which
allows you to take the code that you're
creating and merge it back into the
master on the right hand side what you
have is a slightly different approach
this is for projects where you reach a
point in a project where you go okay
we're going to effectively restart the
project at this point in time and we
want to ignore the complete history
that's happened before that and that's
called get rebase and that would allow
you to rewrite the project history by
creating a brand new Mainline branch
that ignores all other previous branches
that have happened before it you can if
you want to very quickly and easily find
out all the files that have been used to
make a particular commit so when
somebody asks you the question how do
you find a list of files that's been
changed in a particular commit you can
actually say that and all you have to go
is find the command get div tree dash R
and then the hash that you would use for
the commit and that would actually then
give you a breakdown of all the files
that have been made with that particular
commit a question that you'll be asked
when you're talking about merging files
is what is a merge conflict in git and
how can it be resolved so essentially a
merge conflict is when you have two or
more branches that are competing with
commits in git and you have to be able
to determine which is the appropriate
files that need to be submitted and this
is where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you're going
to be able to show how that pull request
would be demonstrated inside of GitHub
So within the pull request there's going
to be a highlight of conflict markers
and you'll be able to select which
conflicts you want to keep and which you
want to merge and which ones you want to
change so if it's a step through how you
would actually resolve a merge conflict
and the first step would be under GitHub
you want to be able to pull the
repository name and then the pull
request around that repository in the
pull request list click the pull request
with a merge conflict and that you'd
like to be able to resolve they'll pull
up a file they'll list out all of the
conflicts for you near the bottom of
that file will be a list of the requests
that need to be resolved and then if you
need to make a decision on which
branches you want to keep or which ones
you want to change that will have to be
something you have to put in
instructions inside of the file you'll
actually see that there are conflict
markers within the instructions which
are going to ask you which files you
want to change and which ones you want
to keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your file scroll down to the
next set of conflict markers and repeat
steps four and five until you resolve
all of the conflicts you will want to
mark your file as resolve in GitHub so
that the repository knows that you are
having everything resolved if you have
more than one file with a conflict then
you want to go then on to the next file
and start working on those files and
just keep repeating the steps we've done
up to this point until you have all of
the conflicts resolved and then once you
have all of the resolutions created then
you want to select the button which is
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into GitHub and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within GitHub so you
can also do this through command line
and with the command line you want to
use a get bash and so you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local get repository and
command line by using the CD change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide.md
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with GitHub you actually go
through and use a text editor and use
any text editor but as you go through
and edit out what you want to keep and
what you want to manage in your conflict
so you actually have a resolution that's
been created so that you'll be able to
then once you you're using the conflict
markers you can actually merge your
files together so that the solution
itself will allow you to incorporate
your commits effectively into the
resolution once you've gone through and
applied your changes you're able to then
merge the conflicted commits into a
single commit and able to push that up
to your remote repository all right
let's talk about the next section which
is continuous integration with Jenkins
so the first question you'll be asked
about with Jenkins is explain a Master
Slave architecture of Jenkins so the way
that Jenkins is set up is that the
Jenkins Master will pull code from your
remote git repository such as GitHub and
we'll check that repository every time
there is a code commit it will
distribute the workload of that code and
the tests that need to be applied to
that code to all of the Jenkins slaves
and then on request the Jenkins master
and the slaves will then carry out all
the builds and tests to be able to
produce test reports the next question
you'll be asked is what is a Jenkins
file and simply put a Jenkins file as a
text file that has a definition of the
Jenkins Pipeline and is checked into a
source code repository and this really
allows for three display things to
happen one it allows for code review and
iteration of the pipeline it permits an
audit Trail for that Pipeline and also
provides a single source of troop for
the pipeline which can be viewed and
edited so which of the following
commands runs Jenkins from the command
line is it Java Dash jar jenkins.war
Java Dash War jenkins.jar Java dot dash
jar Jenkins jar Java Dash War Jenkins
dot wall and the answer is a Java Dash
jar jenkins.war so when working with
Jenkins you're going to be asked what
are the key Concepts and aspects of
working with the Jenkins Pipeline and
you want to really hold out your fingers
here and go through four key areas and
that is pipeline node step and stay so
pipeline refers to the use defined model
of a CD continuous delivery pipeline
node are the machines which is which are
part of their Jenkins environment within
the pipeline step is a single task that
tells Jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire Pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to Define
dependency in Maven and do we have A
build.xml B palm.xml C
dependency.xml or D version dot XML and
the answer is
palm.xml working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
the domain-specific language for Jenkins
and there are one or more note blocks
that are used throughout the entire
Pipeline on the left hand side you can
actually see what they are script would
look like and the right hand side shows
what the actual declaration for each
section of that script would be the
second time of Jenkins pipeline is a
declarative Pipeline and a declarative
pipeline provides a simple and a
friendly syntax to Define what the
pipeline should look like and then you
can actually at this point use an
example to actually break out how blocks
are used to define the work completed in
a decorative pipeline so how do you
create a copy and backup of Jenkins well
to create a backup periodically backup
Jenkins to your Jenkins home directory
and then create a copy of that directory
it's really as simple as that the
question you'll be asked as well is how
can you copy Jenkins from one server to
another well there are essentially there
are three ways to do that one is you can
move a job from one installation of
Jenkins to another by copying the
corresponding job directory the second
would be to create a copy of an existing
job directory and making a clone of that
job directory but with a different name
and the third is to rename an existing
job by renaming a directory so security
is fundamental to all the work that we
do within devops and Jenkins provides
the center core to all the work that
gets completed within a devops
environment there are three ways in
which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a Jenkins has his own internal
database that uses secured user data
from and user credentials B is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or C you can
actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core plug-in within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot HPI plugin file into the Jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi dot pen and once you've
completed these three steps restart
Jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the fake file you should see that it's
set to True which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false Security will
be disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time Jenkins
is restarted so what are the ways in
which a build can be scheduled and run
in Jenkins well there are four ways in
which you can identify the way a build
can be scheduled on running Jenkins the
first is when source code management
commits new code into the repository you
can run Jenkins at that point the second
can be after the completion of other
builds so maybe you have multiple builds
in your project that are dependent on
each other and when so many other builds
have been executed then you can have
Jenkins run you can schedule builds to
run at a specified time so you may have
nightly bills of your code that
illustrates the changes in the solution
you're building and then and finally you
also can manually build a environment on
request occasionally you will want to
also restart Jenkins and so it's good
that when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
bills to complete by using the Jenkins
URL that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the URL for your Jenkins
environment slash safe restart so let's
go into the fourth and final section of
this first video which talks about
continuous testing with selenium so the
first question you will be asked most
likely around selenium are what are the
four different selenium components and
again you want to hold open your fingers
because there are four distinct
environments you have selenium
integrated development environment or
selling IDE you have selenium remote
control or selenium RC you have selenium
web driver and then selenium grid you'll
be asked to explain each of those areas
in more detail but let's start off with
by looking at selenium driver what are
the different exceptions in selenium
Webdriver so it's useful to remember
that an exception is an event that
occurs during the execution of a program
that disrupts the normal flow of that
program's instructions and so we have
four we have a timeout exception an
element not visible exception no such
element exception and a session not
found exception and each of those if we
step through them are the four different
types of exceptions that can be thrown
up when using the selenium Webdriver so
as we evolve in our digital world with
the different types of products that are
available for us to be able to build
Solutions onto multiple platforms you're
going to be asked can selenium and other
devops tools run in other environments
and so a good question around this is
cancellium test and application in an
Android web browser and the short answer
is absolutely yes it can we have to use
the Android driver for it to be able to
work so you want to be able to talk
about the three different types of
supported tests within selenium so when
the question comes up what are the
different test types supported by Salam
you can answer that and there are three
different types of tests first is a
functional test second is a regression
test and third is a load testing test
the functional test is a kind of Black
Box testing in which test case are based
on a specific area or feature within the
software a regression test helps you
find any specific areas that functional
tests or non-functional areas of the
code wouldn't be able to detect the load
testing test allows you to monitor the
response of a solution as you increase
the volume of hits and how you're using
the code are put onto it an additional
question you'll be asked is how can you
get a text of a web element using
selenium but the get command is due to
achieve text of a specific web element
now it's important to remember however
that the command does not return any
parameters but just returns a string
value so you want to be able to capture
that stream value and discuss about it a
question you'll be asked around selenium
is can you handle keyboard and mouse
actions using selenium and the answer is
yes you can but you have to make sure
that you're using the advanced user
interaction API and the advanced user
interaction API is something that can be
scripted into your test and it allows
you for capturing methods such as a
click and hold and drag and drop Mouse
events and then keyboard down or
keyboard up a key release events so that
if you want to to capture say the use of
control roll shift or a specific
function button of the keyboard you'd be
able to capture those of the following
four elements which of these elements is
not a web element method a get text B
size C get tag name d send keys and it's
B size you're going to be asked to
explain what is the difference for when
we use find element or find elements and
so if we look at find element find
element finds the first element in the
current web page that matches the
specified locator value in contrast find
elements finds all of the elements on
the web page that matches the specified
value when using Webdriver what are the
driver close and Driver quit commands
and these are two different methods used
to close a web browser session in
selenium so driver close will close the
current web browser which your focus is
set and Driver quick closes all the
browser windows and ends the web driver
session completely the final question
that you are likely to be asked in using
selenium is how can you submit a form
using selenium well in this instance
that's relatively easy the following
lines of code will let you submit a form
in selenium which would be web element
El equals driver dot find element and
then you put in the ID and the element
ID and then L submit open close
parentheses semicolon so let's just get
into the first section which is
configuration management so one of the
questions that you'll get asked right
away is why do you have SSL certificates
used for Chef really fundamentally your
immediate answer should be security SSL
provides for a very high level of
private security and private and public
key pairing this really is essential to
ensure that you have a secure
environment throughout your entire
network the second part should be that
if you're using SSM and you're using the
private public key model within SSL
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that the chef that you'll
be able to validate that the nodes
within your network that Chef is
validating against actually are the real
nodes themselves not imposters so you
will also be asked some questions such
as the following which is the following
commands which you use to stop or
disable the HTTP service when the system
boots and you'll typically get four
responses and there'll be hashtag
systemctl disable
httpd.service or is it system disable
http.service system disable httpd or the
final option which is systemctl disable
httpd dot service your answer should be
the first one which is hashtag systemctl
disable
http.service so Chef comes with a series
of tools and allowed to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about is what
is 10 best kitchen and Test Kitchen is
essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to test out your
cookbook before you actually deploy it
to a real node so some of the commands
that you would use are for instance if
you want to create an instance of Test
Kitchen you would do kitchen create if
you want to destroy an instance after
you've created it you do kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances you would do kitchen
converge so a question you'll get is
around Chef is how does Chef apply
differ from Chef clients it's a
fundamentally the difference between
them is that Chef apply will validate
the recipe that you're working on
whereas Chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on the recipe and the other is
focus on the entire cookbook so there
are some differences when you're working
with different command lines so for
instance and when you're working with
puppets and and you're working with one
version of puppets and you want to do
what is the command to sign a requested
certificate the top example here is for
puppet version 2.7 whereas the lower
option here is for puppet version three
that's something to bear in mind when
you're going through your interview
process is that the tools that are used
within a continuous integration can
continuous delivery devops model do vary
and so you want to be able to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools so that when
you're talking to your interviewer
you're able to show you the Deep
knowledge that you have which open
source or Community tools do you use to
make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
Foundation of puppet itself and so the
three options you have is being able to
track configurations with jira which you
should be doing anyway but it's a great
way to be able to clearly communicate
the work that's been done with puppet
our Version Control can be extended with
get and then the changes should be
passed through Jenkins so the three
tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira Git and Jenkins so
what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are four the
resources are basic units of any
configuration management tool they are
the features of the nodes they are the
written catalog and the execution of the
catalog on a node so as we dig deeper
into puppets one of the things that you
are likely to be asked regarding puppet
is what is a class and puppets and so a
class in public is really the name
blocks in your manifest that contain the
various configurations and this income
include Services files and packages and
we have on the screen here example of
what a class would look like when you
write it out and you may want to
memorize just one class don't memorize
just a whole set of classes just
memorize one the person's interviewing
you is just really looking for someone
who has a working knowledge they're not
looking for you to have memorized
complete massive classes but having one
small class to be able to illustrate the
experience you have is extremely
valuable to the interviewer and
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into ansible one
of the things that you're going to be
asked around ansible is what is ansible
role so a role is an independent block
of tasks and variable files and
templates embedded with inside of the
Playbook so the example we have here on
the screen actually shows you one role
within a Playbook and in this role it is
to install Tomcat on a node again as
with previous question within puppet of
a class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two roles so you
can talk knowledgeably about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible when
should you be using the curly brackets
and so just as a framework reference and
there's often two different ways that
these kind of brackets are referred to
now they're either referred to as French
brackets or curly brackets either way
and what you'll be wanting to ask is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets within ansible and really
the answer comes down to two things one
is that it makes it easier to
distinguish strings and undefined
variables and the second is for putting
together conditional statements when you
are actually using variables and the
example we have here is this prints the
value of and we have Foo and we have to
then put in the variable conditional
statement of Foo is defined as something
so what is the best way to make content
reusable and redistributable with
ansible and there's really essentially
three the first is to include a sub
module or another file in your playbook
the second is to important Improvement
of an include which ensures that a file
is added only once and then the third is
roles to manage the task within the
Playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide a differences between ansible
and puppets so if we look at animal it's
a very easy agentless installation it's
based on python you can configure it
with yaml and there are no support for
Windows in contrast puppet is an agent
based installation it's written in Ruby
the configuration files are written in
DSL and it has support on all popular
operating systems so we dig deeper into
the actual architecture ansible it has a
much more simple architecture and it's
definitely a push only architecture in
contrast to puppet it's a more
complicated but more sophisticated
architecture where you're able to have a
complete environment managed by the
puppet architecture so let's get on to
our next section which is
containerization so let's go through and
you're going to be asked to explain what
the architecture of Docker is and docker
really is the most popular
containerization environment so Docker
uses a client server architecture and
the docker client is a service which
runs in a command line and and then the
docker Daemon which is run as a rest API
within the command line will accept the
requests and interacts with the
operating system in order to build the
docker images and run the docker
containers and then the docker image is
a template of instructions which is used
to create containers the docker
container is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
together and then finally the docker
registry is a service to host and
distribute Docker images among other
users so you'll also be asked to provide
what are the advantages of Docker over
virtual machine and and this is
something that comes up very
consistently in fact and you may want to
even extend it as having what are the
differences between having a dedicated
machine a virtual machine and a Docker
or docker-like environment and really
the arguments for Docker are just
absolutely fantastic you know first of
all Docker does contain an occupy docket
containers occupy significantly less
space than a virtual machine or a
dedicated machine the boot up time on
Docker is significantly faster than a VM
containers have a much better
performance as they are hosted in a
single Docker image Docker is highly
efficient and very easy to scale
particularly when you start working with
kubernetes easily portable across
multiple platforms and then finally for
space allocation Docker data volumes can
be shared and reused among multiple
containers the argument against virtual
machines is significant and particularly
if you're going into an older
environment where a company is still
using actual dedicated hardware and
haven't moved to a cloud or cloud-like
environment your Arguments for Docker
are going to be very very persuasive be
very clear on what the advantages are
for Docker over a virtual machine
because you want to be able to
succinctly share them with your team and
this is something that's important when
you're going through the interview
process but also equally important
particularly if you're working with a
company that's transitioning or going
through a digital transformation where
they aren't used to working with the
tools like Docker you need to be able to
effectively share with that team what
the benefits are so how do we share
Docker containers with different nodes
and in this instance what you want to be
able to do is Leverage The Power of
Docker swarm so Docker swarm is a tool
which allows the it administrators and
developers to create and manage clusters
of swarm nodes within the darker
platform and there are two elements to
the node there's the manager node and
then there's the the worker node the
manager node as you'd assume manages the
entire infrastructure and the working
node is actually the work of the agent
as it gets executed so what are the
commands to create a Docker Swan and so
here we have an example of what a
manager node would look like and once
you've created a swarm on your major
node you can now add worker nodes to
that swarm and again when you're
stepping through this process be very
precise in the execution part that needs
to be taken to be able to effectively
create a swan so start with the manager
node and then you create a worker node
and then finally when a node is
initializes a major note it can
immediately create a token and that
token is used for the worker nodes and
associating the IP address with the
worker nodes question 17 how to run
multiple containers using a single
service it is possible to run multiple
containers as a single service by using
Docker compose and Docker compose will
actually run each of the services in
isolation so that they can interact with
each other the language used to write
out the compose files that allow you to
run the service is called yaml and yaml
stands for yet another markup language
so what is the use of a Docker file so a
Docker file actually is used for
creating Docker images using the build
command account so let's go through and
show on the screen what that would look
like and this would be an opportunity
where if you're actually in a technical
interview you could potentially even ask
hey can I draw on a whiteboard and show
you what the architecture for using the
build command would look like and what
the process would look like again when
you're going through an interview
process as someone who interviews a lot
of people one of the things I really
like is when an interview candidate does
something that's slightly different and
in this instance this is a great example
of where you can stand up to the
Whiteboard and actually show what can
actually be done through actually
creating images on the Whiteboard very
quickly little square boxes where you
can actually show the flow for creating
a build environment as an architect this
should be something that you're
comfortable doing and by doing it in the
interview and suddenly you want to ask
permission before you actually do it but
doing this in the interview really helps
demonstrate your comfortable feelings of
working with these kind of architecture
drawings so back to the question of
creating a Docker file so we go through
and that we have a Docker file that
actually then goes ahead and creates the
docker image which then in turns creates
the docker container and then we are
able to push that out up to a Docker Hub
and then share that Docker Hub with
everybody else as part of the docker
registry with the whole network so what
are the differences between Docker image
and Docker containers so let's go
through the docker image so the docker
images are templates of a Docker
container an image is built using a
Docker file and it stores that Docker
file in a Docker repository or a Docker
Hub and you can use Docker Hub as an
example and the image layer is a
read-only file system the docker
container is a collection of the runtime
instances of a Docker image and the
containers are created using Docker
images and they are stored in the docker
Daemon and every container is a layer is
a read write file system so you can't
replace the information you can only
append to it so so one you can actually
use yaml for writing your so a question
you can be asked is instead of yaml what
can be an alternate file to build Docker
compose so yaml is the one that is the
default but you can also use Json so if
you are comfortable working with Json
and my that is something that should be
get comfortable with is you want to be
able to use that to name your files and
it's a frame of reference Json is a
logical way of being able to do value
paired matching using a JavaScript like
syntax
so you're going to be asked to how to
create a Docker container so let's go
through what that would look and we'll
break it down task by task so the task
is going to be create a MySQL Docker
container so to do that you want to be
able to build a Docker image or pull
from an existing Docker image from a
Docker repository or Hub and then you
want to be able to then use Docker to
create a new container which has my SQL
from the existing Docker image
simultaneously the layer of read write
file system is also created on top of
that image now below at the bottom of
the screen we have what the command
lines look for that so what is the
difference between a registry and a
repository so let's go through that so
for the docker registry and repository
for the registry we have Docker registry
Is An Open Source server-side service
used for hosting and distributing Docker
images whereas in contrast for
repositories collection of multiple
versions of a Docker image in a registry
a user can distinguish between Docker
images with their tag names and then
finally on the the registry Docker also
has its own default registry called
Docker hub for the repository it is a
collection of multiple versions of
Docker images it is stored in a Docker
registry and it has two types of public
and private registry so you can actually
create your own Enterprise registry so
you're going to be asked you know what
other Cloud platforms that support
Docker really you know list them all and
we have listed here Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure Google Cloud Rackspace
but you could add in their IBM bluemix
you could put in Red Hat really any of
the cloud service providers out there
today do support Docker it's just become
an industry standard so what is the
purpose of Expose and publish commands
in Docker so if we go through expose is
an instruction used in Docker file
whereas publish is used in Docker run
command for expose it is used to expose
ports within a Docker Network whereas
with Publishers can be used as side of a
Docker environment for expose it is a
documenting instruction used at the time
of building an image and running a
container whereas with published is used
as to map a host port to a running
container port for expose is the command
used in Docker whereas for publish we
use the command Dash p for when we're
doing our command line used in Docker
and examples of these are expose 8080 or
with Docker we would put in all for
publish we would do the example Docker
run Dash Dash p and then
0.0.0.80 colon 80 as our command line so
let's look at continuous monitoring so
with continuous monitoring how does
nagos help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and service and so
this is really just a high level
question of using 9 years within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say
negus allows you to help manage the
servers and check if they've been
sufficient utilized and if there are any
task failures that need to be addressed
and so there are three areas of
utilization and risk that you want to be
able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and if
applications are working properly
together with our web services and apis
that are reachable
so the second question you'll be asked
is how does negus help in continuous
monitoring of systems applications and
services so it's able to do this by
having the initial negative process and
scheduler and the additional plugins
that you would use for your network
connect with the remote resources and
the negative web interface to be able to
run status checks on a predefined
schedule so what do you mean by nagus
remote plugin executor or the mpre of
Nag years so mpre allows you to execute
plugins on links Unix machines that
allow you to do additional monitoring
and machine metrics such as disk usage
CPU load Etc what are the ports used by
nagios for monitoring purposes in this
example there are three and they're easy
to remember so I would memorize these
three but they're essentially ports five
six six five six six seven and five six
six eight so the there are two types of
checks within that year so you will be
asked for what is an active and passive
check in nagios so an active check and
is initiated by the nagios process and
is run on a regular schedule a passive
check is initiated and formed by an
external application or process so this
may be where a system is failing and
checks our results are submitted to
their years for processing and to
continue with this for what is an active
and passive check active checks are
initiated by the check logic within the
nagios Daemon and negus will execute a
plug-in and pass information about what
needs to be checked plugin will then
check the operational state of the host
or service and then process the results
of the host or service check and send
out notifications in contrast with the
passive check it is an external
application that initiates the check it
writes the results of the check to an
external command line file and I guess
reads the external command file and
places the results of all passive checks
in a queue for later processing so you
can go back and revalidate and then
negos may send out notifications log
alerts Etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're going to be asked to explain
the main configuration file and its
location in Nigeria so the main
configuration file consists of a number
of directives that affect how many years
operate so consider this as the
configuration file that it's read by
both now us processor and the cgis so
this will allow you to be able to manage
the main configuration file that's
placed into your settings directory so
what is the netgears network analyzer
and again hold out your four fingers
because there are four options here so
the nagis network analyzer R1 provides
an in-depth look at all your network
traffic source and security threats two
allows system admins to gather high
level information on the healthier
Network Three provides a central view of
your network traffic and bandwidth
dictator and then four allows you to
proactive in resolving outages abnormal
behavior and threats before they affect
critical business processes so what are
the benefits of HTTP and SSL certificate
monitorings with nag years so with HTTP
certificate monitoring it allows you to
have increased server and services and
application availability obviously very
important fast detection of network
outages and protocol failures and allows
web transaction and web service
performance monitoring the SSL
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explain
virtualization with nagios so in
responses the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how nagios itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including Microsoft Visual PC
VMware Zen Amazon ec2 et cetera Etc so
just make sure you get that right off
the bad and I guess it was able to
provide capabilities tomorrow and so
much of metrics on different platforms
it allows for ensure for quick detection
of service and application failures and
has the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including CPU usage
memory networking and VM status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in nagios and it
is name use and register so name is a
template name that can be referenced in
other object definitions use specifies
the name of the template object that you
want to inherit as properties and
variables from and register indicates
whether or not the object definition
should be registered to nagios and on
the right hand side of the screen we
have an example of what that script
would look like again you may want to be
able to memorize this as it's something
that you can achieve write down and show
someone if you're going through a
technical interview so why is nagyo said
to be object r oriented and
fundamentally comes down to the object
configuration format that you can use in
your object definitions it allows you to
inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical
object-oriented development and is now
applied for the nagios environment so
some of the objects that you can inherit
are Services host commands and time
periods so finally explain what is State
talking in nagios and so there are
really four options here when you're
talking about State stalking so State
stocking is used for login purposes in
nagios it allows you to enable for a
particular host or service that nagos
will watch over very carefully it will
lock any changes it sees in the output
of the check results and then finally it
helps the analysis of log files
with that we have reached to the end of
day five so far we have learned the
important development tools of devops on
the day 6 of devops learning week we
will reveal the next stage where you get
to master the most frequently Asked
devops interview questions so stay tuned
and don't miss it thanks for watching
don't forget to subscribe to stay tuned
for more from scently learn